Herzlich willkommen.
Ich habe die Falsch-Taste gedrückt. Die hat mich gerade erschreckt.
Herzlich willkommen, was habe ich gesagt?
Zur Freak-Show Nummer 292.
Oh Mensch, wir müssen uns Gedanken über die 300 machen.
Ja, das erzählen wir aber auch schon seit einem Jahr. Wir könnten einfach mal anfangen.
Ja, wir könnten mal anfangen, uns darüber Gedanken zu machen.
Genau, wir schreiben den, was schreiben wir? 22. Mai.
Oh, morgen ist der 23. Mai. Fällt mir gerade auf. Also 22. Mai 2025.
Und wir sind's. Hallo, ich bin's Tim. Und Roddy ist da. Hallo, Roddy.
Guten Abend.
Und Ralf ist da.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
And this is what you get. Keine Gäste, keine Überraschung. Hier wird alles nach
bewährtem Rezept zubereitet.
Auch keine ehemaligen?
Ne, keine ehemaligen, einfach nur straight unsere Linie.
Manche würden sagen, leider.
Ach, wer würde sowas denn sagen?
Ein bisschen deprimiert, wir müssen ihn noch ein bisschen aufbauen.
Er hatte einen harten Tag.
Das ist ja auch okay. Man kann ja auch mal einen harten Tag haben.
Danke.
Aber immerhin bist du gesund.
Genau, wenigstens etwas.
Ja, das ist doch schon mal ein Schritt nach vorne.
Stimmt, kommt auch nicht so oft vor.
Genau.
Ja, Leute, ich dachte mir, wir fangen heute mal an mit Feedback,
weil Feedback ist immer gut und wir hatten so viel und das ist durchaus,
ich habe auch das Gefühl, man muss sich dazu nochmal äußern zu bestimmten Themen
und nachfragen und so mit den Kommentaren und mit dem Feedback ist das ja so eine Sache.
Da kommen ja auch manchmal so ein paar Spitzen, also manche sind ja auch ganz schön angespitzt.
Manchmal, so bei bestimmten Meinungsäußerungen oder so.
Wie das im Internet so passiert.
Wie das im Internet so ist, ja.
Unter anonymen Namen.
Das wissen wir nicht. Leider heißen die ja wirklich so.
Wahrscheinlich heißen die einfach wirklich Schiffsschraube. Genau.
Man weiß es nicht.
Grüße.
So und ich blicke erstmal hier auf meine Notizen und stelle fest,
ich habe mich hier ein bisschen verformatiert,
das werde ich jetzt mal ganz schnell nochmal korrigieren und weil es so schön
ist und weil ich das irgendwie wichtig finde und weil es auch andere Leute aufgegriffen haben,
möchte ich gerne beginnen mit dem Scheißthema vom letzten Mal.
Das gab viel Feedback.
Genau, also das hat die Leute wirklich in Wallung gebracht und das finde ich
eigentlich auch ganz gut, weil sowas ja auch gedacht.
Also nicht unbedingt, dass ich aufrührerisch wirken wollte, aber ich dachte
mir so, das ist schon so ein Thema, das muss man mal ansprechen.
Und das ist ja auch schwierig so mit dem Fäkalen, das gehört ja nun mal zu unseren
schambehafteten Themen. Genau, zu den Tabuzonen.
Ich finde zu Recht, aber vielleicht ist ein bisschen zu viel Tabu dabei,
das kann natürlich sein.
Zu Recht, warum findest du, dass das zu Recht so ist? Warum ist das Recht?
Naja, ich sag mal so, es ist jetzt auch kein wirklich ein Thema,
was einen so durch den Tag trägt.
Also dich vielleicht schon, aber mich nicht.
Naja, die Befindlichkeiten sind ja sehr ungleich verteilt. Also ich habe es
ja zum Beispiel wiederum mit dem Blut und finde ja dann irgendwie,
dass andere Leute sich darüber so unterhalten. Das finde ich ja ganz furchtbar.
Also naja, ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich jetzt gerne oder viel darüber nachdenke.
Ich finde nur, es ist wichtig, darüber nachzudenken.
Im Prinzip war das ja auch schon der zweite Teil. Der erste Teil,
den hatten wir ja auch schon mal. Und da ging es ja um ganz generelle, allgemeine Fragen.
Sägespäne und anderes Ding.
Ja, und auch irgendwie, wie gehen wir mit unseren ganzen Stoffen so um?
Die bereits gewechselt sind.
Die, aber auch die, die wir so hinzufügen über die Kanalisation und so weiter,
Medikamente, was da alles irgendwie abgeht.
Also wir verbreiten ja sozusagen auch so eine biochemische Grundsuppe in der
Natur von Depressiva und was nicht alles.
Tim Silleri hat mal von LSD im Trinkwasser geträumt und was haben wir jetzt? Antidepressiva,
im Fäkalkanal.
Ja nun.
Ja nun was?
Ja, ist ein Problem.
Haben wir also akzeptiert.
Naja gut, ich meine, dass Medikamente nicht ins Klo gehören.
Naja gut, die Nachricht ist vielleicht noch nicht bei allen angekommen und dann
muss man sich halt darüber unterhalten.
Wie kriegt man den Scheiß da wieder raus? Also nicht den Scheiß,
sondern die Medikamente natürlich.
Genau, aber mir geht es ja gar nicht um die Medikamente, sondern mir geht es ja ums Feedback.
Ich lese mal, was geschrieben wurde. Zum Beispiel kam hier, da ist auch wieder
die Frage, ist das der richtige Name?
Flutschfinger in dem Zusammenhang interessant gewählt, würde ich mal sagen.
Flutschfinger schreibt, bei dem Scheißthema kamen ja ein paar wichtige Punkte zu kurz.
Bei Anschluss an den, also kurzer Rückblick für Leute, die letztes Mal nicht
gut zugehört haben. Wir haben uns ja über Bidetbrausen unterhalten.
Also so eine Art Handdusche in der Nähe des Klos.
Die kann man dann für alles Mögliche verwenden, aber primär ist es natürlich fürs Gesäß.
Oder was man untenrum sonst noch so bestrahlen möchte. Naja, also.
Flutschfinger schreibt, bei Anschluss an den Spülkastenzulauf ist das Wasser
nicht zu kalt, gerade im Winter? An dieser Körperstelle.
Das wurde von mehreren geantwortet, nein.
Ja, und also erstmal scheint die Temperaturempfindlichkeit da nicht so ausgeprägt
zu sein, das ist natürlich eine sehr subjektive Geschichte, da kann ich jetzt
nicht unbedingt für andere sprechen.
Weißt du denn, welcher Körperstelle des Menschen am meisten temperaturempfindlich ist?
Finger? Lippen?
Erste-Hilfe-Kurs? Nicht aufgepasst?
Nee, ich bin ja, wird ja mal ohnmächtig, bevor es wieder kommt.
Der Nacken.
Der Nacken?
Der Nacken des Menschen, ja. Das heißt also, wenn du den Nacken des Menschen,
darum ist ein Schal auch so effektiv.
Wenn also der Nacken eines Menschen warm ist,
strahlt das so quasi aufs Gesamt-Temperaturempfinden des Menschen aus.
Was aber auch tückisch sein kann, wenn nämlich deine Füße schon gerade abfrieren,
aber dein Nacken warm ist, dann kriegst du das auch eventuell zu spät mit.
Von daher Vorsicht bei beheizten, was auch immer, Nackenkissen.
Tod durch Fußballschal sozusagen.
Das kann man auch einfach ausprobieren. Ja, nehmt einen Schal und rubbelt den
mal so links, rechts an eurem Nacken entlang.
Das wird dann sehr schnell sehr wohlig warm im ganzen Körper.
Okay, ich rubbel mal so ein bisschen hier. Rubbeldi, rubbeldi, rubbeldi, rubb.
In den ersten 5 Minuten.
Da muss man so alt werden.
Wenn ihr Leute ärgern wollt und so richtig, also im Sinne von richtig fies ärgern,
dann kannst du noch den Trick machen, dass du einen Eiswürfel nimmst und jemand
anders vorher eine Zigarette zeigst und dann hinter ihm stehst und ihm dann
den Eiswürfel in den Nacken rein drückst.
Lass mich geraten und weil man zwischen heiß und kalt nicht so richtig unterscheiden
kann, sondern nur die Differenz wahrnimmt, denkt man...
Du wirst gerade abgefoltert mit einer Zigarette. Mach das nicht zu Hause, Kinder.
Also sowas, sondern nur in der Schule oder was?
Dinge, an die ich mich aus meinen Erste-Hilfe-Kursen erinnere.
Da haben wir exakt das beigebracht bekommen.
Okay. Das ist interessant, aber ich kann euch versichern, Leute.
Am Arsch ist eigentlich scheißegal. Abgesehen davon, dass die Vorstellung,
dass das Wasser, was so aus dem Wasserhahn kommt, immer eiskalt wäre,
ist ja auch absurd. Also ich meine, das hat man wirklich sehr selten.
Normalerweise die Menge an Wasser, die man dort zum Einsatz bringt,
stand sowieso schon in einem Rohr, was stundenlang irgendwie von einem Haus mitgewärmt wurde.
Also da fallen ja keine Eiswürfel raus, sondern das ist halt einfach unproblematisch.
Bis es richtig kalt wird, muss man schon eine Weile laufen lassen.
Normalerweise hängt, weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es auch Häuser, wo das nicht so ist.
Und ich war gerade tatsächlich in Polen, dazu später mehr,
in so einer Apartment-Wohnung zum Übernachten und dort gab es eine relativ moderne
Wohnungsinstallation und die hatte tatsächlich auch eine BD-Browser am Start,
zu meiner größten Freude. Und nicht nur das.
Die BD-Brause hatte sogar einen eigenen Thermomischer, eine eigene Mischbatterie.
Das heißt, man konnte dort tatsächlich auch Warmwasser wie am normalen Waschbecken
quasi sich zusammenmischen.
Hatte die zwei Rohre Anschluss oder wie?
Offensichtlich.
Okay.
Also den Luxus haben sie sich dann einfach mal geleistet. Ich meine,
das ist so ein Meter vom Waschbecken entfernt gewesen, dann führst du halt auch
nochmal das warme Wasser dort auch noch hin und dann kannst du eben auch warmes
Wasser rauslaufen lassen.
Das allerdings, habe ich ausprobiert, an der Stelle, in die Richtung bin ich
da schon eher empfindlich. Also zu warm ist gar nicht mal so gut.
Kalt ist eigentlich ganz geil.
Naja, schämt ihr euch schon alle, es geht noch weiter.
Flutschfinger führt fort. Achso, den Aspekt hatten wir jetzt.
Eine Heizung, die immer ein Reservoir warm hält, könnte auch zukeimen.
Da hat er recht. Ja, aber da ist ja keine Heizung.
Nein, wenn da eine Heizung wäre.
Ja, aber wenn da ein Warmwasseranschluss ist, dann ist das derselbe wie in deinem
normalen Wasserhahn und der könnte auch zukreimen.
Man nennt es Legionellen und es gibt relativ viele Warmwasserinstallationen,
die Probleme mit Legionellen haben, weil sie das warme Wasser nicht warm genug machen.
Das hatten wir bei uns Anfang des Jahres, bei uns im Haus.
Also es wird auch immer öfter gemessen, deswegen kommen die Einschläge näher.
Aber Legionellen sind ein Problem, also da hat er einen Punkt.
Ja, aber wo kommen die jetzt her?
Wo die genau herkommen, weiß ich nicht, aber sie scheinen in wärmerem Wasser ganz gut zu gedeihen.
Ja, aber das Problem haben wir doch mit jedem warmen Wasser,
das hast du ja dann auch unter der Dusche.
Da ist das Problem auch besonders groß, weil man wohl besonders empfindlich
ist, wenn man die quasi in die Lunge bekommt.
Und dadurch, dass die Dusche so viele Tröpfchen macht und so weiter und Dampf
und so weiter, kann das sein, dass man die einatmet und das ist wohl besonders ungesund.
Deswegen will man halt wirklich gucken, dass man keine Legionellen hat.
Am Arsch sind sie vielleicht nicht so schlimm.
Darum haben wir dann, also das war bei uns im Haushalt mehr Parteienhaus, hier mit alter,
altem Heizkörper halt unten fürs Wasser im Keller, der halt nicht genug auf
Temperatur gekommen ist, weil das ist ein echtes Problem und das haben sie über
Wochen, ich bin versucht zu sagen Monate nicht in den Griff bekommen.
und dann sind wir umgestiegen auf Duschköpfe mit legionellen Fettelter. Die gibt es nämlich.
Und dann kannst du zumindest sicher sein, dass deine Kinder nicht verseucht
werden, weil die sind dann nochmal besonders betroffen.
Kinder und alte Leute, wie immer.
Und diese Filter, die halten dann halt so irgendwie vier Wochen oder sowas.
Vier Wochen?
Das ist aber nicht lange.
Das ist nicht lang. Dann siehst du denen aber auch schon an,
dass da schon irgendwie sonst was durchgesuppt ist und dann musst du wieder auswechseln.
Gibt es aber. Kostet glaube ich so 30 Euro oder sowas.
Das wusste ich nicht, aber na gut.
Also das ist ein leidiges, das nämlich wegzukriegen, ohne eine neue Heizung.
Du darfst unser Chat einen Produktlink hinzufügen. Ja, ich gucke mal, ob ich da was finde.
Das war wirklich sehr leidig.
Aber ich glaube, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man jetzt bei der Po-Reinigung,
während man auf dem Klo sitzt, dann noch einen tiefen Atemzug von dieser Situation,
reinzieht, halte ich für überschaubar.
Ja, ich halte das auch nicht für ein zentrales Problem.
Ich wollte nur sagen.
Prinzipiell hat er recht.
Gut.
Weiter führt er oder sie.
55 Euro, ich dachte, das wäre günstiger gewesen.
Der Finger, der Finger. Der Finger, ja.
Je nach Jahreszeit, jetzt wird es ein bisschen eklig, je nach Jahreszeit,
Gesundheitszustand oder einmaligen speziellen Mahlzeiten kann man unterschiedliche
Konsistenzen feststellen. So, so.
Wer kennt es nicht?
Wer kennt es nicht? Von der Sprühwurst bis zum Kantholz ist alles dabei. Kann man?
Kantholz.
Wie reinigt man die zusätzlichen Artefakte der Sprühanlage selbst,
wenn es mal alles kreuz- und querflucht?
Das bezieht sich jetzt wahrscheinlich auf die Klos, die sozusagen keine separate
Handbrause haben, sondern das irgendwie eingebaut haben.
Da habe ich keine gute, nicht viel Erfahrung, aber ich würde mal sagen,
so eine Handbrause, wenn man die noch zusätzlich hat, ist hervorragend zum Reinigen
vom Klo. Also sowas will man sowieso haben.
Na, also besonders wenn alles kreuz und quer flog. Der Clou der Toilettenschüssel
ist auch der, dass alles glatt und einfach designt ist, damit man es leicht reinigen kann.
Stellt euch vor, in der Sprühdose Sprühdüse hängt sich was fest und starrt euch
dann immer bräunlich unansehlich an.
Man fragt sich, wie es die Japaner überhaupt ins 21. Jahrhundert geschafft haben.
Dass sie nicht alle schon von Legionellen und Sprühwürsten dahin gerafft wurden.
Ja, also ich würde einfach mal sagen, die Praxis es zeigt, dass es alles beherrschbar.
So, jetzt kommen die anderen Detailfragen. Was, wenn genau das einem Besucher
passiert? Oha, ja, naja, Gott.
Der muss ja auch irgendwie sein, ähm, das in den Griff kriegen, ne?
Bekommt ein Sprühstrahl wirklich alles ab? Tja.
Dazu habe ich gleich noch einen passenden Einspieler. Muss man sich nach dem
Sprühstrahl nicht trotzdem abtrocknen?
Das kam übrigens, das kam so oft, das war überhaupt der Trigger,
warum ich mir dachte, da muss ich jetzt echt nochmal drauf einsetzen.
Die Vorstellung, dass wenn man jetzt sozusagen den Po reinigt mit Wasser,
dass das irgendwie dazu führen würde, dass danach der ich weiß gar nicht,
wie man sich das vorstellt, der Po wie so ein nasses Handtuch irgendwie ist und.
Vor Wasser nur so trieft, also das regnet jetzt einfach irgendwie alles ab und
dann kann man halt auch und das ist ja nicht das Ende des Klopapiers,
sondern kann man einfach Ein einzelnes unbeflecktes Blatt aus dieser Klopapierrolle entnehmen.
Ein gut gewähltes.
Ein gut gewähltes, mit einem schönen Muster auch. Das appliziert man dann und
schon hat man sowohl noch Nutzen aus seinen Restbeständen als auch so einen proggenden Hintern.
So trunken war er wahrscheinlich noch nie.
Ein Full House, ein Straight Flush, je nachdem ein gutes Blatt halt.
Jetzt wird es irre. Ist ein Föhn zwingend? Nein.
Toilettenpapier kann man auch zum Ohren- oder Nase-Säubern und so weiter verwenden.
Ist also nicht schlecht. Ich habe auch nicht gesagt, das ist schlecht.
Ich habe nur gesagt, wir verbrauchen unnötig viel davon.
Und es tut nicht das, was es tun sollte.
Und wir können uns einfach mal kurz auch anhören, wie das in Finnland so bewertet
wird, die ganze Situation.
Das klingt dann nämlich so. In Finland, we have.
This thing called käsisuipu, a.k.a.
pussy telephone. This is why we are so happy, because we have so clean,
Rantala from Madventures said one time, if you fall face first in shit,
do you wipe it with paper or do you actually use water as well?
I, for instance, like to use. water.
So that's why I'm so happy. So please.
Start using these. They are very handy, when you have the squirts. Like that.
Das wird erstmal geklärt.
Ja, also ich finde, das ist jetzt irgendwie abschließend geklärt.
Vielen Dank für den Link.
Ich habe es gerade nicht notiert, wer mir das geschickt hat.
Das war auch irgendwo in den Kommentaren. Genau.
Ja, ich will es jetzt gar nicht übertreiben.
Achst du schon.
Ja, dann mach ich weiter. M verweist noch auf das Produkt Happy Po.
Happy Po, was nicht alles gibt. Ja, und ich dachte mir, was kann denn Happy Po sein?
Und Happy Po ist sozusagen, gibt's wirklich, Happy Po ist quasi das Bidet to go.
Also das ist halt einfach im Prinzip wie so eine elektrische Zahnbürste,
bloß da vorne Wasser rauskommt.
Das ist aber nicht elektrisch, oder?
Doch. Oder nicht? Achso, du meinst, das ist nur gepumpt? Das kann sein.
Entschuldigung, ich dachte, das wäre tatsächlich eine elektrische Lösung.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, das ist
eine irgendwie aus Silikon bestehende Flasche, wo man gut drücken kann.
Du hast wahrscheinlich recht.
Okay, ich nehme alles zurück.
Besonders für die 11,99 glaube ich, ist da nichts elektrisches.
Ja, da hast du recht. Aber dafür gibt es das sowohl in Pink als auch in Minze. Dunkelblau.
Ja, wenn es das in Pink gibt, bin ich schon...
Genau, da wird alles nur gedrückt. Entschuldigung, das hatte ich gerade...
Das sah gerade so elektrisch aus, ehrlich gesagt.
Macht sie aber nicht schlechter.
Eher besser.
Genau, und das ist gepumpt und das ist halt dann to go, sozusagen.
Dann hast du es halt auch mal dabei.
Depot to go.
Da ist sozusagen für alles gesorgt, egal wo du jetzt gerade bist.
Sepp fügt dann noch an, der deutsche Begriff für Schataff, ich weiß nicht,
fiel der Begriff bei uns?
Nee.
Ist Bidet, Spritze oder Handbidet? Ein Schataff ist eine Art Handbidet,
die in muslimischen Ländern oft verwendet wird, um sich nach der Toilettennutzung zu reinigen.
Solche Bidet-Spritzen gibt es auch in Finnland, hatten wir gerade in Hotels.
sind diese oft mit dem Waschbecken verbunden und man kann daher auch warmes Wasser nehmen.
Vorsicht, der Anus kann sehr empfindlich auf heiß reagieren, hatten wir gerade.
Im Finnland, und nicht kalt. Kalt ist nicht das Problem, heiß ist das Problem.
Aua, die Vorstellung allein.
Im Finnland hatte ich häufig gesehen, dass jedes Klo auch ein kleines Waschbecken
hatte, an dessen Verrohrung dann die BD-Sprisse angeschlossen war. Genau so. Ja.
Genau, hier hätte ich jetzt eigentlich mein finnisches Video einspielen können,
aber Da habe ich jetzt das Timing ein bisschen.
Aber ich verschone euch jetzt mit weiteren Ausführungen zu diesem Thema.
Ich will nur klar machen, also ich habe wirklich viele begeisterte Kommentare
auch noch so sonst wie bekommen, die aller Meinung sind, das ist the way to go.
Happy Po.
Naja gut, ich finde, es ist ja auch Opt-in.
Wer damit nicht klarkommt, der soll es halt bleiben lassen.
Gilt für viele andere Dinge im Leben auch.
So ein bisschen wie mit Elektromobilität.
Ja.
Genau. Gibt halt ein paar Leute, die wollen halt weiterhin schmieren.
Kommen wir zum anderen Thema.
LLM als Support. Das war nochmal gleich der Bereich, den wir da bejammert haben, dieser Vorfall.
Von Cursor.
Genau, von Cursor.
Eine Freundin, JSN schreibt, eine Freundin arbeitet bei einer weltbekannten
Fintech-Bude, hat mir gerade erzählt, dass derzeit 70% der Support-Tickets von
einem LLM beantwortet werden. 70.
Und die Mitarbeiter nutzen das Tool intern auch, weil die Anfragen teilweise
sehr komplex sind bei Produkten wie Futures, Hebeloptionen etc.
Die machen Copy und Paste. Die LLM hat Zugang zu den Nutzerdaten und Transaktionen
und kann solche Anfragen dann gut beantworten.
What could possibly go wrong?
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe gerade bei solchen Support-Anfragen,
man muss es ja fast überall benutzen.
Also es ist ja die totale Seuche mit diesen ganzen Chats, die dann auch alle
noch so komische Namen haben. Frag doch Fred!
Aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, LLM hat Zugang zu den Nutzerdaten und Transaktionen, schreibt er da.
What could possibly go wrong?
Ja, everything could possibly go wrong.
Also das ist so, na gut, Fintech.
Aber ich meine, der Punkt ist schon, wir wissen ja alle, dass die LLMs nicht ohne Qualität sind.
Also die können bestimmte Dinge sehr viel besser.
Also du kannst halt mal eben die komplette Transaktionshistorie reinsaugen und
wenn das Ding gut drauf trainiert ist, dann können da sehr viele solidere Schlüsse
daraus gezogen werden, zumindest als generelle Einschätzung.
Nur meistens ist es mit diesen Detailproblemen immer so,
dass da genau eine Sache konkret scheiße läuft und die wird halt bei solchen
Summarizer-Ansätzen oft auch übersehen oder halt komplett falsch interpretiert
oder genau andersrum, als es halt eigentlich ist und da wird es dann immer schwierig.
Und ich finde, Support muss ja manchmal ein spezifisches Problem lösen und für
die spezifischen Probleme sind die Dinger nicht so gut, aber für die allgemeinen
Anfragen mit Sicherheit ganz tauglich.
Ich wäre jetzt eher so auf dem Ding, dass du halt eine Prompt Injection machen
könntest, theoretisch.
Also ist das LLM, was da läuft, gut genug dagegen geschützt,
dass jemand halt nicht nur die Daten, zu denen er eigentlich Zugriff haben sollte,
sondern auch zu anderen Daten über das LLM bekommt.
Also ich habe mich selber an Prompt Injection versucht, bin nicht besonders
weit gekommen aber gut, das ist vielleicht auch irgendwie, aber,
Es gibt die Möglichkeit, irgendwie eine LLM-Daten zu entlocken,
die sie eigentlich nicht Lust freigeben soll. Also das ist so.
Ja.
Insofern sage ich, dass die LLM hat Zugang zu den Nutzerdaten und Transaktionen.
Wenn die das richtig machen und sie hat nur Zugang zu dem Nutzer,
der gerade authentifiziert ist, okay, dann mag das seine Berechtigung haben.
Du verstehe ich das hier auch nicht.
Ja, das wird jetzt nicht in die Trainingsdaten einfließen.
Nee, das auch nicht.
Aber klar, du könntest über eine Prompt Injection dir theoretisch ja auch Zugang
auf einen anderen Account irgendwie erschleichen.
Richtig, richtig, das meine ich.
Das eine oder andere ist ja schon durchaus denkbar.
Ja, klar. Da muss dann natürlich das System entsprechend designt sein,
dass das gar nicht erst möglich ist.
Gut, dann gab es noch einen Hinweis hier zu Batterien. Ich hatte ja behauptet,
dass die Teslas auch alle noch mit Bleisäure-Akkus rumstehen.
Es stellt sich raus, ich habe keine Ahnung von dem Scheiß.
Sollte besser das Maul halten. Tesla verbaut seit 2022 keine Bleisäure-Starter-Batterien
mehr, sondern Lithium-Ionen-Batterien.
Was auch sinnvoll ist, weil Bleisäure-Batterien ihre Stärke bei Anlassern haben
und nicht bei sonstiger Bordelektronik.
Und es ist auch ein logischer Schritt, weil wahrscheinlich so ein Tesla sowieso
auch nicht so eine dicke Bleisäure-Batterie braucht, sondern mit einer kleineren
Lithium-Ionen-Batterie wahrscheinlich sowieso besser fährt.
Ähnliches dürfte für andere Elektroautos gelten.
So, wollen wir beim Autothema wären und jetzt kommt die Mercedes Schlüssel Story.
Magst du vielleicht den Kommentar von Nick hier kurz aufgreifen?
Der ist sehr, sehr lang.
Ja, wir können ja so Absatz für Absatz aufgreifen, aber wenn du schon mal anfängst
vorzulesen, ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, Nick Stohn schreibt, Als Fahrer einer A-Klasse W169, dem kleinen Bruder des besagten B-Elchs,
muss ich, glaube ich, ein wenig Klarheit in die ganzen Spekulationen rund um
Schlüsselthematik bringen.
Na, dann mal los.
Die Kamera im Rückspiegel, die im verlinkten Motor Talk Beitrag erwähnt wird,
ist nur eine einfache Fotozelle, die für das Abdunkeln des Rückspiegels bei
Blendung zuständig ist.
Der Abgleich zwischen Steuergerät und Schlüssel, um den Rollcode wieder in den
richtigen Takt zu bringen, darüber hatten wir ja gesprochen,
passiert nur über das Zündschloss, wo sich entsprechend das Gegenstück zum Infrarotfenster
des Schlüssels befindet.
Er sagt eigentlich sollte das nicht funktionieren oder was sagt er?
Ja, im Kern glaube ich schon. Also wir erinnern uns, ich hatte ja glaube ich
fünf Szenarien vorgelesen.
Ungefähr, ja.
Irgendwie sowas mit dem Dreh. In den Kommentaren sind jetzt noch mal mindestens
fünf andere Varianten übrigens auch noch mal erwähnt worden.
Also es bleibt schon so ein bisschen Voodoo. Aber es mag natürlich sein,
dass die Variante, die dann bei mir geklappt hat,
nicht dadurch klappte, dass ich sie vorher auch einmal an den Rückspiegel gehalten
hatte, wie diese Variante empfohlen hat, sondern dann quasi eben die Prozesse
danach im Schloss, die eigentlich entscheidenden waren.
Das kann ich natürlich nicht nachvollziehen. Das kann schon gut sein.
Was natürlich auch sein kann, ist, dass die auch innerhalb einer Baureihe einen
Rolling Change gemacht haben und dass tatsächlich sein Auto halt anders funktioniert
als deins. Das kann durchaus sein.
Auch das ist denkbar. So, bei dem nächsten wird er, denke ich,
mit Sicherheit recht haben, nämlich das Öffnen und Schließen passiert seit den
2000ern ausschließlich über Funk.
Die ersten modernen Schlüssel Mitte der 90er sprachen noch über Infrarot.
Da gab es entsprechende Empfänger an der Unterseite der Rückspiegel,
also generell schon richtige Location.
Und neben den Notschlössern am Heckdeck und der vorderen Türrand.
Stimmt, ich bin irgendwann mal durchs Heckdeck in mein Auto auch rein,
als alles andere kaputt war. Das war aber ein anderes Auto.
Diese wurden dann aber bereits mit den 98er S-Klasse Baureihe 220,
also hier ist jemand, der sich auskennt,
zumindest in diesem Mercedes-Universum, durch die neuen Schlüsseltypen abgelöst,
die wir bei unseren Elchen ohne klappbaren Schlüsselbart auskommen.
Wissen die eigentlich die Jüngeren noch, was mit den Elchen gemeint ist?
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob wir Jüngere überhaupt hier noch zuhören.
Sind wir die Jüngeren schon? Nein, eigentlich nicht, aber wissen es auch nicht.
Du darfst das gerne nochmal aufbringen.
Du weißt es aber, oder?
Nein.
Was hier gemeint ist, der Elchtest?
Der A-Klasse.
Der Elchtest der A-Klasse, ja, den, ja.
Die A-Klasse, also Hintergrund, die A-Klasse wurde irgendwann mal vorgestellt, das war 90er Jahre?
Ich glaube, müsste 90er gewesen sein.
Ich tippe auch, das ist ein typisches 90er-Jahre-Produkt. Die A-Klasse bei Mercedes,
das war quasi das erste kleine Auto von Mercedes.
Und wir stellen fest, dass es 1997 auf den Markt kam.
Und dann werden ja mal so diverse Sicherheitstests durchgeführt.
Unter anderem der Elchtest. Und der Elchtest ist im Wesentlichen die Situation,
dass ein Elch auf die Straße gelaufen kommt und das Auto muss dem aufweichen.
Und ausweichen konnte das Fahrzeug?
Sehr erfolgreich. Dem Elch ist nichts passiert.
Aber der Rückspiegel war kaputt. in this process?
Nein, Dinge passierten, weil die A-Klasse ist ja schon besonders von der Konstruktion,
zumindest damals gewesen, weil es nämlich in der sogenannten Sandwich-Bauart gebaut wurde.
Das heißt, der Motor war nicht vollständig irgendwie vorne wie beim normalen
Auto, sondern zumindest Komponenten und Teile davon waren nach unten verbaut.
Das heißt, die A-Klasse ist viel höher gewesen als ein anderes Mittelklasse-Auto
in der Form und das führte aber natürlich dann auch zu einem nach oben verlagerten Schwerpunkt.
Und dann hat halt diese hektische Links-Rechts-Ausweich-Bewegung dazu geführt,
dass diese arme A-Klasse umgekippt ist. Da gibt es ja bestimmt 13 Millionen YouTubes-Videos zu.
Und das sieht natürlich dann schon sehr traurig aus, wenn einfach so ein Auto,
nur weil es ausgewichen ist, plötzlich so auf der Seite liegt.
Elchtest. So und dann seit...
Ja, der Chat ist schon... Genau.
Ja, stimmt, die A-Klasse. Ja.
Das war für die wirklich ein Problem, ja, also dass das Ding irgendwie da fast
umgekippt ist, das war einfach nicht geil für Mercedes, das ist so schnell nicht los geworden.
Das haben sie dann, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne, auch nur durch Elektronik
behoben, zumindest bei der ersten Baureihe.
Otto war ja immer so, wie es war und dann haben sie halt irgendwie ABS,
was auch immer, halt schärfer eingestellt und weniger dynamisch und weniger
sportlich und bist du dann in den darauffolgenden Modell rein.
Dass dann… Aber wenn ich das richtig in der Renauung habe, war das ursprünglich
mal von irgendwelcher schwedischen Presse irgendwie lanciert worden.
Und die machen das wohl immer noch und gerade amerikanische Autos schneiden
da wohl gerne mal schlecht ab.
Naja, auf jeden Fall.
Deshalb wird jetzt der liebevoll von Elchen.
Von Elchen gesprochen, genau. Also die kleinen, die A-Klasse, B-Klasse und so weiter.
Aber der klappbare Schlüsselbart ist dann irgendwie weg. Jetzt gucke ich gerade,
ist der Rest des Kommentars eigentlich noch relevant?
Also hier den Pro-Tipp würde ich nochmal vorlesen, weil das zeigt,
in was für einer Welt wir hier unterwegs sind.
Pro-Tipp bei der Gelegenheit. Falls der Schlüssel mal gar nicht will und man
das Fahrzeug abschließen muss, Beide fahrerseitigen Türen öffnen,
Schlüssel ins Zünnschloss stecken, Fahrzeug manuell über die Tasten der Türinnentafel
links abschließen, Schlüssel ziehen und Fahrertür schließen,
über die Fonttür an der Fahrerseite den hochgesprungenen Schließstift wieder
runterdrücken und dann die Fonttür schließen.
Sie müssen nur den Nippel durch die Lasche ziehen, an der kleinen Kurve ganz nach oben drehen.
Was er jetzt nicht so genau sagt, ist, man muss da einmal quer durchs Auto turnen, um das zu machen?
Nee, dachte ich auch zuerst. Man muss nur rechtzeitig Schlüssel abziehen und
dann kann man auch wieder raus.
Also man muss jetzt nicht durchs Auto durch. Nichts richtig verstanden habe.
Jetzt über die Fronttür an der Fahrerseite.
Früher war alles einfacher.
Das ist auf jeden Fall so der Konami-Code für Türschlüsse öffnen.
Holla.
Naja.
Genau. Volkmar hatte dann auch noch einen ähnlichen Kommentar hier Mercedes-Benz
E-Klasse. Das scheint so ein richtiges Thema zu sein.
Hier funktionierte mein Schlüssel auch nicht mehr. Dachte, die Platine ist endgültig
kaputt, da neue Batterie schon ein paar Wochen, nach ein paar Wochen gewechselt werden musste.
Lösung 4. Bei Ebay nach neuem Schlüssel gesucht. 30 Euro im Netz.
Nach anderen Möglichkeiten Anlernmöglichkeiten gesucht. Entschuldigung.
Das war mir alles zu spooky. Mein Schrauber gefragt, ob er den anlernen kann, negativ.
Im Internet-Profi in meiner Nähe, in Klammern 100 Kilometer gefunden,
der behauptet, alles für 200 Euro anlernen zu können, Absage bekommen.
Habe ich dann nicht gemacht. Lösung 0, zum Mercedes gelaufenen neuen Schlüssel
für ca. 500 Euro gekauft.
Der Schlüssel kam dann auch mit fertigen Hardware-Notschlüssel.
Lösung 5, nach deinem Beitrag, deinem Beitrag Ralf, habe ich den defekten Schlüssel
nochmal mit Batterie bestückt und er geht.
Ich werde wahnsinnig ohne anlernen. der geht. Jetzt habe ich drei Schlüssel. Das ist der Wahn.
Tja, mein Beileid folgt mal.
Ja, so ist das.
Ja, dann habe ich noch ganz viel Feedback bekommen zu meiner Auslassung zum
Thema, man müsste ja mal was mit 3D machen und das Lustige ist,
ich habe tatsächlich in der Zwischenzeit was mit 3D gemacht.
Zu meinem vollkommenen Überraschung eigentlich was ganz anderes,
weil ich nämlich das erste Mal in meinem Leben dann wirklich diesen Moment hatte
mit oh scheiße, da ist jetzt ein Plastikstück mit einer komischen Form kaputt gegangen.
Was ich aber unbedingt brauche, um die Funktion eines viel teureren Gerätes,
in dem Fall eine Dunstabzugshaube, sicherzustellen.
Das ist so eine Dunstabzugshaube, wo man so die Abzugsklappe,
also die sozusagen diese ganzen Filterkram beinhaltet, so nach unten lösen muss.
Und die Klappe hält eigentlich nur, weil sie so durch zwei Plaste nippelt,
die man so um 90 Grad dreht, so links und rechts sich festhält.
und der eine davon war porös und ist gebrochen und es war so ein kompliziertes.
Zweiteiliges System, wo man den einen Nippel in den anderen so reindrehen und
reinploppen lassen musste.
In meiner ganzen Verzweiflung bin ich dann zum dachte ich mir so,
das wäre doch mal jetzt was für ein 3D-Drucker, jetzt ist vielleicht der Moment gekommen.
Ich habe natürlich keine, ich habe auch keine Ahnung von 3D,
ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung von CAD gehabt an sich.
Ich habe noch nie ernsthaft ein CAD-Programm benutzt in meinem Leben.
Bin dann ins X-Hein gerannt, gleich irgendwie auf einen netten Nerd getroffen,
der sich dankenswerterweise sofort meines Problems stundenlang angenommen hat
und dann saßen wir dort und haben gemeinsam dieses Teil nachgebaut in FreeCut.
FreeCut ist quasi so das Gimp des CAD.
Es ist eher das VI des CAD.
Man könnte aber auch sagen, Gimp ist das VI des Photoshop. Also ich will gar
nicht Schlechtes sagen über FreeCuts, die üblichen Cross-Plattform-Probleme
mit User-Interface und so weiter.
Aber was ich sehr viel beeindruckender fand, ist die Denke, wie man in CAD überhaupt
baut. Also das war mir bis dahin noch komplett nicht bekannt,
also die Logik, die man überhaupt walten lassen muss.
Also du denkst da in Flächen, die extrudieren,
die in andere hinein, da was heraus subtrahieren,
das ist mehr so ein mathematisches Ding und tatsächlich hatten wir nach ein
paar Stunden also ein fast funktionsfähiges Teil da auch aus dem Drucker dann
entnommen, das kam dann aus so einem Prusa 3D-Drucker heraus.
Und es hätte wahrscheinlich auch alles perfekt funktioniert,
während ich im letzten Durchlauf so eine Subtraktionskugel so einen Millimeter zu groß geraten,
sodass die Software in dem Moment noch so Stützstege da innen reingemacht hat,
die ich dann nicht manuell rausbekam und dann habe ich das irgendwie rausgebohrt
und dann war das Loch aber zu groß und dann hat dieser Schnappmechanismus nicht funktioniert.
Wie groß war denn das Teil?
Relativ klein.
Wie habt ihr da die Maße genommen?
Mit einem,
elektronischen Schieberrigger.
Genau.
Und es musste jetzt nicht unbedingt alles auf 0,1 Millimeter genau sein.
Schon so auf Millimeter, würde ich sagen. Und das ging so.
Aber sehr viel mehr Gedankenschmalz musste eigentlich investiert werden in diese intrinsische Logik.
Von woher baut man das Ding auf und so.
Ich wäre komplett gescheitert, wenn ich das alleine probiert hätte.
Da wird man doch eigentlich auch erwarten, dass das doch mittlerweile mit so,
3D-Kamera im iPhone verbaut.
Man filmt es mal von allen Seiten und dann wird schon mal eine Leerung gemacht
und dann muss man nur noch dagegen kutschen und optimieren.
Das dachte ich am Anfang auch, dass es so eine reine wie sieht das von außen
aus Nummer ist. Aber hier war auch entscheidend, wie sieht das von innen aus.
Und da hätte dir diese 3D-Kamera genau überhaupt nicht geholfen,
weil das eine Teil, was ich in das andere reinstecke, das hat so eine Verdickung,
und quasi das Weibchen, was ich so eigentlich modelliert habe,
muss dann quasi so ein Loch haben, was so gerade nur ein kleines bisschen enger
ist, dass wenn man es da reinsteckt, dass es so richtig so rein snappt und sich dadurch festhält.
Und dieser Snap-Effekt war am Ende dann zu gering, sodass, als ich das dann
installiert habe, die Dunstabzugshaube, dieser Deckel, das dann immer noch auseinandergerissen hat.
Ich habe versucht zu verkleben und so weiter, auch wieder alles nicht funktioniert,
weil ich wahrscheinlich den richtigen Klebstoff gehabt habe.
Anyway, ich werde bei Gelegenheit noch mal refinen, das noch mal ausprobieren
und vielleicht dann hier auch Vollzug melden können. Fand ich auf jeden Fall sehr interessant.
Ich bringe auf jeden Fall mal mit das Teil.
Ja, da habe ich jetzt leider nicht dran gedacht.
Aber insofern mit FreeCut kann man offensichtlich schon irgendwie arbeiten.
Man muss diese Software dann so ein bisschen kennenlernen und die Quirks und
so weiter und die Logik und vor allem auch die Sprache, also die Begriffswelt quasi verstehen.
Insofern war das ganz interessant. Ich hatte aber auch noch einen anderen Neben-3D-Ausflug,
der sich eher zufällig ergeben hat, weil ich festgestellt habe,
dass es mittlerweile MCP-Server gibt für Blender.
Wurde auch in den Kommentaren nochmal erwähnt, hatte ich aber vorher schon entdeckt,
habe ich auch mal ein bisschen mit rumgespielt.
Und auch hier wie beim Programmieren mit AI, wenn man keine Ahnung hat von dem,
was man da benutzt, hilft einem AI auch nur begrenzt. ja.
Trotzdem habe ich es geschafft, das zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Also das zum Laufen zu bekommen ist auch nicht so schwierig.
Du musst halt so ein Python-Plugin in Blender starten, dann macht der einen
Server auf, einen MCP-Server, der dann quasi die interne Funktionalität von
Blender eben über dieses MCP-Protokoll.
Bereitstellt.
Dann sagst du halt dem Desktop-Client, den du verwendest, in dem Fall habe ich
Claude von Anthropic verwendet, gesagt so, ja hier, MCP-Server, kennst du, ne?
Kannte er dann auch und dann habe ich so, dachte ich mir so,
okay, was ist so das grundlegendste 3D-Ding, was du so kennst und dann habe
ich gesagt, ja okay, mach doch mal ein Rubik's Cube hier in Blender.
Und dann macht es so pop, pop, pop und irgendwie eine Millisekunde später sind da so,
dreimal drei Würfel vor meinen Augen und sieht schon so ein bisschen sieht schon
so ein bisschen Rubik's Cube mäßig aus und dann habe ich noch gesagt Ja,
kannst du dir auch mal die typischen Rubikskub-Farben geben?
Und dann hat er das halt auch die Farben an der richtigen Stelle.
Das hat alles super funktioniert. Dann dachte ich so, ja, okay,
jetzt gehst du mal hier auf die 12.
Und hab dann irgendwie versucht, so, ja, jetzt will ich das aber auch irgendwie,
wie kann ich das machen, dass sich das auch bewegt und animieren lässt,
wie ein Rubik's Cube, ne, mit den Seiten.
Und man hat, ja, eigentlich kein Problem, musst du halt dann immer nur temporär
gruppieren und dann gemeinsam die Gruppe rotieren und so.
Aber dann ist das irgendwie mit Python-Skripten, die dann erstellt werden,
da wurde es dann irgendwie schnell kompliziert, da hab ich dann irgendwie gegen die Wand gefahren.
Aber es war so, okay, funktioniert grundsätzlich, Aber es ist halt nochmal eine
ganz andere Welt als diese Cut-Welt.
Also Cut und Bauen und Konstruieren ist nochmal anders als das,
was Blender macht, zumindest soweit ich das verstanden habe.
Aber naja, okay, war auf jeden Fall alles ganz interessant.
und letzter 3D-Teil, weil das, was ich ja eigentlich wollte,
ist ja so für, wir machen ja so Lichtinstallationen und dann ging es ja so da
drum, okay, wenn man das jetzt so in die Welt stellt, wie sieht das eigentlich aus?
Welche Abstände sind die richtigen Größen?
Wie kann man sich das räumlich vorstellen in so einem Large Scale?
Und mit der Intention, dass wenn man es in 3D modelliert, dass man es dann vielleicht
eben auch mit der Apple Vision Pro sich angucken kann.
Und naja, da gibt es jetzt noch nicht viel zu vermelden, aber was jetzt wohl
der Kandidat ist, ist tatsächlich was relativ Einfaches, nämlich ein JavaScript-Framework,
das nennt sich 3.js, also 3.js.
Ja, Punkt.js heißen sie alle.
Ja, also was das sozusagen macht, ist glaube ich relativ klar.
Das ist halt ein System, in dem du eine 3D-Szene beschreiben kannst und die
rendert dann halt quasi in Echtzeit immer zwei Bilder und das kann man dann in diesem Web.
XR oder WebAR Format in eine Webseite packen und in der Theorie sollte so eine
Apple Vision Pro in der Lage sein,
sich dann dieser Seite zu bemächtigen und die dann eben auch wirklich dreidimensional anzuzeigen.
Ich habe mit so ein paar Beispielen rumgeprobiert und mit ein paar Beispielen
geht es und mit ein paar Beispielen geht es nicht und ich habe noch nicht so
ganz verstanden, was, wann es nicht geht und wann es geht.
Ich glaube, die Web XR haben nicht funktioniert und die Web AR haben funktioniert oder so.
Aber ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo da wirklich der nennenswerte technische Unterschied
ist oder ob da nur ein Bug in den Examples war oder ein Bug in der Apple Vision Pro ist.
Aber das werden wir uns auf jeden
Fall noch mal ein bisschen anschauen und vielleicht klappt das ja auch.
Aber da tut sich auf jeden Fall ein bisschen was und vielleicht noch so hinterher,
ich bin auch gerade so ein bisschen dabei, meine Meinung über 3D zu ändern.
Also Was war denn deine bisherige Meinung?
Naja Ungefähr so wie zu Computerspielen würde ich sagen.
Na Also Man ist ja, also abgesehen von der echten Welt ist man ja 3D jetzt nicht
so viel in der Medienausspielung jetzt nicht so viel,
begegnet man dem ja nicht so oft sondern es gab eigentlich nur 3D Kinos und
es gab halt dieses Brillen bisher und die Brillen bisher waren mir einfach visuell
war mir einfach zu unattraktiv mit diesem Unterhabenmuster.
Spiele in 3D gehören da jetzt nicht zur Medienausspielung bei dir?
Naja, die Spiele finden ja auch nur auf diesen Brillen statt,
die diese schlechte Auflösung haben und diese schlechte Auflösung fand ich halt einfach Ja.
Oder auf Monitoren, die eine große Auflösung haben.
Ja, auf Monitoren ist es ja nicht dreidimensional. Ich rede jetzt von wirklich,
ich nehme das dreidimensional wahr.
Also über eine echte, nicht ein 3D-Objekt auf 2D wird mir angezeigt ist,
darum rede ich nicht, sondern ich rede jetzt von, wann ist es wirklich ein Gewinn,
ein Zugewinn, dass es dreidimensional auch konkret perzipiert werden kann,
versus es ist einfach nur bei 2D und bei Filmen.
Also du gehst jetzt auf maximale Immersion.
Ja, Immersion ist ja nochmal ein anderer Aspekt. Ja, also Immersion heißt ja,
du bist in 180 oder 360 Grad Environments und egal wo du hinschaust,
hast du quasi die Welt. Das ist das, was Immersive meint.
Kann man so definieren? Kann man auch anders definieren?
Nee, kann man nicht. 3D ist jetzt nicht per se Immersion. 3D ist ja auch,
wenn du so ein 3D-Objekt hier einfach in AR einfach hier im Raum schweben lässt
sozusagen, während du sonst alles genauso weißt.
Immersion ist schon, wenn du dich in dieser Welt fühlst, aber das kannst du natürlich Okay.
Egal. Es spielt jetzt auch keine Rolle. Was ich nur sagen möchte ist,
meine primäre Wahrnehmung waren halt diese anderen Brillen und Kino.
Das waren eigentlich die einzigen Orte, wo mir in irgendeiner Form 3D-Szenen
über Medium dargereicht wurde.
Und weder im Kino noch auf diesen normalen Brillen hat mich das irgendwie nennenswert
überzeugt und ich war speziell immer von den Filmen nicht begeistert,
weil mir das Ganze immer so layered vorkam.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es auch so geht und es ist auch, glaube ich,
in den meisten Filmen so gemacht,
also dass die so Post-Production-mäßig erst so 3D-fiziert werden,
da habe ich nicht wirklich den Einblick, aber mir war das einfach zu wenig und
mich hat das im Kino eher gestört.
Also mir hat das im Kino nicht genug gebracht, als dass ich sagen würde,
das habe ich jetzt mehr erlebt, als ich jetzt den 2D-Film erlebt habe.
Weil unser Hirn leistet genug für, wie wir das wahrnehmen wollen.
Und wir haben uns alle schon in 2D-Filmen komplett verlieren können.
Da war jetzt 3D nicht unbedingt erforderlich. Da arbeitet der Film an sich erstmal
mit den Bildern und ganz unabhängig davon, ob er 2D wird.
Vor allen Dingen, das ist halt auch ein Problem der Parallaxe.
Also du musst ja, damit du eine echte 3D-Sicht hast, müssen die zwei Augen ja
unterschiedliche Dinge sehen.
Das können sie ab einer bestimmten Entfernung aber nicht mehr,
weil der Winkel zwischen den Augen so gering ist, dass es sowieso alles flach ist.
Und also ich finde gerade im Kino, wo man sowieso...
Und mehrere, viele Meter weit von der Leinwand entfernt sitzt,
hast du dann immer so das Gefühl, du bist in so einer Welt, alles ist flach
und plötzlich ragt irgendwas aus dem Bildschirm raus.
Dann, ob das jetzt irgendwie die Ecke vom Flügel, vom Raumschiff ist oder weiß
ich nicht, irgendeine Fresse von irgendjemandem oder so.
Und ich fand das immer, also erstens ein sehr platten Effekt und zweitens eher
unangenehm als etwas, was mir einen Mehrwert bietet.
Also wie der Chat hier richtig streibt, Steffen Gerdes ist leider wahr,
richtig in 3D gedrehte Filme wie Avatar sind leider die Ausnahme und sehen auch deutlich besser aus.
Das stimmt grundsätzlich, das heißt also wir können unterscheiden zwischen welche,
die wirklich stereoskop mit zwei Kameras aufgezeichnet sind,
ja dann ist immer noch, wie du sagst schon, der Augenabstand ein Problem,
dass das trotzdem noch realistisch ist, versus das, was in der Post-Production
dann halt 3D reingerechnet wird.
Was ständig immer besser wird, aber was halt trotzdem nicht wie das Original ist.
Wir erinnern uns auch an die Sendung, wo ich das hier mit dem Standbilder in 3D umrechnen habe.
Der Punkt ist aber, und da bin ich jetzt quasi mittlerweile fast noch extremer
als bei Tim, das klassische Beispiel dafür, wo das richtig gegen die Wand gefahren
ist, ist die Hobbit-Trilogie von Peter Jackson.
So, wir erinnern uns, Herr der Ringe, alles super, ewiges Meisterwerk,
zig Oscars, erfolgreichste Filme, jada jada.
So, und dann hat er die Hobbit-Trilogie hintereinander gelegt und wollte technisch
nochmal so ein richtiges Fund draufsetzen.
Und er hat zwei Sachen gemacht, zum einen wirklich ganz super sauberes 3D,
so alles mit so einer Dual-Kamera abgefilmt und zum anderen hat er 60 Hertz gefilmt.
Das heißt also nicht wie im Kino üblich 24 Bilder pro Sekunde oder 30,
sondern quasi doppelte Frame-Rates, so wie beim Shooter, damit das alles schön
flüssig ist. So und das führte dann aber dazu.
Shooter nicht unter 120.
Das führte im Kino dazu. Es war 3D, es war super flüssig. Das sah aus wie Fernsehen.
weil also die Psychologie, dass ich sitze im Kino und gucke da jetzt etwas,
das war so fremd und so störend, dass man da saß und dachte so,
was ist das für ein scheiß Film hier.
Das ist etwas, was ich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann mehr FPS, mehr gut,
und dass man bisher die technische Limitierung hatte, dass man nur 24 Frames
auf die Screen kriegt, dass man die mal bricht und mal ein bisschen flüssigere Animationen hat.
Also ganz ehrlich, dieses Jammer kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. So gar nicht.
Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, ich hatte das sogar schon mal hier in der Sendung.
Ich habe vor ein paar Jahren mal so einen
Artikel gelesen von irgendeinem Filmkünstler, der das propagiert hat.
Leute, schaut euch den Hobbit einfach mal in der Standard 2D 24 Frames Per Second
Version an. Das kann man nämlich einstellen auf der Blu-Ray,
welche Version du guckst.
Und plötzlich ist das ein sehr viel besserer Film. Das heißt also all das,
was einen vorher ständig irgendwie so irritiert und warum sieht das so komisch
aus und die Action-Sequenzen wirken auch irgendwie alle so ganz sonderbar.
Und plötzlich denkst du so, der Film ist gar nicht so viel schlechter als Herr der Ringe.
So, kann man machen. Also von daher da draußen, wenn ihr auch,
wie ich, traumatisiert dann nur im Kino die Version habt, guckt euch mal vor
allem die Special Edition an.
Insbesondere die Endschlacht im dritten Teil. Die ist spektakulär gut.
Da haben sie nämlich noch 20 Minuten Bonusmaterial reingeschnitten,
das vorher nicht drin war.
Und da gibt es fantastische Schlachtensequenzen.
Traumatisiert.
Also wer auf Fantasy-Schlachten steht, das ist schon ein echter Goldstandard.
Aber jetzt.
Aber der Hobbit war 3D, oder was?
Der Hobbit war 3D, genau, 60 Hertz.
Auch mit 3D-Kameras.
Mit 3D-Kameras, genau. Und das war einfach eine Scheißidee. Und derselbe Film
in 2D24 sieht sehr viel besser aus und funktioniert als Film komplett anders, psychologisch.
Und von daher, wir hatten ja hier, als wir die letztes oder vorletztes Mal auch
die Vision wieder besprochen hatten, dieser U-Boot-Film, hast du den mittlerweile gesehen?
Der jetzt bei Apple TV drin ist. Alles gesehen, was da jetzt zu sehen war.
Das ist ja, würde ich sagen, vom 3D-Effekt her der am künstlerischen wertvollste,
wo es jetzt nicht irgendwie um Action geht, sondern schon auch so,
wie ist die Bildkomposition und ähnliches.
Aber dieses 60-Hertz-Problem bringt der halt auch wieder mit.
Das heißt also, du bist dann zwar so, denkst dann, du bist jetzt in dem U-Boot,
aber du denkst halt nicht, du bist in einem künstlerischen Film.
Das heißt also, da muss die Generation nach uns noch diesen Sprung machen zwischen
Kino ist halt leicht ruckelig und Shutter, Unschärfe 24 Frames per Second versus 60.
Ja, interessant. Also ich werde nochmal da ein bisschen mehr schauen zu meiner Überraschung.
Also ich habe einfach mit der Apple Vision Pro merke ich einfach, dass das,
mehr auf einen zurollt.
Während du noch nachdenkst, Steffen schreibt gerade bei 48 Hertz,
also das Doppelte von 24. Das klingt plausibel.
Hat aber denselben Effekt.
Ja, wirkt dann einfach zu echt, ne? Kann man sagen.
Oder? Würdest du das so beschreiben? Zu echt? Zu videomäßig?
Zu Video. Es wirkt halt wie so eine Soap-Opera und nicht mehr wie ein monumentales Fantasy-Epod.
Aber vielleicht ist das ja auch nur ein Gewöhnungsding.
Das hat Peter Jackson dann behauptet. So Leute, ihr müsst euch daran gewöhnen
und in zehn Jahren ist das der totale Mainstream und dann werdet ihr diesen
Film völlig anders sehen.
Der hat das also sehr energisch vertreten.
Das war auch damals ähnlich wie Avatar, so eine Geschichte, so jetzt müssen
die Kinos für diesen Film dann jetzt nochmal auf 48 Hertz aufrüsten und so weiter.
Aber ich würde mal hier und heute behaupten, bis heute hat sich das nicht ansatzweise
durchgesetzt. Ich weiß gar nicht, der letzte Avatar, Avatar 2,
weiß jemand in welcher Bildrate der im Kino war?
Der war High Frame Rate, sagt zumindest Chat-GPT.
Ah, okay.
Ich habe mir gerade mal versucht eine Liste mit so Filmen, die wirklich in nativen
3D aufgenommen wurden und das sei wohl auch schon beim ersten Avatar der Filme der Fall gewesen.
Beim zweiten dann mit High Framerate, dann die von dir erwähnte Hobbit Trilogie
und dann auch Gravity und sowas.
Gravity kann ich mir nicht.
Tron Legacy auch. Teilweise mit nativen 3D gefilmt. Teilweise konvertiert.
Ja, und Pina von Wim Wenders, das ist auch alles schon irgendwie zehn Jahre
her und der Einzige, der irgendwie erst hier vor kurzem gedreht worden ist, ist Avatar 2?
Echt? Und sonst keiner?
Naja, was ich eigentlich nur sagen möchte ist, mit der gesteigerten Bildschirmqualität,
setzt bei mir eine Gewöhnung ein.
Also was mir am Anfang noch vielleicht auch komisch vorkam, dass...
setzt sich langsam irgendwie fest. Also ich habe auch das Gefühl,
man muss im Kopf ein bisschen mitgehen. Man muss so mitlernen.
Man muss sozusagen das Neue auch akzeptieren.
Und vieles von dem, was einen vielleicht am Anfang gestört hat,
wird dann am Ende auch nicht mehr so von mir nicht mehr so negativ bewertet.
Also ich glaube, das kann sich noch ändern. Mal schauen.
Gut.
Ralf, du nimmst ja am Internet teil.
Ja.
Kann man schon sagen.
Du nimmst am Internet teil.
Aber Tierlisten kanntest du nicht.
Kannte ich nicht.
Ja.
Richtig.
Erstaunlich, aber kannte ich nicht. Ja, und Roddy, du kanntest die.
Ich kannte die, ja. Hab denen nie so richtig Bedeutung beigemessen, aber Ich auch nicht.
But it's the thing. Also das muss man einfach mal so sehen.
Und der Jack darf uns gerne mal Tipps geben für richtig gute Tierlist Webseiten,
Generatoren oder Programme, mit denen man Tierlist machen kann.
Wer von Tierlist noch nichts gehört hat, Tierlist ist einfach so ein,
kommt wahrscheinlich aus der Videogame Kultur wahrscheinlich.
Es ist im Prinzip ein einfaches Rankingsystem, wo man innerhalb einer bestimmten
Gruppe von Dingen diese Dinge in so Level einstuft. In Tears eben.
Und diese Tears werden dann üblicherweise in naja sieben oder weniger Level eingestuft,
von denen aus irgendwelchen Gründen der beste S heißt und die anderen dann von A bis F gehen.
Und je nach Auslegung wird dann auch mal sowas wie E oder so weggelassen,
je nachdem wie sehr man das aufspreizen möchte.
Und der Sport ist, dass man sich dann halt irgendeine Definitionsgruppe von
Dingen, die miteinander verwandt sind offenbar,
nimmt und dann eben in freier Diskussion darüber Klärung erzeugt,
was denn nun in welche Kategorie gehört und ob irgendwas davon S ist.
Und ich dachte mir, das wäre ja auch mal etwas für uns.
Das hört sich nach uns an.
Hört es sich, oder?
Ja, unbedingt.
Meinung haben wir.
Meinung, Subjektivität haben wir auch.
Mäßig Ahnung, Meinung haben wir.
Genau, mäßig Ahnung und viel Meinung.
Aber auch Haltung.
Genau.
Weiß irgendjemand, wo sich dieses S herleitet? Sowas macht mich immer ganz wuschig.
Supreme, super.
Ich meine, dass das so ein bisschen unklar ist. Also da gibt es verschiedene Meinungen zu.
Was das bedeuten könnte, es könnte super oder superb heißen.
Ist halt einfach das Tollste.
Superb, super, superior, special oder Sugoi, was auch immer das jetzt ist.
Sugoi can be used for expressing something extraordinary, meaning something
like wow or amazing or incredible in English.
Oder im Japanischen steht das S für Schuh, which is the Japanese word for excellent.
Und dann ist es wohl auch noch in japanischen,
Schulnoten,
Academic Grading in Japan.
Achso.
S ist also, ja, das S ist für so besondere Leistungen.
Weil A bis F ist ja auch Ami-Schulnoten.
Ja.
Wobei F mehr oder weniger immer als Fail oder Flunked übersetzt wird.
Ja, aber S ist einfach das Außergewöhnliche. Ja, also wenn etwas auf ein S-Tier
kommt, dann muss es mehr als nur gut sein.
Sondern es muss irgendwie besonders
viel Impact haben oder einfach so eine außergewöhnlich geile Idee sein.
Also mehr als eine 9,0 bei IMDb.
Wie Georg gerade sagt, saugut.
Saugut.
Genau, ist das jetzt saugut. Genau, und da wir so unkreativ sind,
dachten wir, ihr könnt uns ja mal Vorschläge machen für so Gruppen.
Also was naheliegendes wären zum Beispiel,
Schnittstellen.
Ja. Also zu Schnittstellen, da habe ich auf jeden Fall eine Menge Meinung und
es gibt auch eine Menge davon.
Was wir bitte nicht machen, Programmiersprachen.
Warum nicht?
Anderthalb Stunden Lebenszeit verbrennen, weil sowieso,
Linux-Distributionen Elixier nicht von S wegzukriegen ist.
Das ist auch geil. Das werden wir nicht tun.
Angenommen, wir würden uns über Linus-Distributionen unterhalten.
Was wäre die Folge davon?
Ich würde die nur nach dem Klang des Wortes oder im Screenshot bewerten.
Wir würden das dann mal machen, egal was die Kriterien sind.
Nur nach dem Namen oder so oder keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, wir.
Würden auf der Straße erschossen werden.
Die Kommentare wären eigentlich kaum lesbar dann.
Nenne ich es mal vorsichtig.
Genau.
Ja, aber es mag ja weniger kontroverse Kategorien geben, die trotzdem Spaß machen.
Denkt euch doch mal was aus und schreibt uns das mal für die nächste Sendung
und dann picken wir uns da mal so ein paar lustige raus.
Das ist halt das Ding. Wir müssen uns vorbereiten. Also das können wir nicht ad hoc machen.
Ich würde jetzt mal Schnittstellen in den Raum werfen, es sei denn,
uns fallen noch was Besseres an, was wir vorher machen wollten.
Du redest von Hardware-Schnittstellen?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich rede von...
Ich wollte es nur klarstellen.
Ja, nee, du hast ja recht. Also so Interfaces im Sinne von Dinge,
die die Dinge verbinden.
So ein SCSI zum Beispiel.
So was zum Beispiel.
Dank des Adapters.
Apple Desktop-Bus, sag ich nur.
Ja, da gibt es eine Menge und das müssten wir dann auch zentral sammeln und
so ein bisschen ranken und so weiter.
Und man müsste ja auch ein bisschen Gefühl dafür bekommen, weil man kann sich
ja natürlich stundenlang darüber unterhalten. Aber man müsste ja dann auch wirklich
über jedes einzelne Ding reden und abstimmen und da muss man mal den richtigen
Rahmen finden, dass nicht die ganze Sendung da mit drauf geht.
Aber ich fand das mal irgendwie einen schönen Gedanken.
Ja, Tierlist, also the Internet ist vor Tierlist. Ist, genau.
Und vielleicht bringt uns das ja auch alle irgendwie ethisch-moralisch irgendwie weiter.
Ethisch-moralisch.
Ja, ethisch-moralisch.
So, was mich weitergebracht hat, war der Besuch einer weiteren Konferenz.
Und ich hoffe, das interessiert euch jetzt, das Thema.
Weil ihr müsst ja eine Frage stellen. Aber ich wollte mal ein wenig dazu sagen.
Also ich hatte das ja auch schon angekündigt. Ich war auf der Elixier-Konf.
und da fällt mir gerade noch ein, dass ich vergessen habe, eine bestimmte Notiz noch vorzunehmen.
Die Elixierkonf 2025, es ist eine Konferenz, die findet halt jedes Jahr statt
und wie der Name schon sagt, es geht um Elixier, die tollste Programmiersprache
der Welt und Esstier auf jeden Fall.
Absolut Esstier, ja, also No we're talking,
Oder auch A Also man muss sagen, weil Also,
Das ist ein bisschen Man könnte auch das Man könnte es ja auch das 10er System
nehmen Und ihr wisst auch Worauf auch immer man das 10er System anwendet Was ist die goldene Regel,
Wisst ihr überhaupt, wovon ich rede, wenn ich sage 10er-System?
Man bewertet Dinge nach dem 10er-System.
Also von 0 bis 10?
Ja, oder von 1 bis 10. 1 ist schlecht,
10 ist das Bestmögliche, aber generell im 10er-System muss eigentlich immer
gelten, 10en gibt es nicht und 1en gibt es eigentlich auch nicht,
weil nichts kann so schlecht sein und nichts kann so gut sein.
Ja, ja, ich sage nur. Aber das S-Tier-System sagt, es kann S geben.
Bei Programmiersprachen könnte es schwierig werden.
Also das ist definitiv ein Thema.
So, warte mal, wo ist denn jetzt hier die Information, die ich noch kurz abrufen wollte?
Ähm ah ja genau hier und zwar wollte ich mal kurz grüßen und zwar den Stefan,
den Steffen den Friedrich, den Marc den Per und den Julian und den Martin die
ich auf der Elixier Konf getroffen habe und die alle frikscheuern ja sowas und nicht nur das,
Anna erzählte mir sogar weil ich mal angefangen habe von Elixier zu reden in
diesem Podcast hat dazu geführt, dass er dann in seiner Firma Exit eingeführt
hat und deswegen war er letzten Endes auf dieser Konferenz. Da war ich ein bisschen stolz.
Auf jeden Fall war ich da und es war ganz interessant, auch wenn ich sage,
ich hadere ein wenig mit Programmieren.
Also auf der einen Seite finde ich das halt einfach super spannend und interessant,
weil da eben so diese ganze Community zusammenkommt und da herrscht so ein ganz guter Knowledge Level.
Also man wie sagt er, äh,
Man muss alles 0,7 mal erklären, bevor es einer versteht.
Also schon so advanced. Und ich habe mir bloß die ganze Zeit darüber Gedanken gemacht,
auch über dieses Konferenzdesign selber, weil das ist irgendwie ganz schön eingefahren
und irgendwie völlig anstrengend.
und wir sind ja jetzt auch so ein bisschen den Kongress gewohnt und der Kongress
ist ja so dermaßen anders als so andere Tech-Veranstaltungen,
aber das ist halt so eine normale Tech-Veranstaltung und dann hast du dann erstmal,
ich würde sagen ungefähr,
Männeranteil von 96% da geht es dann schon los, irgendwie schwierig,
aber was noch ein bisschen anstrengender ist, das fängt dann irgendwie morgens
um neun geht das dann schon los.
Das ist aber schon schwierig. Und dann enden die um 18 Uhr.
Und dazwischen ist dann aber auch totale Dauerbeschallung mit relativ kurzen
Abständen zwischen den Talks.
Und wenn dann das Programm auch noch so interessant ist, und das war relativ
interessant, ja, dann will man sich natürlich auch irgendwie alles anschauen
und es total überlastet. Das war eine Zweitagesveranstaltung.
Dann war an dem einen Abend könnte man dann mal, da war dann so am Abend so,
und jetzt machen wir noch eine Stunde irgendwie, es gibt Drinks.
Woraus dann zwei Stunden wurden, weil sie irgendwie alle nicht aus dem Hotel
bekommen haben. Also weil das ja immer in so Hotels stattfindet.
Und am zweiten Abend, als die Veranstaltung dann zu Ende war,
war sie dann halt auch sofort zu Ende um 18 Uhr und dann sind irgendwie alle
schon wieder woanders hingegangen.
Gut, Leute wollen dann vielleicht auch irgendwie sich irgendwo nochmal separat
treffen und nicht zusammen rumhängen, aber der ganze Wert einer solchen Konferenz,
weil man ja auch online daran teilnehmen kann und sich die Talks so anschauen kann,
der Wert des Vorort liegt ja im Wesentlichen am unmittelbaren Gespräch und am
direkten Austausch, Dass man halt all die Leute mal direkt am Schlawittchen
greifen kann, die an irgendwas arbeiten, wo man weiß, da müsste sich mal was
ändern und hier lalala, lass mal reden.
Da kann man dann eben mal sehr gut seinen Punkt machen und mit so einem 5-Minuten-Pitch
unter Umständen auch mal wirklich Dinge in Bewegung bringen,
was halt online so irgendwie nicht möglich ist.
Und deswegen hadere ich immer ein wenig mit diesen total einformatierten Konferenzen,
die sehr wenig Wert darauf legen,
den eigentlichen Wert, nämlich die Kommunikation und das direkte Gespräch,
dem genug Raum zu geben, indem die Pausen zu kurz sind.
Das After-Conference-Geschehen nicht ausgedehnt genug ist und dann,
auch wenn dann der letzte Tag gekommen ist, nicht auch nochmal einen Abend hinten dran zu hängen.
Das wäre jetzt so meine primäre Kritik.
Allerdings, und das ist ja gerade im Vergleich zu dem Kongress aus bekannten
Gründen, dann in meinen Augen ein Vorteil,
in zunehmendem Maße kommen ja diese Konferenzen mit so Specialized Conference
Apps und da gibt es ja mittlerweile schon sehr viel,
die einem ermöglichen sich da irgendwie zu registrieren und dann bist du halt
auch automatisch connected mit allen anderen Teilnehmern.
und siehst die Avatare und kannst mit den Leuten über die App direkt chatten
und dich verabreden und so weiter.
Das finde ich wiederum ganz cool, auch wenn die Apps teilweise so ein bisschen saugen.
In diesem Fall kam ein System zum Einsatz, das nennt sich Swapcard,
also was wohl so eher von dem Gedanken ausgeht, dass man irgendwie Businesskarten ausgibt,
Hat ja jeder so seine eigene Vorstellung davon, wie man das,
was man da so als wichtigstes Feature benennt.
Das war so, ja okay, also hat als, ich finde so als Web-App nur so bedingt gut
funktioniert, weil es irgendwie seinen State nicht gut gemanagt bekommen hat.
Da hat man schon gemerkt, dass es nicht in Elixier programmiert ist.
Mit Elixir wäre das nicht passiert.
Aber immerhin du hast halt irgendwie die Agenda die Videostreams waren dann
direkt bei den Talks dabei und auch nach der Veranstaltung tauchen die Aufnahmen
da auf, ist irgendwie alles gut zugeordnet,
man findet sich zurecht und du kannst halt auch noch über die Konferenz hinaus
so diese ganze Chat-Systematik verwenden und das ist,
eigentlich eine gute Sache,
ist jetzt nur die Frage, wie macht man eben diese Apps also das war jetzt ganz
offensichtlich wieder so eine Web-App die dann halt auch als Native-App kommt,
teilweise werden ja auch Native-Apps gemacht, jetzt am Montag fängt ja die Republika
hier an in Berlin, die haben jetzt auch glaube ich erstmalig eine eigene App rausgebracht,
die man sich runterladen kann, die auf mich auch erstmal so ein bisschen einen,
Eindruck macht, als wäre sie eine Web-App.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, jetzt noch nicht so richtig viel Zeit damit verbracht,
weil das ist irgendwie alles gerade ganz neu.
Immerhin, auf Zuruf, weil die App kam halt raus und ist natürlich dann für iPhone
und iPad. Und für was ist sie nicht?
Für einen Mac war dann wieder nicht angehakt. Ich mich dann gleich beschwert
auf Mastodon und dann hat der Developer tatsächlich den Haken dann noch gesetzt,
sodass man es jetzt auch auf dem Mac machen kann.
So ist es richtig.
Ja, nicht, dass es jetzt besonders überzeugend rüberkommt, weil es ist halt
eher, sagen wir mal so typische,
ja, du kannst die iPhone-App auch auf dem iPad starten und dann ja,
nichts passt sich wirklich an, an das Format, du hast nicht so verhältst du
dann wie eine iPad-App, da taucht dann kein Sidebar auf, weil der Platz auf
einmal da ist und so weiter.
Gut, geschenkt immerhin, es läuft so, ich finde das ganz gut,
Weil manchmal ist einfach so eine App auch auf dem Mac besser zu verwenden,
als das Ganze immer nur im Webbrowser zu machen mit den üblichen Problemen,
die so Webbrowser so mit sich bringen.
Aber da hast du dann natürlich gleich wieder diese Accessibility-Probleme,
du kriegst den Font nicht größer und so weiter und dann wird es schwierig.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr mal gute Erfahrungen gemacht habt mit solchen Apps.
Toto, der ja schon mal hier in der Freakshow war vor einiger Zeit,
der hat ja seit Jahren eigentlich auch diese Republika immer mit seiner App,
die er auch für den Kongress anpasst und für andere Veranstaltungen anpasst, beschickt.
Die funktioniert auch eigentlich immer sehr gut.
Die funktioniert eigentlich auch immer ganz gut. Ich weiß jetzt nicht,
ob er sie jetzt für die Republika jetzt überhaupt noch rausbringt.
Weiß ich gar nicht. Habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen.
Genau. Aber wie seht ihr denn das generell auf so Konferenzen,
weil es ja immer so dieses Spielball ist aus Privacy auf der einen Seite,
aber auch so Kommunikationswunsch auf der anderen Seite.
Ist das überhaupt noch, ist der Privacy-Gedanke da überhaupt noch aktuell in
Zeiten von LinkedIn und Xing und so weiter?
Also meine Grundposition wäre ja immer, alles kann, nichts muss,
solange es freiwillig ist und man ein Opt-in hat in solche Vernetzungsfeatures,
spricht da erstmal rein gar nichts gegen.
Also ich kann da jetzt heute noch nicht so ganz viel zu sagen,
aber in ein paar Monaten vielleicht so im Bibliotheksbereich planen wir da gerade was in die Richtung.
Aber nicht für Konferenzen, sondern für Workshops, die wir machen in unseren Räumlichkeiten.
Was ja eigentlich das gleiche ist.
Was vom Grundprinzip her gleich ist, aber auch ein bisschen anders gelagert,
weil die Leute sollen noch mehr arbeiten.
Das heißt, da geht es dann auch eher darum, denen dann eine Arbeitsumgebung
bereitzustellen. Also die haben sich einmal getroffen und treffen sich vielleicht
auch vier Wochen wieder, aber dazwischen soll auch nochmal was passieren.
In dem Bereich werden wir uns ein bisschen tummeln. Also ich glaube daran,
dass da grundsätzlich ein Potenzial ist.
Leute treffen sich im physisch-realen Raum und wollen aber auch irgendwie digital
was zusammen weitermachen, weil sie merken, oh, ich bin ja gar nicht alleine
hier mit meinem exoten Interesse.
Ich glaube, da ist noch was zu holen, quasi der Verbindung vom Hyperlokalen rein ins Digitale.
Also ich verstehe es nicht so ganz. Eigentlich ist so eine Konferenz halt auch zum Networken da.
Und wenn man da jetzt, keine Ahnung, irgendwie anonym auftreten will,
dann ist es so ein bisschen.
Das spricht so ein bisschen der Teilnahme an sich, ne? Ja, finde ich auch.
Aber gut, das ist ja jedem selbst und so.
Man läuft dann auch auf der Konferenz ja nicht physisch mit einer Maske rum,
also auf manchen Konferenzen vielleicht schon und klar, Cosplay und so, alles auch prima,
aber so in der echten Welt siehst du ja auch, was ist das für eine Nase,
warum soll man das dann nicht parallel dazu auch in einem geschützten System,
also ich würde dann schon sagen, so der Preset sollte dann sein,
es sind dann aber auch wirklich nur die Leute,
die dann da mit einem Ticket auch wirklich rumlaufen auf der Konferenz,
Aber dass die sich dann in einem geschützten Raum digital vernetzen können,
finde ich per se erstmal total naheliegend und wenig anrüchig.
Man muss halt gucken, was für Mehrwert generiert man dann auch wirklich für die Leute.
Wenn es dann nur so endet, so okay, hier hast du meinen WhatsApp-Handle,
dann ist es halt ein bisschen wenig.
Darum versuchen wir halt so ein bisschen über die Feature-Leiste zu kommen.
Was brauchen die Leute eigentlich und wie kriegt man sie von Google Docs weg
und solche Fragen werden wir versuchen zu beantworten.
Mhm. Wirst du denn auch auf der Republika sein?
Nee, ich werde nicht da sein, weil ich auf der Next Library Konferenz bin in Aarhus.
Aarhus. Ah, Aarhus, da war ich schon mal.
Doc 1, so eine der Pilgerbibliotheken, wo man hinpilgert im internationalen
Bibliothekswesen, wenn man sehen will, was da so on vogue ist.
Und da ist jetzt die Next Library von Sonntag bis Dienstag.
So, weltweite Konferenz für so,
was sind die nächsten hippen Themen im öffentlichen Bibliotheksbereich.
Und da war ich überhaupt noch nie, weil ich bin ja auch erst seit einem Jahr
öffentliche Bibliothek.
Und da bin ich schon ganz gespannt, was die Dänen da so machen und Dänen und alles dazwischen.
Ja, vielleicht nur so ein, zwei kleine Snippets noch, was auf dieser Elixierkonferenz
mich besonders erwischt hat.
Ich will jetzt nicht über die Details von Elixier-Talks reden,
das war zwar alles super interessant und echt high level und wirklich,
also da passieren geile Sachen,
aber zwei Dinge vielleicht, also auf der einen Seite, es gibt ja immer so die
Talks über Technik und dann gibt es so die Talks über, was wir alles damit gemacht
haben und dann merkt man dann manchmal überhaupt erst, was in was implementiert
ist, das weiß man ja heutzutage nicht.
Und ich habe auf dieser Elixier-Konferenz gelernt, dass BBC.com eine Elixier-Webseite
ist, seit einiger Zeit bereits und dazu beigetragen hat, dass diese mächtige
Datensammlung, die das sozusagen ist,
weil es sozusagen das Frontend für den kompletten Radio- und Fernseh- und Dokumentationsfilminhalt
von BBC, also alles läuft über eine Elixier-App und der Talk hat halt schön gezeigt,
wie sie das alles realisiert haben und was sie da für coole Features eingebaut
haben, um sozusagen auch die Stabilität der Links und die Stabilität des Systems
langfristig zu sichern. Das fand ich auf jeden Fall sehr interessant.
Aber was mich so richtig umgehauen hat, war ein Talk über Metaprogrammierung in Elixir.
Also Metaprogrammierung ist ja sozusagen das Programmieren von Programmieren.
Also zum Beispiel Makros, wenn man so eine Programmiersprache hat,
die Makros unterstützt, die also quasi in dem Moment, wo das Programm übersetzt
wird, dass man Code, der dann später läuft,
selbst zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch mal aus Makros anderen Code generiert und sich
damit eine ganze Menge so Boilerplate-Code,
also so Code, den man immer wieder auf dieselbe Art und Weise in derselben Struktur
in seinem Programm versinken muss, sich damit ersparen kann.
Dafür wird es typischerweise eingesetzt, aber in einem Talk ging es richtig wild zur Sache,
weil hier so ein paar Features von Elixir kombiniert wurden,
um die Sprache mit einem LLM zu verbinden.
Und das beginnt erstmal ganz einfach mit einer Bibliothek, die einem generell
erstmal den Zugriff auf LLMs erlaubt.
Also wenn du quasi mit all diesen APIs von OpenAI und Anthropik und so weiter sprechen möchtest,
gibt es halt eine Lektierbibliothek, die das irgendwie einfach macht,
wo du einfach nur sagst, mit wem möchtest du denn gerne reden und du musst nicht
die spezifischen APIs implementieren.
Das war schon mal ganz nice, das gab es aber schon vorher und das war ja nicht nur der Anfang.
Und dann hat er irgendwie mit diesem System, jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz meine
Gedanken zusammen kriegen, nicht, dass ich das wieder komplett falsch erzähle,
aber es war eh so facettenreich, das kriege ich jetzt nur im Ansatz.
Auf jeden Fall hat er ein Prompt-LLM-Frontend, in dem Fall halt Cloud,
glaube ich, also die Cloud-Desktop-App, mit seinem eigenen Code verbunden,
so über einen MCP-Server und war dann in der Lage,
in diese Cloud-Desktop-App Onstage rein zu diktieren, ja, nach dem Motto, ja, ja,
Ich möchte gerne jetzt hier Code schreiben, weil dieser MCP-Server konnte dann
auch, hatte auch Filesystemzugriff auf den Source Code.
Das heißt, er hat ihm dann live gesagt, füge diesem Programm,
mit dem ich gerade rede, ein weiteres Modul hinzu, was das und das tut.
und dann hat Claude sozusagen in dem laufenden Programm ein weiteres Modul hinzugeschrieben
und das lief dann da auch und hat dem gesagt, was dieses Tool machen soll,
ja und immer wenn irgendwie.
Hier, wenn ich Success sage, dann sollst du irgendwie die Konfetti-Kanone auf
dem Bildschirm irgendwie explodieren lassen,
also schwer zu beschreiben, wenn dieser Talk irgendwann mal öffentlich ist werde
ich ihn nochmal verlinken,
aber es war so mindblowing wie super mega dynamisch das ging,
dass du sozusagen in einem laufenden Programm Code rein diktieren konntest,
also nicht den Code diktieren, sondern eine Anweisung rein diktieren konntest,
die dann dazu geführt hat, dass Code geschrieben wird, der in dem Moment dann
auch gleich wieder läuft und Dinge tut,
ohne dass er irgendwas nochmal starten musste, sondern einfach die ganze Zeit
nur, wo er im Laptop stand und mit der Maschine geredet hat.
Das war schon echt wirklich future-proof.
Echt total next-level geiles Zeug.
Naja, also ich hatte auf jeden Fall meinen Spaß in Krakau und ich werde auf
jeden Fall diesen Train weiter bereisen.
Da könnte ich vielleicht mal reingehen, so Thema Programmieren und Live und
so. Was habt ihr denn letzten Samstag gemacht?
Schon so lange her.
Letzten Samstag?
Letzten Samstag.
Gesungen.
Selbst gesungen?
Ja.
Manche Leute singen auch selber.
Es war Samstag, 17. Mai.
Kann ich dir sagen. Also erst habe ich erklägliche neun Stunden im Zug verbracht,
um von Krakau wieder zurückzukommen, weil die Bahnverbindung von Polen,
also von diesem Teil in Polen,
Die furchtbar schlecht sind. Also nicht nur, dass es zusätzlich noch Verspätung
hatte, es ist auch an sich keine ausgebaute Hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke.
Es gibt sowas zwar, aber es führt alles nur nach Warschau.
Es ist alles total zentralisiert in Polen. Und als ich dann sehr verspätet endlich
zu Hause war, dann habe ich mir diesen ESC angeschaut.
Aha.
Darauf wolltest du doch wahrscheinlich hinaus.
Darauf wollte ich in der Tat hinaus. Am 17., also letzten Samstag,
war der Eurovision Song Contest.
Wie hieß der früher eigentlich nochmal? Weißt du das noch?
Ja, der Grand Prix de la Chanson de Revision. Wundervoll.
Das war noch Zeit.
Das war noch ein besserer Name.
Genau, abgekürzt ESC heutzutage. Ja, und Guilty Pleasure.
Ich gucke den wirklich, seit ich denken kann. Das heißt also bestimmt irgendwie
40, 45 Jahre so. Meine Eltern haben den geguckt.
Also ich habe, jetzt ist es wirklich schlimm. Ich habe ein einziges Jahr,
konnte ich den nicht gucken, weil ich da auf einer Familienfeier war.
Und das war das Jahr, in dem Lena gewonnen hat. Man stellt sich diese Schmach vor.
Vorher irgendwie 45 Jahre ESC guckst und dann sowas. Gut, also auf jeden Fall,
der war jetzt wieder letzten Samstag.
Das ist ja auch eine interessante Tierlist-Veranstaltung. In gewisser Hinsicht.
Okay, ich weiß, da geht es um finales Ranking. Aber auch hier muss dieses Problem
gelöst werden, dass man sich da irgendwie über irgendwas einigen muss.
Und insofern war gerade diese Veranstaltung sehr interessant.
Ja, okay. Auf jeden Fall, ich hatte auch ein Problem.
Und zwar, ich finde, der ESC macht vor allen Dingen dann so richtig Spaß,
wenn er halt auch irgendwie digital begleitet ist.
So und früher hat man das natürlich irgendwie auf Twitter gemacht und hat dann
also ESC Twitter-Begleitung geschrieben.
Das verbietet sich heutzutage auf X, ist klar. Aber auf Mastodon ist auch echt was los.
Das heißt also da gibt es einfach doch viele, viele Leute, sowohl international,
aber auch und gerade in Deutschland, die dann da also wirklich eine lustige,
umfangreiche Begleitung machen.
Aber was ist dann immer das Grundproblem?
Sekunde.
Ja, ja.
Hast du auch Freunde, die mit dem ESC nichts anfangen können?
Ja, schon. Die dich nicht checken? Bemühst du dich da irgendwie um Vermittlung?
Seit ich Kinder habe, irgendwie nicht mehr, weil das alles so schwierig zu organisieren ist.
Und die haben da gar keinen Bock drauf, was ich anprangere. Ich denke mir,
es gibt auch irgendwie auch keine coolere Kinderveranstaltung.
Man ist diese ganzen Irren da auf der Bühne mit ihrem bescheuerten Kostüm und so.
Aber es perlt völlig ab an meinen Chiddies.
Das ist so Rollis Blick. Ich glaube, Rolli gehört auch in diese Kategorie.
Zu viel schlechte Musik auf einmal, das ist einfach nichts für mich.
Also ich finde vor allen Dingen toll, so ein bisschen raus zu schnüffeln,
was die Trends des jeweiligen Jahres für diese Veranstaltung eigentlich sind.
Es gibt halt irgendwie Jahre, in denen hast du plötzlich überall Trommeln.
So diese Tribal Drums waren irgendwie mal wichtig.
So dann sind irgendwie wichtig jetzt plötzlich diese ganzen Digitalprojektionen
natürlich, weil es ja auch einfach die technische Bühne ist,
die sie halt irgendwie haben und wie unterschiedlich das aufgesetzt wird.
Und dann gibt es die Gegenbewegung, dass sie wieder zurück ins Analoge und wieder
richtige Bühnen aufbauten und nicht nur digital sich auf die Leinwand verlassen.
Und welche Songs setzen sich jetzt gerade durch? Singst du auf Englisch?
Singst du in deiner eigenen Sprache?
Sondern es gibt immer so ganz vielfältige, mehrdimensionale Trends,
die sich so von Jahr zu Jahr teilweise fortsetzen.
Dann hast du wieder einen Cut und das, was letztes Jahr funktioniert hat,
funktioniert dieses Jahr überhaupt nicht.
Und gerade so in der Konstanz, so über 10, 15 Jahre, finde ich das total spannendes
Fernseh- und Kulturexperiment einfach.
Ich bremse dich nochmal ganz kurz aus, um Roddy mal noch mitzunehmen,
also du bist ja so es gibt ja verschiedene also okay, schlechte Musik hast du
gesagt ist das das einzige was du wahrnimmst von dem ESC, also nimmst du das
als reine Musikveranstaltung wahr?
Ich nehme es größtenteils als Musikveranstaltung wahr, ja ich weiß da gehört
auch viel Bremborium außenrum dazu,
mit, wie du schon sagtest Bühnenaufbauten und Trickkleidern und Leute,
Windmaschine Windmaschine, Leute hängen an Seilen und werden durch die Halle
transportiert und so weiter. Mir ist das einfach alles so dänelig.
Okay, und würdest du akzeptieren, dass der ESC, also ist dir klar,
wie populär diese Sendung ist?
Äh, ja, es gibt Leute, die sich das angucken.
Es ist nach Sport die größte Fernsehveranstaltung der Welt.
Naja gut, Fernsehen ist sowieso nichts für mich und Sport angucken finde ich
jetzt auch langweilig, aber ja.
Ja, geschenkt, also ich glaube auch nicht, weder will ich dich da irgendwo hin
retten, ich will nur mal kurz klar machen, wie populär das ist.
Also dieser ESC ist sozusagen Europas, jenseits von Fußball,
ist es sozusagen Europas größter Kulturexport.
Ich meine, das ist die einzige Gelegenheit, wo die Welt überhaupt mal checkt,
wie viele europäische Länder es gibt, wie die heißen und wie die Hauptstädte heißen.
Und nur 24 singen und aber das Dreifache darf abstimmen, weil die es alle gar
nicht ins Finale geschafft haben und oh meine Güte.
Genau, aber ich finde diese, es gibt kaum eine Veranstaltung,
die das Wort Vielfalt dermaßen abstrahlt.
Außerdem ist es glaube ich in der schwulen und generell LGTBQ,
wie viele Buchstaben da noch alles mittlerweile dazukommen, ist es überhaupt
der totale Megakult, weil da ja auch einfach schon seit Jahr und Tag.
Das ist schon immer gewesen.
Schon in den 70ern. Immer queere Menschen, schräge Vögel und bärtige Diven und
alles mögliche, nicht nur gesungen und performt, sondern auch gewonnen haben.
Conchita Wurst habe ich mitbekommen.
Conchita Wurst, ganz grandios. Für mich überhaupt einer der größten Erfolge,
die diese Veranstaltung jemals hat feiern können. Das war einfach ein Geniestreich.
Dieses Jahr war ich nicht ganz so happy mit dem Ergebnis, aber egal.
Für wen warst du? Was war dein Lieblingstitel?
Ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich einen hatte.
Und es ist ja so, außerdem schwingt ja immer noch ein bisschen Gesellschaftspolitik.
Unbedingt. Vor zwei Jahren Ukraine gewonnen. Hatten aber auch wirklich einen
guten Song, muss man sagen.
Ja, absolut verdient. Also da haben sie alles geleistet und Ukraine ist auch ein starkes Popland.
Also ich finde auch, Ukraine ist einfach auch Musik-Pop-technisch einfach auch ganz vorne.
War auch davor schon immer gut platziert.
Und hat auch schon ein paar Mal gewonnen, also überhaupt nichts Neues in der
Hinsicht, ansonsten ist halt Schweden auch immer hart am Wind,
weil es sind eh sozusagen die Pop-Könige, nicht erst seit ABBA.
Und das ist lange her.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich diesmal so einen richtigen Favoriten hatte,
aber ich habe natürlich mit Interesse wieder auf dieses Spiel mit Israel geschaut
und da gab es ja diesen Effekt, dass halt, also das Abstimmungssystem des ESC
ist ja ein Politikum für sich.
Früher war das, gab es glaube ich, korrigiere mich, es gab früher kein Juryvoting.
Also ganz früher, bis ich glaube in die 80er rein, gab es nur ein Expertenjuryvoting.
Überhaupt keine Menschen durften abstimmen.
Weil das war technisch auch noch gar nicht machbar.
Wer technisch vielleicht nicht gegangen war, irgendwie Demokratieverständnis,
Partizipation, das war da alles noch nicht so irgendwie verwurzelt im Fernsehen.
Und da hat dann also immer eine Expertinnen-Jury vom jeweiligen Land bestellt,
dann irgendwie abgestimmt, wie drei, fünf Hanseln, müsste man gucken,
wie da genau der Modus war.
So, dann gab es diese Mischform mit,
es gibt sowohl Publikumsstimmen und die waren dann sehr, sehr viel wert versus
auch noch irgendwie ein leichter Anteil an Fachjury,
aber nicht allzu viel und das haben sie dann auch wieder irgendwann umgedreht
in, dass es jetzt quasi 50-50 zählt.
Das heißt also, die Stimmen einer Expertinnen-Jury pro Land zählt genauso viel
wie das, was die Leute anrufen.
Und man darf nicht für das eigene Land anrufen, sondern nur für andere.
Und konnte auch im Internet abstimmen, muss dann da aber auch dieselben Handygebühren
bezahlen. Das fand ich irgendwie so.
Da drehen sich mir irgendwie die Fingernägel hoch, wenn ich auf einer normalen
HTML-Seite irgendwie für, ich drücke auf einen Button, soll ich dann Geld bezahlen?
Das ist schon klar, dass die Bots raushalten wollen und so, aber alles ein bisschen weird.
Naja, so ist auf jeden Fall derzeit jetzt der Modus. es zählt 50-50 und bei
Israel war es halt so, die in den,
In der Expertinnenjury war es ganz ordentlich platziert, aber nicht überragend.
Die waren, glaube ich, in der zweiten Hälfte irgendwo, so um Deutschland rum
auch fast, glaube ich, relativ dicht dran.
Ja, aber in keiner Hinsicht irgendwie als Favorit.
Genau, und dann kam halt das Publikumsvoting und haben die dann also fast auf
den ersten, aber dann eben doch mit 50 Punkten Abstand, glaube ich,
auf den zweiten Platz gespült.
Am Ende, ja.
Die hatten allerdings auch einen super Auftritt. Das war ein schönes Beispiel
für eine gute Verbindung von Bühne.
Die hatten so einen Turm aufgebaut, wo sie dann so eine Glastreppe,
Wendeltreppe, wo sie so hochgeschritten ist.
Und währenddessen dann aber dahinter auch die Projektion auf den Leinenwänden
gut abgestimmt war. Also das hatte schon auch viel Schönes.
Wobei den coolsten Auftritt von der Bühne her fand ich in der Tat das,
was im Inneren einer Sanduhr gespielt hat.
Und wo die ganze Performance lang von oben Sand runtergerieselt ist.
Was wohl eigentlich Kork war.
Was wohl Korkstücke waren und dann drehte sich aber quasi dieser Werfer dann
plötzlich beim Refrain und dann hattest du nicht mehr so einen linearen Sandstrom,
sondern so zwei sich verschränkende, das war, fand ich auch total hübsch.
Aber ich will dir recht geben, dieses Jahr musikalisch war ich enttäuscht,
mich hat eigentlich kein einziger Song musikalisch so richtig mitgenommen,
aber man kann auch nicht alles haben.
Die Lettinnen waren, dachte ich mir so, das war mal, das hat mir zugesagt.
Das waren diese sechs Mädels.
Die so elfenartig da hatten und Fäden da rumtanzten, die wohl auch in Lettern
eine ganz große Nummer sind.
Aber so einen richtigen Favoriten hatte ich nicht. Ich fand dann aber das Ding
mit Israel, weil das halt auch wieder alles so böse war.
Und sogar der jetzige Gewinner, dieser JJ, hat sich jetzt dafür ausgesprochen,
dass Israel diesmal nicht teilnehmen soll. Das ist einfach so furchtbar peinlich.
Naja, also wie auch immer, man merkt einfach, ich will das nicht überbewerten,
aber schon mit der Ukraine und jetzt auch so ein bisschen mit diesem Israel-Publikumsvoting,
auf einmal merkst du so eine...
Stimme Europas, die zugegebenermaßen weit gefächert ist, weil Australien darf ja auch mit abstimmen.
Ja, auch nochmal so eine Nuance.
Aber irgendwo spürst du, dass eine politische Diskussion im Raum und wie es
wirklich wahrgenommen wird, teilweise große Differenzen aufweisen kann.
Und sich dort dann abbildet.
Genau, und sich dann einfach in so komischen Punkten auf einmal so abbildet.
Aber dann spürbar ist, weil du hast richtig gemerkt, die haben so,
was weiß ich, 240 Punkte oder sowas bekommen, während alle anderen so bei 100
schon aus dem Häuschen waren.
Und dann war das so richtig so ein, oh was, wirklich?
Weil auch niemand anders auch nur ansatzweise irgendwie in diesen Punkten bereits gekommen ist. so.
Und das finde ich, das sind so kleine Wirkungskräfte.
Ich will so eine Show nicht überbewerten, aber ich finde es generell ganz bezaubernd
an dieser Veranstaltung, dass sie so diesen internationalen Wettbewerb,
so dieses komm, lass uns doch einfach gegeneinander singen, anstatt dass wir uns die ganze Zeit,
abschießen, wo Fußball ja auch so eine Variante von ist. Ähm,
Dass das sozusagen gelungen ist, auch noch über diese europäische Idee hinweg
das so in die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen und zu so einem witzigen Ding zu machen,
weil irgendwie ist es ja auch witzig.
Selbst wenn einem die Musik nicht gefällt, diese ganzen Tönekinds,
die ja im Vorfeld schon läuft und auch teilweise die super, super witzigen Performances
da teilweise bei rauskommen.
Diesmal war es glaube ich nur diese Espresso Macchiato.
Der war aber die schon ziemlich gut.
Der war in der Tat auch wirklich ziemlich lustig.
Und Schweden war halt auch schon sehr lustig, muss man sagen.
Das war auch gut.
Also im Vorfeld habe ich die beiden mitbekommen, den Espresso Macchiato.
Ich würde sagen, da hast du fast alles Wesentliche erfasst.
Die Finnen in der Sauna, das fand ich schon sehr gut.
Ach ja, genau, die mit ihrer Sauna.
Ja, aber das waren ja die Schweden. Die Schweden waren in der Sauna.
Ja, das waren die finnischen Schweden.
Das waren die finnische Schweden.
Nein, das ist der Teil von Schweden, der Finne spricht.
Ah, okay, siehst du die Details.
Genau.
Okay, also halten wir fest, kann man wirklich gut machen. Ja,
natürlich ironisch, aber wie du schon sagst.
Du willst ja sicherlich noch auf irgendwas hinaus.
Ich will eigentlich noch was ganz anderes.
Ja, ja, das dachte ich mir schon.
Aber ich dachte, der Einstieg ist gut und es war wirklich so,
wie ich gleich beschreibe.
Ja, ist gut. Und wo wir gerade dabei sind, dich vom eigentlichen Thema abzuhalten,
würde ich auch nochmal das Voting-System ansprechen.
Weil ich finde, bei so vielen Teilnehmern ist es schon wichtig,
dass noch mehr Nuance rauskommt. Weil wir hatten ja auch tatsächlich dann zwei Fälle, glaube ich.
Also ich glaube, Island hat überhaupt gar keine Punkte bekommen am Ende.
Also weder vom Publikum noch von der Jury.
Und die Franzosen, die sich schon fast auf den Siegeszug wenden,
sind dann einfach auch mal mit null Punkten im Publikumsvoting und haben echt
nicht schlecht gestaunt.
Das war schon so richtig so, ja nee, das hat uns jetzt einfach mal gar nicht gefallen.
Und dann habe ich mich halt gefragt, was für eine Null ist das?
Ist das so eine Null, so eine Null, Null oder ist es nur eine Cut auf Null?
Das ist eine Cut auf Null.
Genau, weil es ja immer nur eine Top Ten gibt, die die Punkte bekommt.
Plus die Zwölf.
Hör zu Tim. Es werden Punkte vergeben von 1 bis 10 und dann gibt es aber halt
quasi noch den eigentlichen Gewinner, der bekommt 12 Punkte. Es gibt keine 11 Punkte.
Die 9 wird nicht vergeben.
Die 11 wird nicht vergeben.
Nur die 11 wird nicht vergeben. Okay, dann ist es eine Top 11.
Von 1 bis 10 plus 12. La Le Manille, du es point.
Der zweite Platz kriegt keine Punkte?
Germany, 12 Points. Nein, das ist einfach ein Abstand zwischen,
der zweite Platz kriegt 10 Punkte, der erste Platz kriegt 12 Punkte.
Das war schon immer so und ist historisch gewachsen.
Aber der Mechanismus, auf den du vielleicht hinaus willst, ist,
dass es halt diese zwei grundsätzlichen Abstimmungsrunden gibt.
Nämlich erst werden nur die Jury-Ergebnisse verkündet.
Nee, nee, darauf wollte ich nicht hinaus, sondern ich wollte darauf hinaus,
dass es sich ja also erstmal sehr löblich finde ich ja, dass es generell ein
Preferential Voting gibt, weil ich finde das Preferential Voting als Konzept
ist meiner Auffassung nach für so etwas das richtige Voting.
Weil es quasi, du rankst halt mit das fand ich am besten und die anderen fand
ich weniger gut, aber du hast nicht so nur eine, einer kriegt eine Stimme und
alles andere fällt raus.
Aber dadurch, dass es nur eine Top 10 ist, und es wie viele Teilnehmer sind im Finale?
24 waren es, glaube ich.
Genau. Heißt es, dass mehr als die Hälfte, jedes Mal, 26 sind es sogar,
also deutlich mehr als die Hälfte, also 15 kriegen keine Punkte, 11 kriegen Punkte.
und das finde ich nicht okay weil dafür ist hier zu viel Nuance gefragt und
generell finde ich es auch gemein,
diese Künstler, die ja teilweise wirklich was leisten mit so null Punkten irgendwie
auch nur in einzelnen Votes nach Hause zu schicken, also irgendwas sollten sie immer bekommen,
damit sie irgendwo auch weißt du, ein bisschen recognition muss irgendwie dabei
sein meinetwegen kann ja der 26.
wirklich null kriegen aber eigentlich auch nicht und ich weiß der ganze Eurovision
ist verliebt mit 12 points das ist halt irgendwie so man muss da irgendwie 1 auf die 12 kriegen,
12 ist halt auch irgendwie eine geile Zahl aber das Ding hieß halt auch schon
mal Grand Prix de la Chanson de Eurovision,
und dann haben sie es Eurovision genannt, da kann man das mit der 12 auch nochmal
überdenken So, so viel wollte ich dazu sagen.
Ob eine Jury jetzt überhaupt erforderlich ist und was bringt,
Das ist eine andere Diskussion.
Wofür ich nochmal werben wollte, ist dieser Spannungsmechanismus,
den Sie da reingedrillt haben.
Der ist noch gar nicht so alt, den haben Sie glaube ich so seit sieben Jahren oder sowas.
Das ist also die erste, also es gibt grundsätzlich drei Teile oder gut,
wenn man genauer hinguckt noch mehr, aber am Anfang wird halt ganz viel gesungen
und währenddessen kann man schon irgendwie abstimmen.
Nee, nicht währenddessen, sondern ich glaube erst, wenn alle gesungen haben,
dann gibt es einen Zeitraum X, in dem alle abstimmen dürfen und dann gibt es
dann noch irgendwie Begleitprogramm, damit nicht für die früheren Platzierten
schon länger abgestimmt werden kann und so weiter.
Das ist also ein festes Intervall, in dem man abstimmen kann.
Dann kommt die erste Wertungsrunde der Profi-Juries, die halt dann 1 bis 10
Punkte vergeben und Gewinner nochmal 12 obendrauf und die werden mehr oder weniger,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob das alphabetisch ist.
Werden die aufgerufen und vergeben ihre Punkte und alle werden sofort irgendwo
reingeschrieben und nur die 12 Punkte werden dann nochmal besonders angesagt
und alle freuen sich besonders.
Und danach hast du dann halt ein Ranking von den 26 Ländern und die sind halt
in der Reihenfolge, wie sie sind.
Und der Clou ist dann bei der zweiten Runde, wo dann nochmal halt pro Land quasi
ein bis zehn Punkte vergeben werden, plus dann nochmal die zwölf Punkte für
den eigentlichen Gewinner.
Das wird dann nicht mehr aufgerufen pro, wie hat die Bevölkerung des Landes
X abgestimmt, sondern die gehen die Summe aller für jeweils Einleitung. von hinten hoch.
Das heißt, sie fangen mit dem letzten Platz an.
Das heißt also, wenn jetzt Island null Punkte in der Jury gehabt hat und auf
Platz 26 ist, ganz weit unten und das Publikum das aber toll gefunden hätte
und denen 100 Punkte gegeben hätte, dann wären die hochgeklettert,
das ist dann auch schön animiert,
an allen anderen vorbei, die noch keine 100 im Jury-Voting hatten und landet
dann auf Platz, was weiß ich, 15 oder sowas. Und dann wird der.
Zweitschlechtplatzierteste aufgerufen und bekommt seine Punkte.
Das heißt also, das Feld wird dann wirklich im wörtlichen Sinne von hinten aufgerollt.
Ja, und du merkst dann schon, okay, die kommen alle so ein bisschen hoch,
aber mit dem Sieg haben sie nicht wirklich was zu tun.
Und bei Israel war es dann aber wirklich so, die waren, glaube ich,
ich meine, ich ungefähr auf Platz 15, haben dann halt diese irren 200x Punkte
bekommen und waren mit riesen Abstand auf Platz 1.
Zwei.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt 1. Die waren zu dem Zeitpunkt auf Nummer 1,
weil ja quasi jetzt in Österreich noch keine Public-Vote gekommen sind.
Genau, das waren andere.
Die 1-Punkte hatten. So, und dann kommt quasi, danach kamen noch 14 andere Länder
und du hast auch gemerkt, oh, keiner von denen kann sich jetzt,
obwohl er vorher schon mehr Punkte hatte, schafft es sich an Israel vorbeizuschieben
und werden die noch vom Thron gestoßen oder nicht und das erzeugt wirklich,
hat häufig zumindest in den letzten Jahren eine irre coole Spannung erzeugt, weil du halt wirklich.
Ja, so sollte man mal Bundestagswahl verkünden.
Oder Kanzler wählen.
Großer Fan von diesem, es ist ja nicht unbedingt der Abstimmungsmechanismus,
sondern der Präsentation der Zahlenergebnisse.
Die Zahlen stehen natürlich alle fest. Es muss irgendwie more fine-grained werden.
Ich finde, das Ranking muss irgendwie...
Die Bestrafung der letzten Plätze ist zu hart.
Ja, man kann ja auch...
Was häufig die Deutschen waren in den letzten Jahren.
Man kann ja auch, sagen wir mal, die Punkte irgendwie nach so einem logarithmischen
Ding vergeben. In gewisser Hinsicht ist das ja schon so ein bisschen mit der Eins.
Die kriegt ja sozusagen nochmal so einen Boost. Dann könnte man das ja auch
sagen, was weiß ich, die untersten Plätze kriegen alle einen Punkt. Weißt du?
Jetzt haben wir beide Unrecht, Tim. Hier, Alex Zalex schreibt es gerade.
Der sagt, dass es jetzt so ist, dass es Eins bis Acht gibt, Zehn und Zwölf.
Das heißt, die 9 fehlt und die 11 fehlt. Beide fehlen.
Habe ich doch recht gehabt.
Also quasi erster und zweiter Platz sind jeweils rausgehoben.
Genau, top 10. Also 16 kriegen keine Punkte,
10 kriegen jeweils Punkte und man könnte genauso gut auch sagen,
die letzten kriegen alle einen Punkt und dann geht es mit zwei weiter und dann
nimmt man die 9 wieder mit rein und dann passt das auch.
Und dann haben sie auch wieder ihre Dusepoint und irgendwie einen Punkt Vorsprung und alles ist gut.
Aber ich finde so, bei den schlechten, also wenn die dann alle gleich sind,
dann sollen sie nicht null Punkte geben, sondern einen Punkt geben. Was soll's?
Ja, aber es sind ja nicht alle gleich schlecht.
Okay.
Das ist mein Gerechtigkeitswahr. Wie dem auch immer sei.
Ja, kommt aus dem eigentlichen Thema.
Nächstes Jahr kannst du dich ja live auf Mastodon darüber beschweren.
Wirklich.
So, aber damit du dann auch dort gelesen und wahrgenommen wirst zu diesem Thema,
brauchst du auf Mastodon was? viel mehr noch als auf Twitter damals, früher.
Was brauche ich wo was?
Damit deine Postings zum ESC gut verbreitet und wahrgenommen werden.
Eine Mastowall für den ESC.
Ja, jein, kommen wir auch noch zu, aber damit die überhaupt funktioniert, braucht es was?
Datenbank.
Nee, Hashtags.
Ah, Hashtags.
So, weil wir wissen, Mastodon, Suche über alles gibt es mittlerweile,
aber dein Server muss mitspielen und du musst es konfiguriert haben, jada jada.
Was ist dein eigentliches Ziel jetzt?
Da kommen wir jetzt in wenigen Sekunden hin. Jetzt sag doch mal,
was ist denn das richtige Hashtag für den ESC gewesen?
ESC.
Meinste.
Na, was heißt das Richtige? Das Richtige ist das, was die meisten verwenden
und ich würde sagen, ESC ist das, was am meisten verwendet wird.
Siehst du, das glaubst du jetzt?
Ja, glaube ich.
Ich wollte es gerne wissen.
Ja, wissen tue ich es nicht. Achso, du wolltest es wissen.
Ich wollte es wissen.
Okay.
So, und ich hatte die Idee schon mal irgendwie vor ein paar Monaten und hab
versucht, das in die Masterwall mit rein zu konfigurieren und da ist aber damals
ChatGPT kläglich dran gescheitert,
aber jetzt haben wir ja Claude Sonnet 37 und es war 20 Uhr und ich hatte noch
eine Stunde Zeit und dachte ich mir so, jetzt mal los.
Sagst du also, ich wollte ein Tool haben, wo du einen Hashtag oder ein Thema
eingibst und wo dir herausgerechnet wird, was zu diesem Event,
was gerade auf Mastodon präsent ist, die populärsten Hashtags sind,
die du dann für deine Postings nehmen kannst.
Auf Basis von?
Auf Basis von. Ich kann jetzt erstmal die URL reinschmeißen.
Die kannst du vielleicht mal aufrufen.
Dann hat man das Ganze schon mal vor Augen und wir werden euch beschreiben, was da zu sehen ist.
Mastotags.
Mastotags habe ich das genannt. Neben der Mastowall und Mastothread gibt es
jetzt also auch Mastotags von mir.
So, es ist also eine ganz simple, olle Webseite.
Written by Claude Sonnet Prompting, Ralf Stockmann. Was heißt das denn? Das ist ja Quatsch.
Ne, ist exakt so. Es ist ja passiert.
Schreibst du auch sonst eine IDE hin? Also ich meine...
Also ich finde, es ist wichtig, dass man sowas transparent macht. Finde ich so? Ja.
Warum? Finde ich nicht.
Also alleine damit Leute irgendwie einsortieren, also erstmal so,
es ist KI-Code, ist Vibe-Prompting, ist es jetzt nicht Vibe-Coding,
ist es jetzt nicht irgendwie, ich bin nicht selber aus den Fingern gewrungen mit allen Pros und Cons,
und ich finde, es ist auch ein permanenter Proof-of-Concept,
so was geht und wie es geht.
Ich habe gleich noch die Prompt History dazu, die publiziere ich halt auch immer.
Ich finde es gut, sowas transparent zu machen, wo wir da stehen, technologisch.
Ich gebe lieber damit an, dass ich das alles so gemacht habe.
Man muss ja trotzdem viel drüber nachdenken. Die Programmierleistung ist ja im Kopf nicht im Tippen.
Jetzt hast du also hier dein Suchfeld und jetzt tippst du einfach mal ESC ein.
Oder irgendwas anderes.
Ja, aber machen wir mal mit ESC, damit sich das jetzt hier auch von der Story her her leitet.
Okay.
So, und da sehen wir, das war offensichtlich nicht die beste Wahl.
So, sondern ESC schafft es also nur auf Platz zwei als populärster Hashtag.
Und auf Nummer eins ist Eurovision.
Ja, aber was sind denn das hier für Zahlen? 50 und 63?
So, das erzähle ich dir jetzt alles, Tim. So, also was sehen wir?
Wir haben jetzt eine Trefferliste mit lustigen bunten Balken, wo man jetzt sehen kann,
Eine Zahl wird da angegeben, die die Verbreitung dieses Hashtags in Postings auf Mastodon angibt.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Wie kommt der denn von ESC auf Eurovision?
So, das erkläre ich dir doch jetzt alles. Also der Mechanismus dahinter ist folgender.
Du hast halt eine Ahnung, zu welchem Thema du was suchst, bist dir aber halt nicht sicher.
Ist das jetzt schon das perfekte Hashtag? Das heißt, wenn dort jetzt eine Suche abgegeben wird,
werden die ersten 40 Beiträge von Mastodon Social ausgewertet,
die dieses Thema oder diesen Hashtag haben.
Und sämtliche Hashtags all dieser 40 Beiträge werden nochmal in eine Rangliste
gebracht und die fünf besten davon,
über die wird im Hintergrund nochmal eine zweite Suche losgetreten und die Ergebnisse
sämtlicher Hashtags daraus kommen auch in die erste Gesamtliste.
Und daraus hast du dann aus quasi diesen sechs Suchen zusammengebaut eine Top-Liste,
die hinreichend präzise ist.
Okay, stopp, stopp, stopp. Syntax-Error in 10.
Kannst du nochmal?
So schwierig ist es nicht.
Ich habe einen Parsing-Fehler gehabt. Also was, kannst du das nochmal leichter
erklären in den Algorithmus?
Also pass auf.
Ich gebe was ein.
Die Grundannahme ist, Leute versuchen, um Reichweite zu kriegen,
geben sie mehr als ein Hashtag in ihren Beiträgen rein.
Das tun sie auch oft.
Das tun sie auch oft, ja. So, wenn du jetzt was über die WWDC schreiben willst,
dann schreibst du WWDC, WWDC25 und Apple.
Schauen wir nochmal.
Genau.
Apple ganz vorne, dann WWDC, dann WWDC25, iOS 19.
BWD 2025.
Aber wenn ich hier Eurovision angebe, dann kriege ich Gaza und Israel.
So, da kommen wir gleich zu. Das heißt also, da bilden sich jetzt dadurch,
dass jetzt hier keinerlei semantische Interpretation drin ist.
Also was weiß ich, da ist jetzt nicht nochmal eine KI zwischengeschaltet,
so oh es geht um Musik, dann filtere ich mal alles raus, was jetzt mit Israel und Gaza zu tun hat.
Ja, aber das war eben, wie du gerade eben ja beschreibst, ein präsentes Thema
und das war auch auf Mastodon ein präsentes Thema.
Darf Israel jetzt eigentlich hier gewinnen und sollten die überhaupt mitmachen?
So, und das bildet sich eben auch in den Hashtags ab.
So, warum man jetzt also auch nicht einen Automatismus oder ich jetzt wirklich
nicht empfehlen würde, stumpf immer nur die ersten drei zu nehmen,
wenn du jetzt beispielsweise mal WWDC eingibst, also sprich,
man will sich jetzt schon mal darauf vorbereiten, wie können wir denn über das
nächste Apple-Event schreiben.
So, dann hast du halt als Top-Treffer Apple. So, der ist dann aber so breit,
dass er dir also jetzt für eine Masterwall beispielsweise überhaupt nicht hilft,
um dich da auf dem Laufenden zu halten, weil da kommt ja dann noch alles mögliche an Beifang.
Das heißt, du nimmst dann jetzt als Hashtags WWDC, WWDC25 und WWDC 2025.
Das sind die drei bestplatzierten thematischen Hashtags genau für diese Konferenz.
So, und das Feature, was ich dann noch reingepromptet habe, ist,
du kannst jetzt also bis zu drei von diesen Hashtags,
aussuchen und kannst die markieren und kannst dann oben mit einem Klick eine
Masterwall dazu starten, ohne die noch irgendwo anpassen zu müssen oder ähnliches.
Das heißt also wenn jetzt einfach mal,
also auch nur bis zu drei, weil die Masterwall kann ja nur drei,
aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie drei beliebige anwählst über die Checkboxen und
dann auf Masterwall geht, wird ja direkt dazu eine aufgebaut.
Und umgekehrt werde ich die Connection auch noch machen.
Du kannst in der Masterwall ja oben auf die Hashtags draufgehen,
um die anzupassen. Dann werde ich dort quasi auch nochmal einen Button reinbauen zu Explode.
Hinweise für bessere Hashtags noch für deine Masterwall, damit das Ganze noch
besser irgendwie zusammenpasst.
Super, was man hier kriegt, wenn man auf Freakshow geht. Wie AfD-Dancing-Memes,
du mit einer Vision Pro und irgendwas mit Trump.
Das sind alles andere Freakshows.
Genau, das sind alles andere Freakshows. Das ist natürlich jetzt ein totaler
Gemischtwarenladen. Aber auch dafür hilft jetzt so ein Service halt zu gucken,
okay, was sind jetzt halt Hashtags, die thematisch einigermaßen drinstecken.
So, also jetzt Siehst du ja, wie dieser Dienst jetzt hier gebaut ist.
Was spricht dagegen jetzt nicht über ein Hashtag einzusteigen,
sondern über einen Suchbegriff?
Also wenn ich jetzt sage, dass er sich gerade beschwert, dass das irgendwie
kein Space enthalten darf.
Ja, ein Space nicht. Also es muss in einer, könnte ich reinprogrammieren,
im Moment ist es lassen. Im Moment ist es so, dass es quasi keine.
Er nimmt ja an, es wäre dann sozusagen ein Hashtag. Er sagt Invalid Hashtag Format.
Ja, da ist die Fehlerausgabe jetzt nicht spezifisch genug.
Genau, ich möchte hier 1. FC Union Berlin mit richtigen Leerzeichen eingeben
und danach sucht er und dann guckt er, was da unter dem Suchbegriff für Tags
zu finden sind, weil sonst muss ich ja erstmal mit dem Tag starten,
wenn ich gar nicht weiß, was das erste Tag ist.
Genau, du kannst schon, dann ist es derzeit so, dass du halt nicht nach mehreren
Wörtern suchen kannst, das könnte ich mal, muss aber halt dann auch klar machen,
dass es dann halt nicht, also er sucht jetzt.
Sag das mal deinem Klot.
Ja.
Ja, das hat dir allein gelassen.
Gut. Was ich aber halt bemerkenswert fand, also es ist jetzt überschaubar komplex,
aber es sieht irgendwie hinreichend brauchbar aus, finde ich,
und tut das, was es so irgendwie soll.
Und rat mal, wie lange ich dafür gebraucht habe und wie viele Promts.
Nicht lang. Also nicht mehr als Nachmittag und ich würde sagen,
mit deiner Erfahrung, 10 bis 20 Promts?
Also ich habe gebraucht 20 Minuten, weil ich hatte ja auch nur eine Stunde und 12 Promts.
So und das habe ich mal einfach in die Zwischenablage geworfen und habe das
mal auf meinem Pad gemacht und jetzt kann man sich das hier mal angucken.
in meinem Headstock, wo ich solche Sachen immer versuche, irgendwie ein bisschen
runter zu dokumentieren. Kannst du ja mal draufklicken auf das Dokument.
Das hier?
Genau. Da habe ich jetzt nicht, also ich habe von dem ersten Prompt habe ich
quasi die Antwort auch mit reinkopiert.
Danach habe ich mir das gespart, weil das wenig Erkenntnisgewinn gebracht hätte.
Es ging jetzt wirklich nur darum, okay, wie, wenn ich jetzt so ein Projekt mache,
was ist da quasi so meine Prompt-Strategie?
Und den ersten lese ich vielleicht mal vor, weil dann merkt man schon mal,
was so ein guter Startpunkt für so Vibe-Coding ist. Hallo, ich möchte einen
kleinen Webservice bauen, Mastotex.
Er soll das Problem lösen, zu großen Events wie Wahlen, Sportevents etc.
den richtigen Hashtag für eigene Posts auf Mastodon zu finden.
Also der Hashtag, der gerade zum jeweiligen Thema die größte Verbreitung hat.
Entwickle erst einmal eine Idee, wie man das technisch angehen könnte.
Bitte noch keine Implementierung.
Grundlage soll sein, JavaScript, Bootstrap und die Mastodon API auf Mastodon Social.
Es soll ohne Login funktionieren, es muss nichts gepostet werden,
betrieben soll es auf GitHub Pages.
Das ist also der erste Prompt und dann macht er ein technisches Konzept,
was ich mir vorher schon genau so vorgestellt hatte und dann geht es dann auch
schon los direkt danach.
Ach, das schöne dezentrale Netzwerk mastodon.social.
Genau, weil das ist halt das, wo ich hatte jetzt keine Lust,
jetzt irgendwie 20 verschiedene Server irgendwie noch abzufragen und ähnliches,
sondern das folgt halt alles so dem Prinzip, okay, wenn es um Events geht,
die gerade irgendwie relevant sind, dann sind die auch auf Mastodon Social gut
abgebildet und dann reicht es,
wenn man nur eine API anstresst und nicht noch irgendwie 20 andere Server abgreift.
Ja.
Naja und jetzt kann man halt durchlesen, wie man sich der Sache dann nähert
und ich finde das schon interessant,
ich habe sowas jetzt schon wirklich häufig gemacht, aber diese 20 Minuten,
12 Prompts und dann war das viel, bis auf irgendwie ein paar Designdetails,
die ich danach noch gemacht habe, die sind jetzt hier nicht dokumentiert,
aber das war nur noch reines Pixelschubsen danach.
Es gab bei der Geschichte jetzt keine einzige Stelle, wo er irgendwie rumgezickt
hat und irgendwas getan hat, wo ich dachte, so jetzt aber nicht.
Das hast du jetzt hier nicht mit drin.
Genau, sondern es sind jetzt die einzelnen Blöcke sind jeweils einzelne Queries
hier, die zwölf Stück und dazwischen kamen dann halt Antworten von ihm,
aber die kann man sich vorstellen.
Jetzt schon der Schleimer hier, danke, super.
Ich rede immer sehr, sehr höflich mit meinen LLMs.
Das ist dein Sklave, da kannst du auch mal klare Ansagen machen.
Nein, das mache ich nicht.
Das bist du, ist dir wert.
Es gibt auch die Theorie, dass das die Ergebnisse verbessert.
Naja, ich finde das überhaupt nicht abwegig, weil wir ja hier mit diesen Dingen,
also wir triggern ein neuronales System.
Und alles, was als Antwort kommt, reagiert auf das, was wir reinschicken.
und jedes einzelne Wort, was wir da reinschicken, aktiviert bestimmte Zellen und bestimmte nicht.
Wenn du also danke super toll reinschreibst, dann ist danke super toll als Belohnungselement
sozusagen auch in gewisser Hinsicht in deine Gewichtung mit drin.
Und wenn es nur dazu führt, dass du auch freundlicher zurück angesprochen wirst,
das hilft ja auch schon mal.
Ich finde es immer toll, wenn du sagst, das ist ein super Gedanke, Tim.
Was für eine geile Idee.
Ich wäre da nicht drauf gekommen.
Wo du es gerade erwähnst, ich habe mich gewundert, dass das hier nicht passiert ist.
Ich glaube, da hat Claude was rumgetunt an der Stelle.
Nee, du hast aber nicht so gute Ideen. Also ich werde immer richtig gelobt.
Oder so. Das wird es sein.
Wir loben ihn mal weg.
Es ist halt jetzt Claude Sonnet 3.7. Mit dem Modell hatte ich jetzt from scratch
noch nichts gemacht, sondern ich hatte das nur auf bestehende Projekte bisher
drauf gescheucht und hatte da eher so gemischte,
Erfahrungen, habe ich ja auch schon mal ein bisschen erzählt,
das war mir ein bisschen übereifrig, aber jetzt mit einem Projekt von null hoch,
würde ich sagen, war es nahezu perfekt.
Also das sieht man jetzt wirklich bei der Prompt History, da ist kein irgendwie
Gegenwirken und nee, das ist gerade irgendwie eine falsche Richtung, in die du da läufst.
Klar ist es jetzt ein überschaubar, komplexes Projekt, aber jetzt auch nicht
komplett trivial mit dieser Logik, so, nimm nochmal jetzt die fünf Top und mach
im Hintergrund nochmal eine zweite Suche und aggregiere das zusammen und bring
es in eine vernünftige Anzeige Logik, also das ist jetzt auch nicht,
komplett irgendwie trivial, was da so passiert und dafür hat Claude Zonnet das
echt richtig gut hinbekommen, muss ich sagen.
Naja, Code kann man sich angucken auf GitHub, wie üblich.
Ich verschränke das jetzt nochmal mit der Masterwall und es ist nebenbei jetzt
halt einfach ein schöner, einfacher Masterwall Generator.
Aber so, okay, ich will sicher sein, dass ich jetzt zur Republika die richtigen
Hashtags erwischt habe und was sollte ich beim Posting selber schreiben,
auf jeden Fall verwenden,
damit ich da gut gefunden und gelesen werde. Ich hoffe, es ist nützlich da draußen.
Ja, also es ist schon wirklich erstaunlich, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit diese
Code-Assistenten an Qualität dazu gewinnen.
Also da mag jeder so seine eigenen Erfahrungen mit machen.
Es gibt ja auch noch ein paar Leute, die noch am Wimmern sind.
Und speziell was Claude betrifft, also Apple hat sich ja jetzt wohl auch mit
Anthropik zusammengetan, um mal irgendwie ihren unfassbaren Rückstand zu verjüngen irgendwie.
Also wenn Apple nicht sehr bald da Fortschritte erzielt, dann wird es irgendwie dünn.
Dann laufen sie langsam Gefahr, da den Anschluss zu verlieren.
Andererseits bin ich jetzt auch bei den ganzen übertriebenen Zukunftsaussagen,
die die ganzen AI-Firmen so von sich geben, auch weiterhin milde skeptisch.
Hast du die Google I.O. dir schon angeguckt?
Also ich habe mir eine 30 Minuten Zusammenfassung der wichtigsten Ankündigungen
angeschaut, die im Wesentlichen immer mit Project und dann irgendein Name und jetzt mit AI waren.
und da waren natürlich ein paar ganz bemerkenswerte Sachen dabei in the Demo,
also so wie sie es da halt auf der Bühne demonstriert haben.
Ich habe relativ wenig Erfahrung jetzt mit Gemini und auch relativ wenig Erfahrung
mit den Google-Diensten, aber
sie machen, also sie versuchen zumindest interessante Sachen zu lösen.
Also wir sind dem Babelfisch wirklich sehr nah.
Also so Echtzeit-Übersetzung, das haben sie ja zum Beispiel demonstriert.
Ich kriege jetzt gerade nicht alles zusammen, was sie da angekündigt haben,
aber es war auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge in dieser Richtung und haben halt
da ihre Modelle sehr zugänglich gemacht und vor allem bauen sie es halt in alle
ihre Dienste, alle ihre Apps überall ein.
Haben jetzt auch, glaube ich, bei der Google-Suche jetzt generell so ein AI,
jetzt suchen mit AI quasi so ein Perplexity-Modus.
Das war irgendwie auch klar.
Ich kann es schwer einschätzen, was ihre Aussagen taugen.
Ich meine, sie haben einfach so einen Track-Rekord, dass sie einfach extrem
viele Dienste ankündigen, nur um so drei Jahre später wieder alle einzustellen.
Und wie auch bei Apple muss man halt gerade, was diese ganzen AI-Sachen betrifft,
sehr vorsichtig sein, was so die Qualität betrifft.
Weil das Target ändert sich halt permanent.
Also selbst wenn es heute gut funktioniert, kann es morgen auch schlecht sein.
Und das ist eine, wir haben es jetzt hier mit einer Technologie zu tun,
die gleichzeitig so krass nützlich ist,
aber auch auf der anderen Seite so furchtbar fragil sein kann in ihrem nicht
vorhandenen Determinismus.
Minismus, also die Vorhersagbarkeit.
Also hast du irgendwie früher mal ordentliche Algorithmen scharf geschliffen
bekommen und gut rund gekriegt über die Zeit, dann kommt da einfach rocksolide
Software drauf, wo du dich einfach drauf verlassen kannst.
Aber schon mit diesen ganzen Netz-APIs und diesen ganzen Services,
die da im Hintergrund wirken, wurde das alles schon so wattig.
So ein bisschen fassi.
Und jetzt werden halt die Algorithmen quasi auch nochmal rund gehobelt und irgendwie
wie blubbert das alles wie so ein biologischer Haufen und du weißt jetzt nicht,
ist das jetzt hier irgendwie Schimmel oder Hefe, was da jetzt gerade am Start ist.
Ja, also backen wir jetzt hier Brot oder frisst sich das jetzt alles schon wieder selber auf?
Obwohl ich muss sagen, ich hatte jetzt gestern einen erstaunlichen Erfolg mit
dem neuesten Chat-GPT-Modell.
Das kam ziemlich left field und zwar habe ich ihn so gefragt,
sag mal, kannst du mir einen Text übersetzen, der auf rhetoromanisch ist?
Und rhetoromanisch ist ja jetzt nicht die...
Die meistgesprochene Sprache Europas.
Aber immerhin wird sie gesprochen.
Sie wird gesprochen. Kam als Antwort zurück, ja, ja, kann ich dir machen.
Ich kann dir auch sagen, in welchen der fünf Dialekten das Rete-Romanisches geschrieben ist.
und dann habe ich ihm diesen Text vorgeworfen, also ich hatte von dem Text auch
eine Übersetzung und dann hat er tatsächlich diesen Text korrekt übersetzt und
hat auch noch zu allen Worten erklärt,
was die so heißen und wie so genau die Varianten sind, was es alles sonst noch
so für Bedeutungen haben könnte.
Das fand ich relativ erstaunlich, weil das hatte ich jetzt nicht erwartet.
Das geht auch für tote Sprachen. Also ein ehemaliger Kollege von mir von der
Stabi-Staatsbibliothek, der hat das mal mit Kirchen-Slawisch gemacht.
Und zwar das waren noch wirklich die ganz frühen Chat-GPT-Modelle und der war
also völlig von den Socken wie gut, die eine Sprache konnten,
wo er selber meint, so rasend viele Texte zum Anlernen gibt es da draußen überhaupt gar nicht.
er könnte sich kaum herleiten, wo da überhaupt das Drehlingsmaterial jetzt dafür
so ohne weiteres herkommt.
Ja, also ich glaube aber auch Airpods als Babelfisch Live-Übersetzung,
das werden wir glaube ich echt sehr bald erleben.
Für die nächsten Airpods im September.
Gerade mit diesem Transparency Mode und so, das macht ja total Sinn, das zu machen. Ja.
Da wird es natürlich haarig werden, wenn dann mal falsch übersetzt wird.
Früher haben wir uns ja immer auf Weltverständigungen gefreut, so ja Internet Chat,
das bringt alle zusammen und so und was hat es uns gebracht ja auf einmal hassen
sich alle und Verschwörungstheorien noch und nöcher und auch im Anhalter hieß es ja auch schon,
dass der Bubblefish zu diversen Kriegen geführt hat also da,
garantiere ich nicht für ein goldenes Zeitalter,
ja also so die 30er da mache ich mal keine Aussage zu. Ich lag auch schon bei den 20ern so daneben.
Da fange ich gar nicht erst mit den 30ern an.
Die Frage, die bei uns in der Firma neulich aufkam, ist, wie lange dauert das
noch, bis die ersten Buden zumachen?
Welche Buden?
Firmen, die irgendwas mit Internet machen, weil sie so viel Vibe-Coding machen
und so viele echte Programmierer rausgeworfen haben, dass sie irgendwie ihre Codebase zerschroten.
Es gab jetzt eine schöne...
Schöne Debatte vor zwei Wochen oder sowas ging das raus. Ich weiß gar nicht
mehr, wer die losgetreten hatte.
Wenn denn jetzt Vibe-Coding so das neue große coole Ding ist,
warum sehen wir davon nichts in Open Source Repositories?
so von großen Projekten, also die großen Linux-Distributionen,
die großen Web-Projekte, die ja doch irgendwie ganz überwiegend auch Open-Source sind.
So, warum sind denn da eigentlich nicht Pull-Requests jetzt mal,
die auf der einen Seite offen liegen, so das ist jetzt hier Vibe-Coding und
das hat aber auch wirklich Hand und Fuß und bringt diese Software wirklich nach vorne.
Scheint es derzeit wirklich praktisch noch nicht zu geben.
Das kann natürlich unterschiedliche Gründe haben, so entweder die Leute,
die an solchen Projekten arbeiten,
fassen das einfach aus auch guten, nachvollziehbaren Gründen mit der Kneifzange
nicht an oder sie tun es und legen es aber nicht offen, dass 80% Vibe-gecodet
wurde und sie nur nochmal 20% selber draufgeschüttet haben und das ist einfach nicht bekannt.
Aber den Ansatz so als Messinstrument zu nehmen, so welche Rolle spielt Vibe-Coding
eigentlich bei prominenten wirklich gut laufenden Softwareprojekten, finde ich spannend.
Das ist glaube ich noch ein bisschen schambehaftet so. Das will man jetzt noch
nicht unbedingt zugeben.
Da gibt es nicht jetzt so viele wie wir. Wir setzen uns ja hier hin und sagen,
hey, Vibe-Coder from hell.
Naja gut, wahrscheinlich ist es auch eine Komplexitätsfrage.
Ich glaube, dass ab einer bestimmten Codebase-Größe Vibe-Coding auch einfach
überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert.
Es gab, glaube ich, so eine Welle so vor einem halben, dreiviertel Jahr,
wo dann mal irgendwie offengelegt wurde, Oder so, das meiste von diesem Pull-Request
war entweder, ja, hat dann doch den Code nicht verstanden oder irgendwelche
total trivialen Sachen, nur Kommentare irgendwie hinzugefügt an Stellen,
wo sie eigentlich echt nicht nötig gewesen wären und sowas.
Das hat, glaube ich, auch viele Leute abgeschreckt nach dem Motto,
okay, da kann man sich auch nur eine blutige Nase holen in dem Thema.
Naja, aber ich glaube auch die Bastion wird früher oder später fallen. Also schauen wir mal.
Ich denke, diese ersten Impressionen hängen halt viel mit diesen frühen Fehlern der ersten Coding-LNM.
Das haben wir ja hier auch besprochen, dass da teilweise nur kurz dabei rauskam.
Als ich irgendwie das erste Mal mit ChatGPT versucht habe, Elixier-Code zu erzeugen,
dann merkst du so richtig,
dass der da irgendwie nur so zu 50% in der Elixier-Welt drinsteckte und mit
50% mir irgendwelche anderen Programmiersprachenkonzepte da reingemischt hat
und ich ihn immer wieder darauf hinweisen musste,
dass es sich hier um eine funktionale Programmiersprache handelt und da kann
man nicht irgendwelche Werte ändern.
So, ah ja, jetzt wo du es sagst und so.
und das ist irgendwie schon, ich würde nicht sagen komplett weg,
aber auf jeden Fall spielen wir da jetzt schon in einer ganz anderen Liga, nach einem Jahr und,
ähnlich wird sich das auch weiterentwickeln und ich glaube, ähnlich wird sich
auch die Akzeptanz damit weiterentwickeln, weil.
Wir werden das jetzt bald sehen, dass größere neue Projekte auf diese Art und
Weise geschrieben werden und sehr schnell aus den Startblöcken kommen.
Und dann muss man halt schauen, wie gut das mit der Maintenance und der Weiterentwicklung etc.
Funktioniert. Aber ich sehe jetzt nicht, warum das komplett unmöglich sein sollte,
weil es ist im Wesentlichen Erfahrungswerte wieder, die hier eine Rolle spielen.
So wie du generell mit Programmierung erfahren, Erfahrung sammeln musst,
musst du auch mit dem Vibe-Coding an sich und auch speziell mit den Modellen,
mit denen du arbeitest, Erfahrung sammeln und daraus leitet sich dann erst die
eigentliche Produktivität und der potenzielle Produktivitätsgewinn ab.
Ja und von daher bin ich da milde optimistisch.
Andererseits gibt es natürlich auch in zunahmendem Maße so diese Slop-Problematik
auf einer anderen Ebene.
Also ich glaube Google hat auf dieser I.O. auch angekündigt,
dass sie jetzt GitHub auch so für PR erstellen, für Reviews erstellen und so
weiter auch irgendwie ihre AI-RPIs bereitstellen.
Das heißt, da werden dann die Open-Source-Leute auch nochmal zugeschmissen mit
automatisch generierten Fehlersachen, was ja jetzt auch schon ein Thema war,
insbesondere wenn du so Bug-Bounties hattest. Also dafür war das da total das Problem.
Die Leute gesehen, oh, hier kann man Geld verdienen und so. Und du wirst ja
immer, wenn es um Geld geht, alles vorbei.
Hilft auch die Sparkasse nicht mehr. Ja, AI angeschmissen, ja,
such mal hier irgendwelche Fehler und dann gleich machen wir mal die Einreichung für die Bug-Bounty.
Also so durchautomatisierte Teilnahme an solchen Coding-Wettbewerben.
Und das ist natürlich nicht im Sinne des Erfinders.
Da ging es ja darum, dass wirklich Leute honoriert werden, die viel Zeit aufwenden,
solche Fehler zu finden.
Und jetzt ist es auf einmal ganz einfach, vielleicht auch erstmal nur triviale
Fehler, aber immerhin Fehler zu finden.
Und Leute versuchen halt da, die Kohle abzuziehen. Und ich glaube,
das sind alles so gegenläufige Bewegungen, wo noch nicht ganz klar ist, wie das am Ende ausgeht.
Und ja, müssen wir mal schauen, was ist. Die Contributions, denke ich mal.
Werden von daher erstmal kommen durch neuen Code.
Also es wird neuer Code entstehen, der sozusagen AI-first entstanden ist und
von daher auch sehr viel fresher ist,
während ja gerade die Open-Source-Projekte, die vielleicht jetzt nach Kontributionen sich sehnen,
vor allem diese deshalb nicht bekommen, weil es sich halt teilweise um uralte Code-Bases handelt.
die irgendwie noch am Leben gehalten werden, von genug Leuten benutzt werden
und dadurch einen Wert haben,
aber die so keiner mehr jetzt neu schreiben würde und die Schwierigkeiten haben
auch mit den neuen Environments, dem neuen Web, den neuen OS-Features,
VMs und so weiter, was es auch immer im Einzelnen ist, damit klar zu kommen.
Und das ist dann natürlich jetzt auch vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Erste.
Andererseits glaube ich, dass die Programmierer, die vielleicht derzeit nach
Kontributionen schreien, diese Kontributionen auch wiederum sehr viel direkt
von der AI bekommen können, indem sie nämlich einfach AI-Tools für die Analyse verwenden.
In dem Zusammenhang könnte ich auch nochmal so eine neue Bewegung in der Elixierwelt machen.
Also wir hatten ja über die MCP-Server schon mehrfach gesprochen,
vorhin hatte ich es auch nochmal erwähnt mit dem Blender und was jetzt auch dazu kommt,
das heißt Tide Wave heißt das bei Elixier.
Dass eben auch die VM selber,
also die Laufzeitumgebung, wo dein Programm drin läuft, einen MCP-Server bekommt
und du quasi zur Laufzeit mit einer LLM-Codeanalyse im laufenden Programm vornehmen kannst.
Du kannst also schauen, guck mal nach irgendwelchen Prozessen,
die irgendwie Message-Stau haben und die irgendwie ihre Dinger nicht abarbeiten
oder andere Parameter, was es auch immer ist, Speicherbelegung etc.
Also alles, was du quasi systemisch, telemetrisch aus dem laufenden System abfragen
kannst, steht dir in Echtzeit zur Verfügung, um dann darauf mit einer LLM irgendwie
deine Analysen zu machen.
und sowas werden wir sehen, auch das andere Beispiel, was ich vorhin aus dem
Vortrag gemacht habe mit der Metaprogrammierung.
Also alles greift auf einmal so ganz tief rein und es sind jetzt auf einmal ganz andere.
Debugging-Prozesse, ganz andere Optimierungsprozesse möglich und damit ist unter
Umständen auch komplexere Software auf einmal möglich, die vorher vielleicht
nicht so richtig maintainable war.
Also es ist noch völlig offen das Rennen, aber ich glaube, es wird eine sehr
unterhaltsame Reise werden.
Ich habe jetzt für die Shownotes den Artikel nochmal gerade gefunden.
If AI is so good at coding, where are the open source contributions?
Also den würde ich sagen, echt gerne mal durchlesen, wenn euch generell irgendwie
so Coding interessiert.
Und egal, ob ihr jetzt Vibe Coding cool oder scheiße findet,
der Artikel ist, finde ich, für beide Perspektiven hilfreich.
Jaja, also da gab es ja auch diese Meldung, darauf bezieht sich ja dieser Artikel
unter anderem auch, dass irgendwie Nadella meinte, 30% des Codes,
der bei Microsoft entsteht, sei jetzt irgendwie mit AI gemacht worden,
aber naja, who knows, ob das stimmt.
Ja und ob das dann am Ende nicht doch irgendwie, ja er hat mal auf Autocomplete
irgendwie Tab gedrückt, ne? Achso.
Ich kann mir das noch nicht vorstellen, dass die schon...
Ja, endlich Kommentare im Kurs. Auf einmal 30 Prozent größer geworden.
Auch gerne.
Wir wissen es nicht. Wenn ihr es wisst, fragt es uns gerne zu.
Aber die Zahlen finde ich irgendwie zu fussy, um sie zu glauben.
Ja, ich glaube die klassische Open Source im Sinne von Free Software.
Also vielleicht muss man da auch nochmal ein bisschen unterscheiden.
Also ich glaube so das Free Software Movement, kann ich mir vorstellen,
ist auch so ein bisschen schockiert von diesem Trend, weil es ja auch so ist,
dass derzeit der ganze AI-Coding-Bereich komplett eben von Firmen dominiert wird.
Es gibt halt in dem Sinne keine Open-Source- Engine, die wirklich nennenswert mithalten können,
mithalten kann oder die in irgendeiner Form von irgendeinem Konsortium, einem,
öffnen Konsortium, der allgemeiner zur Verfügung gestellt wird,
was glaube ich auch derzeit noch gar nicht möglich ist, weil einfach sich,
alles so dermaßen im Fluss befindet, die Ressourcen, die dafür notwendig sind,
so in hoher Nachfrage sind, dass die Kosten einfach so hoch sind,
dass sie nur von den großen Unternehmen derzeit auch bezahlt werden können.
Und die Modelle, die halt auf eine bezahlbare Hardware laufen gelassen werden.
Können, einfach noch nicht die Prowess haben, die man dafür braucht.
Naja, diese ganzen RA-Companies werden ja auch mit Venture Capital zugeschissen.
Also die können sich das leisten, irgendwie die völlig überzogenen Preise von
NVIDIA irgendwie zu bezahlen, was du dir als Open-Source-Projekt natürlich nicht leisten kannst.
Genau, und man muss natürlich auch sagen, es ist ja auch so ein gewisser Sustainability-Aspekt
mit drin, der jetzt nicht nur Open-Source betrifft, aber auch Open-Source betrifft.
Jetzt haben wir diese Systeme gerade. Wir wissen, die entwickeln sich irgendwie
ganz gut, Aber es ist auch so, dass derzeit der Betrieb von diesem ganzen Kram
nur möglich ist, weil da so viel Future...
Weil da so viel Venture Capital verbrannt wird.
Genau, weil es wird einfach gerade sehr viel Geld verbrannt und sicherlich wird
es auch ein paar Gewinner geben in diesem Markt.
Aber wie das immer mit den Hypes ist, irgendwann wird sich da die Spreu vom
Weizen trennen. Und ob das Rennen am Ende...
Oder die Bubble platzt, könnte man auch sagen.
Oder die Bubble platzt. glaube ich aber jetzt nicht, weil,
Ja gut, die finanzielle Bubble, die kann natürlich platzen.
Die Technologie geht nicht mehr weg, das ist klar. Aber dieses overhyped Bubble-Ding.
AI für alles und auf jedes Marmeladenbrot muss jetzt irgendwie auch noch AI
drauf und jeder Kühlschrank wird auch nur noch mit AI verkauft, habe ich schon gesehen.
Also es ist alles irgendwie völlig gaga.
Das wird natürlich weggehen. Ich denke mal in zwei Jahren ist dieser Hype,
Dann wird wieder die nächste Sau, die durchs Dorf gejagt wird.
Keine Ahnung, was es sein wird, aber irgendwas. Auf jeden Fall, das hält nicht ewig.
Und dann ist eben die Frage, was bleibt und wer kontrolliert das, was bleibt?
Und wie verfügbar ist das und zu welchen Preisen? Und wenn du dich halt jetzt
auf ein Development-Modell einlässt, was quasi nicht nur AI nutzt,
sondern so viel Komplexität im Prinzip ermöglicht und dadurch ins Projekt bringt,
sodass du nicht mehr genug Wissen in deinem Personalbestand hast,
egal ob es jetzt Firma oder Open Source ist,
dass du das auch gar nicht mehr gefixt bekommst ohne AI.
Aber dann hast du auf einmal diesen Zugriff auf diese AI nicht,
weil du es entweder nicht bezahlen kannst oder es aus irgendwelchen anderen
Gründen auf einmal weggegangen ist.
Dann könnte es halt knifflig werden. Und das muss man sich schon gut überlegen,
wenn man ein Sustainable-Projekt haben will, wie man das gut ausbalanciert.
Andererseits, und das habe ich jetzt auch auf dieser Elixier-Konferenz wieder
gesehen, wenn man sich mit den Leuten unterhält, die Nützlichkeit zweifelt einfach niemand an.
Also das ist einfach, alle verwenden das, alle benutzen das, alle haben das.
Die Erwartung von weiter oben in so Firmen ist aber sehr, sehr groß.
Also das darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Dass es da draußen größere Firmen geben wird, die größere Mengen an Programmierern
rauswerfen, weil sie der Meinung sind,
mit AI sind sie so viel effektiver, dass sie die Leute alle nicht mehr brauchen
und dann in eine Situation kommen, wo sie ein Problem kriegen.
Also damit rechne ich fest, weil das wird alles so als magisches Wasser verkauft.
Also das ist so, wie du so schön sagtest, auf jedes Marmeladenbrot muss AI drauf.
Ja.
So viel dazu.
Und jedes Marmeladenbrot braucht auch Johnny Ive, der wieder aus der,
ich weiß nicht, ob er wirklich in der Versenkung verschwunden war,
aber sagen wir mal, im öffentlichen Interesse war er nicht mehr ganz so im Mittelpunkt.
Hat der nicht zwischendurch Weihnachtsbäume designt oder so?
War das Johnny Ive? Oder war das der Typ von Tesla?
Das weiß ich jetzt.
Ist egal, ist auch nicht wichtig.
Also wer Johnny Ive nicht kennt, Johnny Ive war über einen sehr langen Zeitraum
seit Mitte der 90er Jahre bis ungefähr vor 5 Jahren,
also ungefähr für 25 bis 25 Jahre war er,
der quasi Chefdesigner.
Der Chefdesigner, erst Hardwaredesigner und dann irgendwie auch der Designer,
wobei die Ära ist nicht so gut gelaufen bei Apple.
Einer der Vertrauten von Steve Jobs und gemeinsam haben sie halt so Dinge wie
den iMac, den iPod und so weiter.
Also all diese ganze die Produktserie, die quasi Apple wieder aus der Versenkung,
geholt hat und zur erfolgreichsten Firma der Welt gemacht hat.
Das war unter anderem auch sein Werk.
Er ist Brite, er redet sehr bedächtig und sehr langsam mit so einer mehligen
Stimme war dann in diesen Produktankündigungs-Videos immer so die Background-Voice,
die dann geschrieben hat, die intricate Design.
Er hat vor allen Dingen nie Aluminium gesagt, sondern immer Aluminium.
Das haben die Amis immer, immer, jedes Mal, gab es da irgendwie,
ja Shitstorm ist vielleicht zu viel gesagt, aber es wurde immer bemerkt.
Ja, ich bin mir auch sicher, dass er Color mit OU geschrieben hat,
also das mussten sie dann hinnehmen Aber wir wissen ja, wie die Amerikaner so sind.
Egal, Johnny Ive ist dann aber irgendwann weggegangen von Apple und ich glaube,
das war auch ganz gut so, weil man schon das Gefühl bekam,
dass so sein rigider Minimalismus mittlerweile mehr kaputt gemacht hat, als gut war.
und ja, also immer zu wenig Schnittstellen und,
wofür er auch am Ende dann zuständig war oder an welchen Verfehlungen er für
welche Verfehlungen er wirklich verantwortlich war, das wissen wir jetzt so
nicht, aber es war die Luft war raus und dann ist er halt dann auch irgendwann gegangen,
nach einem längeren Ablösungsprozess und hat dann die Firma Love From,
gegründet und jetzt hat er wieder eine neue Firma gemacht.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Love From jetzt damit zu Ende ist oder seine Beteiligung
da zu Ende ist oder ob das jetzt nur ein zusätzliches Venture ist.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es jetzt eine Bude, die IO heißt und die irgendwie mit Open Air zusammen.
Irgendein mysteriöses Produkt entwickeln soll, was irgendwie so Next Generation,
Devices ist, was du dir irgendwie in die Tasche stecken oder auf den Tisch legen
kannst und mit dem du irgendwie rum AI'en kannst.
Ja, das ist so das Versprechen und es gab so ein völlig,
also vor ein paar Tagen kam schon so ein Interview mit ihm raus,
wo er da irgendwie auf der Bühne von, ich glaube von der Stripe-AP-Konferenz
rumsaß, warum auch immer.
und dann so ein bisschen darüber geplappert hat, wie so seine Philosophie ist
und was ihn so an Silicon Valley so fasziniert hat und auch meint,
dass sich Silicon Valley verändert hätte und es
war ja mal so der kulturelle Polarstern und alle wären ja Idealisten gewesen
und in letzter Zeit würde es irgendwie nur noch von Macht und Geld dominiert
werden und wäre nicht mehr so geil und ein paar Tage später kündigt er dann
automatisch auch noch ein Projekt an mit irgendwie Sam Altman zusammen,
wo die beiden dann wie so Best Buddies irgendwie in so einer San Francisco Bar
rumhängen und sich irgendwelche Plattitüden erzählen.
Das war also wirklich schon sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr cringy anzuschauen.
Ja, und zumal er ja auch meinte, er wäre ja mehr so für Creation,
als irgendwie immer alles kaputt zu machen, weil irgendwie dieses ganze Breaking
Stuff auch nichts bringt und generell mehr Visionen einklagt.
Also ob er das nun zu OpenAI trägt und ob es ihm wirklich gelingt,
ein Device zu erzeugen, was die Masse braucht und was in irgendeiner Form ist,
schafft sich neben Watch und iPad und Vision Pro und iPhone,
oder welche Produktkategorie man jetzt auch immer ranholen will oder Brüllwürfel
auf dem Tisch, mit denen man reden kann.
Krawallkugel.
Ja, so eine Krawallkugel. Also wo sich das einbetten soll, ist mir noch unklar,
aber es gibt wohl einen Prototypen und dann werden wir wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann davon erfahren.
Naja, wahrscheinlich ist es sowas wie der AI-Pin gewesen ist oder sein sollte.
Das steht natürlich zu befürchten, dass es wieder so ein Objekt ist, mit dem du redest.
Aber I don't know. Warten wir mal ab, was kommt.
Johnny Ive ist sicherlich ein guter Designer. Ob er ein guter Internet-Device-Erfinder
ist, weiß ich nicht. Das ist auch, glaube ich, nicht seine Rolle in diesem Spiel.
sondern da scheint sich irgendwie OpenAI selber in irgendeiner Form eine Hardwarebude geholt zu haben.
Ob die dann nur die Fehler der anderen wiederholen oder wirklich nennenswert
etwas anderes im Kasten haben, weiß ich nicht.
Aber mit den Fähigkeiten, die diese Systeme haben, ist es natürlich denkbar,
dass ihnen da irgendein Brückenschlag gelingt, irgendwas gängig werden zu lassen.
Naja, man muss OpenAI zugestehen, dass sie seit längerem dafür bekannt sind,
dass sie ganz brauchbare LLMs machen.
Was die Bude da, diese AI-Pin-Bude war, ist nicht damit groß geworden,
ein super funktionierendes LLM zu haben, sondern die kamen plötzlich mit so
einem Stück Hardware raus und haben das Blaue vom Himmel versprochen.
also insofern halt halte ich ob er für in der lage was zu produzieren was,
Weiß ich nicht, dass den Apple-Leuten vielleicht die eine oder andere schlaflose Nacht beschert.
Also weil Tim hier gerade rumscrollt, während wir sprechen in der Sendung hat
Claude uns zu ehren das Claude Sonnet 4 Modell veröffentlicht.
Jetzt hast du die Überraschung gespoilert.
Gerade eben sprach ich noch über 3.7 und jetzt sind wir also bei 4 und das soll
jetzt nochmal 10% besser im Coding sein als schon das 3.7 und man wird sehen, wir werden es testen.
Ja, zu der Geschichte mit Eif und OpenAI.
Also ich frage mich halt, wenn es irgendwie Hardware ist, was für verschiedene
Varianten haben sie, um da irgendwas zu integrieren und was könnte dann der
Job von Eif bei der ganzen Geschichte sein?
Und ich glaube nicht daran halt,
dass Audio-Only funktioniert mit so einem allmächtigen KI-Assistenten.
Das ist vielleicht irgendwie spannend, aber am Ende des Tages will ich halt
auch auf irgendeine Liste gucken können und will irgendein Bild ansehen oder was rausnehmen.
Vor allem musst du Zugriff auf deine privaten Daten haben, ohne deine privaten Daten freizugeben.
Na gut, das ist ja eine Convenience-Frage. Da kannst du ja sagen,
hier ist mein Login für Google, da ist mein Login für XY.
Wenn Leute so verrückt sind, das zu machen, dann können sie es ja tun.
Aber ich frage mich jetzt erstmal nur auf die Interface-Frage runter reduziert.
Meiner Meinung nach, das was ich glaube, was am besten funktionieren würde,
eigentlich ist in Kombination mit einer Brille.
So, du sprichst mit deiner Brille und siehst die Sachen aber halt in die echte Welt augmented rein.
gebaut. Also halb durchlässig Display.
Das ist das Szenario, wo ich denke, wo es irgendwann hinlaufen sollte,
wenn es darum geht, ich unterhalte mich mit einem KI-Assistenten.
Ich will da eigentlich gar kein Gerät in der Hand halten mit einem kleinen Display,
sondern wenn ich irgendwie rede, dann will ich die Hände frei haben und will
in der Gegend rumgucken und will mit dieser Umwelt durch Sprache,
die ich spreche, interagieren.
Und im Prinzip würde ich sagen, ist die Technik da, bis auf die Brille.
Ja, das heißt also alles andere, dass du jetzt also irgendwie ein Live-Kamera-Feed
auswertest und dort OpenAI in Analyse macht, so was guckt der gerade an und.
Selbst auch schon sowas wie ein rudimentäres Verständnis von dem halt,
wie so Welt funktioniert und was man da gerade sieht, das kann ich mir alles
total gut vorstellen. Ich glaube, da sind die nicht weit entfernt von.
Echtzeitsprache machen sie ohnehin schon gut, also ihre aktuellen Modelle,
mit denen kann man sich ja wirklich, richtig gut flüssig unterhalten.
Ja, wir haben uns vor einem Jahr dieser Skandal, wo sie von Scarlett Johansson
die Stimme genommen hatten. Das funktioniert jetzt schon ziemlich so.
Vielleicht ist jetzt die Betonung nicht so edgy, wie sie es damals irgendwie
immer präsentiert haben, aber vornherein flüssig.
Also wir haben bei uns zu Hause am Abendtisch relativ häufig die Situation,
Papa, frag doch mal die allwissende Müllhalde.
Das heißt also, Papa und Mama wissen irgendwas nicht, die Jungs wollen aber
die Antwort haben, wie Pokémon Monster X die große Schwäche hat.
Dann lege ich das iPhone hin und mache ChatGPT auf im Voice-Modus und frage, hier,
erklär mal zu Pokémon XY, wie kann ich das besiegen in Dings XY und dann erzählt
er einem das und meine Jungs stellen Nachfragen und es ist für die völlig normal,
dass da die allwissende Müllhalde auf den Tisch liegt und alles über Pokémon
weiß. Das stellen die überhaupt gar nicht in Frage.
Wikipedia ist nicht mehr die allwissende Müllhalde, ChatGPT ist jetzt die allwissende Müllhalde.
So und wir versuchen das noch zu framen.
Am Ende ist es immer Marjorie.
Man darf nicht alles glauben, was einem da zählt, wie jetzt so. Aber das ist auch...
Claudia hatte noch eine Zeit, wo sie meinte, das guckt man doch besser alles in dem Wiki nach.
Wir haben jetzt gerade wieder so ein neues Pokémon-Spiel auf der Switch angefangen
und es ist einfach so viel bequemer, halt einfach dein Handy zu fragen,
während du dein Spiel daddelst. Ich will den Controller gar nicht weglegen.
So und ich glaube aber, dass Audio-Only halt nicht reicht. Das heißt also die
Kombination aus Audio auf der einen Seite und ich sehe aber etwas auf der anderen
Seite, klappt meiner Meinung nach so richtig flüssig nur über eine gute Brille,
die halt halb transparent ist.
So, also Google Glass im Prinzip aber mal in geil. So, das ist ein Produkt,
das würde glaube ich funktionieren.
Was ja Google jetzt auch auf dieser I.O. wieder zum x-ten Mal angekündigt hat,
dass sie jetzt so mit verschiedenen Brillenherstellern solche Produkte rausbringen
will, wie es Meta ja auch schon getan hat, mit der Brille, mit der Max schon
die ganze Zeit durch die Gegend läuft.
Andererseits meine ich, ich habe das jetzt nicht zu sehr verfolgt,
aber ich meine in dieser ganzen Debatte um Johnny Ive und OpenAI sei auch so
die Einschätzung von Ive durchgesickert,
dass er nicht der Meinung ist, dass eine Brille die Antwort ist.
ich hatte es eher als etwas, was man irgendwie auf den Tisch legen und in die
Tasche tragen kann, aber so viele richtig Details haben sie auch noch nicht
dazu veröffentlicht. Das ist jetzt alles so ein bisschen,
Teeblätter lesen, aber naja.
Bin skeptisch. Generell, also als Auskunftsmaschine, so wie du es jetzt auch
schon verwendest, reicht mir auch das iPhone.
Also als Public Information und man muss ja eh unterscheiden,
was soll die LLM für einen tun? Soll sie nur übersetzen?
Soll sie ein Gesprächspartner sein? Soll sie ein emotionaler Begleiter sein?
Ist es eine Wissensquelle? Was glaube ich die schwierigste Aufgabe ist,
weil wir eben so hohe Erwartungen haben an die Richtigkeit von etwas und das
wird uns noch eine Weile begleiten.
Aber Wissen heißt halt vor allem, ich durchkämme das Internet und ich bin quasi,
also als LLM, in allen Datenbanken drin und Und ich versuche so viel wie möglich
hier zusammenzufassen.
Klein genug sein, damit es noch effizient ist, groß genug sein,
um auch genug abzubilden.
Aber am Ende wird es immer eine Kompression des Internets sein,
was diese Maschinen rausspucken.
Und die eigentliche Stärke, und da bin ich ja durchaus d'accord mit Apples Vision,
auch wenn sie selber gerade nicht in der Lage zu sein scheinen,
diese Vision umzusetzen, dass du halt.
Du ausgehst mit der Intelligenz von deinen privaten Informationen,
aber eben durch eine richtige Architektur versuchst zu verhindern,
dass diese Daten einem öffentlichen zentralen System zugestellt werden und deswegen
die Intelligenz in das Device zu verlegen, beziehungsweise da,
wo die Performance des Devices nicht ausreicht,
das eben über diese gesicherte Architektur ins Netz zu legen,
die sie vorgestellt haben. Ich finde die Idee nach wie vor super.
Ist natürlich schade, wenn sie es nicht auf die Kette kriegen,
was auch immer der Grund ist.
Irgendwie scheinen sie sich da organisatorisch komplett verhaspelt zu sein.
Aber es ist halt schon wichtig, dass so ein Gerät, wenn es für dich ein persönlicher
Assistent sein soll, also wenn das das Ziel ist hier und nicht eine moderne
Wikipedia und ein moderner Babelfisch,
was auch eine okaye Anwendung davon ist, aber was anderes ist als der persönliche Assistent.
Wenn es der persönliche Assistent sein soll, muss es meine Daten kennen und
es muss mit meinen Daten umgehen können,
ohne meine Daten zu verraten und das ist die Quadratur des Kreises,
an der Apple sich gerade die Zähne ausbeißt,
aber auch für OpenAI wird es nicht einfacher mit ihrem Ansatz in diese Domäne einzubrechen.
Und deswegen ist für mich total offen, was es für ein Gerät ist und welchen
Erfolg es hat, solange man nicht weiß, was eigentlich ihr Ziel ist,
was für eine Art Maschine am Ende dabei rauskommen soll.
Na gut, also nichts genaues weiß man nicht, wir müssen es abwarten.
Genau, so sieht es aus.
Naja, Claude IV wird uns retten.
Bestimmt.
So.
Mal eine Kleinigkeit. Habt ihr das das Käming vom Papst mitbekommen?
Das Körning, ja.
Gott im Himmel, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Nee, nur sein Vertreter. Also.
Das fasst einen doch irgendwie ein bisschen an, oder?
What the fuck.
Einerseits ja, andererseits muss ich sagen so.
Einmal mit Profis.
Ich bin zu wenig Katholik, um dem jetzt irgendwie was abzugewinnen.
Wieso, da muss man ja wohl nicht Katholik sein. Also das ist ja sozusagen,
also das ist ja interkonfessionelle Problematik.
Ja, aber fremder Leute, Grabsteine ist nicht mein Ding. Also das ist so egal.
Achso, du kümmerst dich nur um deinen eigenen oder was?
Zugegebenermaßen habe ich keinen. Also nein, ich kümmere mich auch nicht um meinen Grabsteinen.
Noch nicht, noch nicht.
Aber der Grabstein vom Papst ist weit weg. Dass sie den verkackt haben,
ist ganz offensichtlich.
Ja.
Ähm...
Dass sie sich dabei dann auch noch so peinlich rausgeredet haben,
ist natürlich irgendwie lustig.
L'incredibile errore grafico sulla lapide di Papa Francesco.
Ja, also diese Grabsteinplatte für Leute, die jetzt immer noch nicht wissen, wovon wir reden.
Also der Papst ist da in irgendeiner Kapelle oder so wahrscheinlich begraben worden.
Dreht sich in diesem Grab um.
Genau, und damit er sich in diesem Grab besser umdrehen kann.
haben sie eine Platte draufgelegt, wo einfach nur sein Name draufsteht,
Franziskus. Und wenn man sich das halt anschaut.
Dann sieht es aus wie Frau Franziskus.
Also, da fragt man sich wirklich, was kaputt ist und ob sie das irgendwie mit,
was kann denn da passiert sein?
Also erstmal, was sehen wir? Das ist ein,
FRANCISCVS, Also so die alte lateinische, das römische U sozusagen.
Ja, die Lateine haben keinen Unterschied zwischen U und V gemacht.
Genau. Und zwischen dem R und dem A und dem A und dem N am Anfang,
aber auch zwischen dem C und dem V.
Das geht noch halbwegs. Aber dieses A, das steht schon sehr alleine.
Das A ist richtig.
Das hat rechts und links einfach mal, Also das sieht auch der Blindeste nicht.
Das C und das V geht auch nicht.
Ja, okay.
Worüber wir hier sprechen, der Fachterminus aus der Typografie ist ja das Körning.
Das heißt also der Abstand einzelner Buchstaben.
Oder wie man auch sagt, Käming. Was?
Käming? Wenn es schief läuft.
Jetzt nicht Bad Käming?
Nee, das kenne ich nicht.
Na, denk mal nach.
Achso.
Sehr gut. Okay. I see.
Ja, aus Bad Kemping. Wenn das R und das N so zusammenlaufen,
dass ein M draus wird, dann nimmt dein Körnig im Arten.
Also es kann halt zu eng sein und dann zu weit auseinander. Sehr schön.
Hat sich die Sendung schon gelohnt. Sehr gut.
Danke. In diesem Fall ist es definitiv nicht zu eng, sondern hier ist einfach
mindestens ein Endspace, würde ich sagen, jetzt in typografischer Sprache, ist hier zu viel drin.
Also die große Kunst dieses Kernings ist ja, dass man unterschiedliche Buchstaben
braucht und unterschiedlich viel Abstand zueinander.
Damit sie so aussehen, als hätten sie den richtigen Abstand.
Damit es so aussieht, als hätten sie alle den gleichen Abstand.
Und das ist normalerweise eine Sache, die schon eher so den Typo-Nerds auffällt,
wenn das Körning irgendwo mal nicht so richtig sitzt.
Aber das, was hier bei diesem Grabstein passiert ist, das ist irgendwie jenseits davon.
Das heißt, dieses A, das ist ja fast ein Whitespace links und rechts davon hat das Platz.
Das heißt, das ist nicht jetzt am Computer gesetzt und da hat jemand jetzt beim
Körning gestammt, sondern da ist irgendwas ganz anders falsch gelaufen.
Und wenn der nicht Franziskus geheißen hätte, sondern Dranziskus,
in der Schreibweise würde da ja stehen, Dr. A. M. Ziskus.
Ja, hätten das V-U, ist auch nicht toll.
Aber das ist, würde ich sagen, ein klassischer Kerning-Fehler,
wo man sagen würde, ja sowas passiert, da hätte man drauf gucken müssen,
ein bisschen schlampig.
Aber dieses A, das ist eigentlich jenseits von Katastrophe, das geht gar nicht.
Das heißt also, vielleicht hat da wirklich jemand Space gedrückt dazwischen.
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Ja, aber du meinst, dass das gesamte Schriftwerk, wie es da ist,
am Computer entstanden ist und an einem Rutsch gefräst wurde?
Für mich sieht das eher so aus, als hätte da irgendwie einer mit einer ganz
alten Maschine und beweglichen Lettern.
Das wäre den Römern so nie passiert.
Das kannst du mir nicht erzählen.
Dazu hast du nicht genug alte römische Texte gesehen.
Mag sein.
Also nein, im Prinzip nicht. Das ist eher so, dass man merkt,
dass ihnen am Ende der Zeile der Platz ausgeht und alles wird immer enger.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Ich wäre jetzt gleich auf den Gedanken gekommen,
dass es nicht am Computer entstanden ist. Aber das stimmt, das könnte natürlich Handarbeit sein.
Das ist einfach eine Fräsmaschine und dann hast du so eine Schiebelehre,
wo du dann diese Vorlagenbuchstaben reinschiebst.
Und entweder war das alles locker und dann, naja, dann war das Ader schon so
und dann ist der Stein so teuer und dann hat der Dienstleister halt irgendwie
einen Festpreis verlangt und er hätte nichts mehr dran verdient.
Nee, ehrlich gesagt, ich tippe auf Computer, weil wenn da jemand traditionell
mit so einer Schieblehrer weiter rangeht, die Leute machen alles richtig.
Hier hat einer irgendwie das eingetippt, ist dann irgendwie mit dem Ellenbogen
nochmal gegen die Tastatur gekommen, hat da irgendwie zwei Spaces reingemacht,
dann haben sie da einen Beamer drüber gehalten, das hat drauf gestrahlt und
irgendjemand hat das abgemalt und jemand anderes hat es einfach abgemeißelt. gemeißelt.
So eine typische Trennung der Aufgaben, wo der eine dann nicht mehr weiß,
wie das von den anderen Personen gemeint war und der Letzte,
der das eingemeißelt hat, dachte sich, sieht komisch aus, aber wenn die das
unbedingt so haben wollen, meinetwegen, ist ja bezahlt.
Und so läuft das irgendwie.
Also wer irgendwie was kann in diesem Job und dann Graveur ist,
kann mir nicht erzählen, dass sowas nicht auffällt.
Also AKW hat eine interessante These hier. Es wurde maschinell erstellt,
die Datei war nicht in Pfade Vektoren gewandelt und die Schrift war nicht auf
im Computer installiert.
Ja, so, das kann auch sein, dass da einfach der fucking Font im Arsch ist.
Eigentlich wollten sie es irgendwie in einem Areal machen.
Aber das, das muss doch auffallen, da muss man es halt nochmal neu machen, ne?
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das ganz bestimmte Marmor oder sonstigen besonderer Stein.
Den sie, Times Roman war nicht installiert.
Den sie, weiß ich nicht, irgendwo aus dem brasilianischen Urwald gehauen haben.
Brasilianischen Urwald? Das ist doch bestimmt irgendwie Carrara-Marmor aus Italien.
Ist ja auch egal, wir wissen das alles nicht. Auf jeden Fall sieht es scheiße
aus. Und ehrlich gesagt, was ich am wenigsten verstehe, ist, dass das passiert.
Okay, meinetwegen. Aber warum ist das noch nicht gefixt?
Oder ist es schon gefixt worden? Haben die sich dazu geäußert?
Wenn die das nicht fixen wollen, dann werde ich ja nicht mal Papst werden wollen.
Wenn man so begraben wird.
Wenn das ein Dank ist.
Aber sonst schon oder wie?
Naja, keine Ahnung. Ich bin ja eigentlich schon Papst.
Wir sind ja alle Päpste. Ich bin ein diskronischer Papst.
Also ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich tot bin, ist mein Grabstein nicht mehr mein Problem.
So will ich nicht begraben werden. Also mit so einem scheiß Körning auf dem
Grabstein, das könnt ihr komplett...
Brauchen wir den nicht kommen.
Könnt ihr komplett vergessen. Da drehe ich mich ja sofort wieder um und komme wieder zurück.
Und dann müsst ihr nochmal 500 Jahre Podcast hören. Also.
Also falls ihr da draußen irgendwo auf Insider-Information Die Geschichte dahinter,
wie das entstanden ist, finde ich wirklich voll interessant. Ich wüsste das gerne.
Also falls da irgendjemand noch weitere Quellen hat, her damit.
Das ist schon wirklich wild.
Das geht gar nicht.
Der Papst. Ja.
Ralf.
Ja.
Du willst noch mal über Star Wars reden.
Ah, genau. Wir müssen über Andor reden.
So, aber du hast es selber noch nicht geguckt, das Ende der zweiten Staffel,
oder die zweite Staffel noch gar nicht angefangen.
Meintest du? Richtig, ich habe sie noch nicht mal begonnen.
Aus Gründen. Was auch immer, Roddy, du guckst das sowieso gar nicht, ne?
Nee.
Okay, so das heißt also, ich werde jetzt Spoiler...
Star Wars nicht oder Andor nicht oder generell keine Star Wars-Serien nicht.
Also ich habe bis jetzt keine Star- Serien gucke ich sowieso nicht, ist nicht so mein Ding.
Star Wars bin ich irgendwann bei Episode 7 rausgeflogen, weil ich die so scheiße fand. Was?
Ich bin bei Episode 7 rausgeflogen, weil ich die so scheiße fand.
Ja, ich fand die scheiße.
7 ist super.
7? Das Rebirthing von Star Wars überhaupt?
Ja, sie erzählen Episode 4 nochmal nach, mit größerem Todessterben.
Aber mit Rey.
Mit BB-8.
Nichts kommt da überraschend in dem Film. Allein schon die erste Szene,
wo der eine Sturmtruper irgendwie Blut abbekommt und damit markiert ist gegenüber
allen anderen anonymen Stormtrooper, da weißt du genau,
der nimmt den Helm ab und bekommt eine besondere Rolle in dem Film. Und natürlich.
Es hat noch kein Blut auf einer Stormtrooper Uniform vorher gegeben.
Ja, weil Stormtrooper waren halt bisher auch immer so schüttgut.
Und gerade in der Szene, Kylo Ren hält einen Laserstrahl in der Luft fest.
Der Anfang ist schon saukool.
In dem Moment, wo er dieses Blut abbekommt, merkst du doch, okay,
der ist jetzt markiert, der ist jetzt was Besonderes, mit dem wird jetzt was passieren.
Und das ist so ein billiges Plot-Device, dass ich gedacht habe,
oh Gott, Leute, das könnt ihr doch nicht machen.
Aber das ist eine Nerd-Krankheit. Ich kann es vorhersehen, wie sich hier irgendwas
entwickelt, deswegen ist es schlecht.
Du möchtest die ganze Zeit ausgekontert und überrascht werden.
Okay, ich verstehe das ja auch, aber ich finde, man kann das auch übertreiben, weil Rey.
Wie, weil Rey?
Die ist halt einfach mal super. Die ist halt super.
Okay, wenn ihr meint.
Okay, also du bist nicht so richtig drin im Star Wars-Plot, ich verstehe das,
aber und dann kann ich ja mal kurz nochmal mal meine Position.
Aber ich spiele momentan Jedi Survivor und finde das eigentlich ganz cool.
Aha!
So, so.
Da spielst du bestimmt auch Rey. Ach nee, kann man nicht.
Dann spielt man so Scarlet Jets und sowas.
Karl heißt der Typ. Ja, stimmt. Ich war jetzt gerade im falschen.
Das ist Karl. K-A-L, Karl. Der hat so einen komischen Roboter auf der Schulter
sitzen, der irgendwie komische Dinge tut.
Gut, damit bin ich nicht vertraut. Also ich bin eigentlich so ein Star Wars Film,
Neuntologie-Fan gewesen, hab dann diese Zwischenfilme wie Rogue One und Solo.
Rogue One fand ich ganz toll, Solo fand ich enttäuschend.
Rogue One hab ich auch gesehen, fand ich auch sehr cool.
Mandalorian fand ich toll. Und nicht nur wegen Baby Yoda, sondern,
Vor allem wegen der Musik. Ich finde das, also ich finde ja ein Star Wars,
Epos muss auch immer einen guten Soundtrack haben, weil da ist einfach der Level so hoch gesetzt.
Also ich meine das einfach, Star Wars ist halt wahrscheinlich.
Naja, Williams hat da Standards gesetzt. Das ist schon richtig.
Die hat er auch in anderen Filmen gesetzt, aber ich glaube, die Star Wars der
Star Wars Soundtrack ist so der Soundtrack überhaupt.
Also du brauchst nur wenige Töne und sagst da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Das Darth Vader Team.
Und alle wissen Bescheid.
Der Imperiale Marsch. Er ist in Episode 5 übrigens dazugekommen,
nicht im allerersten Star Wars Film. Gab es den nicht.
Also noch mehr als die eigentliche Intromusik, die ja auch schon ganz gut reingehauen hat.
Aber generell die ganzen Themen in Star Wars, waren einfach immer sehr stark.
Und die erste Serie, die aus diesem Star Wars-Universum rauskam,
mich hat das früher deshalb nicht interessiert, weil das immer so Cartoon-Kram
war am Anfang. War das ja alles so Cartoon-Serien.
Clone Wars, inhaltlich super.
Ja, aber das hat mich nie abgeholt. Ich habe das auch mal probiert und kann
es nicht ertragen. Sorry, aber ich brauche da richtige Menschen.
Da bin ich irgendwie als schuld, glaube ich, in der Hinsicht.
Auf jeden Fall, Mandalorian hat mich schon komplett an die Wand genagelt mit
dem Soundtrack und ich fand die Serie,
spannend genug, sagen wir es mal so. Rogue One fand ich grandios,
weil da mit Abstand der beste Roboter ist vom ganzen Star Wars Universum.
Ich habe die Zahl gerade vergessen, aber den fand ich einfach saucool.
Er war auch relativ düster. Das fand ich eigentlich ganz cool daran,
dass er so ein bisschen gebrochen hat mit den anderen Filmen und so eigentlich
eine Dystopie gezeigt hat.
K2SO ist das.
Der war wirklich...
Der lange Hagere.
Ja, ja, crazy. Den fand ich super. So, und dann kamen auch noch zwischendurch
so Sachen, dieses Ashoka, das fand ich super schwach.
Und da kam Andor.
Book of Boba Fett gab es noch, müssen wir noch erwähnen. Und es gab noch Uliwan,
müssen wir noch erwähnen.
Fand ich auch ganz schlecht.
Da wird eine Kuh gemolken, Alter.
Also da war viel dabei, was mich nicht umgehauen hat.
Obi-Wan fand ich furchtbar langweilig, Solo fand ich nicht gut,
Ashoka fand ich pointless und Mandalorian fand ich gut.
Rogue One fand ich super und dann kam Andor und da war ich das erste Mal auf dem Level der Filme.
Also für mich war Andor sehr schnell richtig Teil der ganzen Star Wars Erzählungen,
weil es ja auch mal endlich mal was Relevantes der ganzen Star Wars Erzählungen erzählt.
Also es ist ja nicht nur so ein, ja, jetzt haben wir hier nochmal ein Universum
aufgemacht und dann finden da Dinge statt und Mandalorian, ja okay,
alles gut so, aber insgesamt ist dieser ganze Mandalorian-Epos nicht relevant,
der stützt nicht die Gesamterzählung Star Wars.
Und Andor geht halt an die Essenz, so wo fucking kommt die Revolution her?
Wobei wir das jetzt vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen detaillieren können.
Also Rogue One erzählt ja quasi die 24 Stunden vor Episode 4.
Das heißt also Episode 4 fängt ja an mit Leia auf dem Blockadebrecher und wird
von Darth Vaders Sternenzerstörer aufgebracht.
20 Stunden vorher?
Pi mal Daumen, lass es 48 sein.
Ja, okay, aber kurz davor.
Zeitlich sehr komprimiert und der Gap zwischen Ende Rogue One zur Intro-Sequenz
von Episode 4 sind wahrscheinlich,
bestenfalls Stunden, vielleicht sogar nur Minuten, je nachdem wie schnell die
wohin gesprungen und wieder aufgebracht worden sind.
Also das geht wirklich ganz direkt ineinander über.
So, und was jetzt Andor macht, ist quasi die Vorgeschichte zu Rogue One erzählen.
Das heißt also nach Episode 3 und zwar etliche Jahre nach Episode 3 wie ist es jetzt zu der.
Rebellion oder wie sind die Urgründe eigentlich der Rebellion die dann quasi
zu dem Anfangssetup von Rogue One führen.
Achtung, wir müssen die Pläne vom Todesstern stehlen.
Damit Luke irgendwann den Torpedo in den Schacht reinschießen kann.
So und ursprünglich war Andor auf fünf Seasons ausgelegt, also fünf Staffeln
sollten es eigentlich sein und jeweils ein Jahr Abstand dazwischen und sie haben aber gemerkt, okay,
die erste Season lief für sie gut, im Sinne künstlerisch wurden sie dafür sehr
gefeiert, kann da gleich noch was zu sagen,
aber sie haben dann gemerkt, okay, wenn wir jetzt in dem Tempo weitermachen,
sind unsere Darsteller einfach zu alt, um das irgendwie plausibel in diese Zeitschnie noch reinzubringen.
Sie haben halt den Original-Hauptdarsteller aus Rogue One genommen oder den
männlichen Hauptdarsteller, es sind ja zwei, das ist ein Tandem in Rogue One.
Und der ist dann einfach mal in Real 20 Jahre älter, als wir Rogue One gespielt
haben. Das kriegen wir irgendwie auch mit digitaler Verjüngung,
das macht alles keinen Sinn mehr.
Wir machen nur noch eine zweite Season, das ist auch kommerziell nicht so ein
Riesenerfolg gewesen, die erste Season.
Und wir komprimieren das so, dass wir dort Zeitsprünge einbauen.
Und zwar war schon Episode Season 1 schon so konzipiert, dass es immer so Dreierblöcke
von Serien, von Folgen gab.
So also Folge 1, 2, 3 bildeten so einen Arc, Folge 2, 3, 4 bildeten so einen Arc und so weiter.
Die also in Sicht so eine Innengeschichte erzählt haben.
1, 2, 3 und 2, 3, 4.
Nein, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Habe ich gerade Quatsch erzählt? 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12. Waren vier Arcs.
Einer davon war auf diesem Gefängnisplaneten und so weiter.
so und das haben sie sich gesagt, so das machen wir jetzt bei Season 2 genauso,
nur mit Zeitsprüngen dazwischen, ein Jahr das heißt also, um noch irgendwie
auf ihre 5 Staffeln zu kommen, haben sie gesagt, so wir machen wieder diese
3er Blöcke, das hat schon gut funktioniert beim ersten Mal und bauen jetzt die,
so, dass man ein Jahr Gap dazwischen hat und,
nehmen das quasi so als künstlerisches Mittel, so und mehr will ich jetzt in
die Inhalte da gar nicht reingehen, weil das wir dann spoilern und du musst
es dir schon angucken Ich will aber eine Sache zeigen,
die finde ich interessant ist und wo dann vielleicht noch wir schon einen ersten
Einstieg haben in, wie hießen deine Listen?
Welche Listen?
Tierlist.
Tierlist, ganz genau. So, ein Dienst, den ich hier schon ein paar Mal promotet
habe, Rating Graph, der, das muss jetzt mal meinen Link mal aufrufen und wir
beschreiben, was wir sehen, besonders beliebt in einem Podcast.
Ja.
So, also der Dienst, den ich hier wieder mal nehme, ist Rating Graph.
Wir erinnern uns, schon ein paar Mal hier vorgekommen in der Freak Show,
die greifen einfach die API von IMDb ab, also der zentralen Film- und Seriendatenbank
im Internet, wo alle voten können, wie gut einzelne Episoden oder einzelne Filme sind.
War das das, was wir hatten mit dieser Trilogie-Geschichte und so?
Genau. So, jetzt kannst du ein bisschen nach unten scrollen.
Jetzt sieht man also hier, wie die beiden Seasons von Andor jetzt auf IMDb bewertet werden.
Die erste in schwarz mit Quadraten und die zweite in grün mit Dreiecken.
Und die zweite in grün mit Dreiecken, ganz genau. So, und wir sehen schon mal, dass...
Das auch ja bei IMDb, wie hattest du es vorhin genannt? Nicht 10er System?
Ja.
Du hast ja schon gesagt, so 10 darf quasi nichts bekommen.
Das stimmt auch. Ich glaube, es gibt praktisch nichts auf IMDb, was eine 10,0 hat.
Aber es gibt halt schon Dinge, die es über 9 schaffen. Ja.
So und es gibt nicht wirklich viele Folgen von Serien, egal wie renommiert,
die es über einen neuen schaffen.
Und wenn man sich die erste Season von Andor anguckt, dann haben es drei Folgen
geschafft von zwölf, über die 9,0 rüber zu kommen.
Nämlich hier die 06er, das ist der Abschluss vom 2.
zweiten Arc, dann die E10, das ist quasi die Flucht aus dem Gefängnis,
das ist bisher die bestgeratetste gewesen.
Beginn des vierten Arcs.
Oder Beginn des vierten Arcs. Ja, aber es ist trotzdem inhaltlich das und dann
halt die Abschlussepisode.
Die haben es alle drei über 9-0 geschafft und dazwischen ist dann aber so ein
bisschen Kruppzeug, was irgendwie so um 8 rum sich platziert.
Kruppzeug.
Nur eine Arme und 8.
Wenn wir jetzt die zweite Season angucken, dann passiert dir etwas sehr,
sehr, sehr Ungewöhnliches.
So, wir sehen nämlich so, der erste Arc ist unter 8, gar nicht mal so toll, alle drei Folgen.
Der zweite Arc liegt zwischen 8 und 9, also so in dem, wo Andor bisher angesiedelt war.
So, und dann aber der dritte und
vierte Arc haben wir fünf Folgen hintereinander, deutlich über eine 9,0.
Auch über 9,5.
Auch über 9,5. Das ist nahezu an Hört Off.
Könnt ihr euch jetzt die alten Folgen anhören. Wir haben ja schon mal über Andor
gesprochen und ich hatte mit der ersten Season große Schwierigkeiten aus verschiedenen
Gründen, die ich jetzt gar nicht alle wiederholen möchte.
Und war jetzt also gespannt auf die zweite Season und muss sagen, wie so häufig.
Man kann jetzt diese IMDb-Score immer kritisieren, es ist alles Mainstream und
so weiter, aber es gibt so ein paar Wahrheiten, die sich da schon abbilden.
Und eine dieser Wahrheiten ist, wenn es eine IMDb-Score größer 9 hat,
dann passiert da schon was Relevantes.
Von daher war ich entsprechend gespannt und ich bin hier voll auf dem IMDb-Trip unterwegs.
Diese letzten 5 Folgen von Undor Season 2 sind wirklich spektakulär.
Was sie da raushauen, nicht im Sinne von, es ist wahnsinnige Effekte oder sowas,
sondern wie gespannt man da ist,
wie sehr man da plötzlich in dieser Story drin ist, das ist schon sehr,
sehr, sehr bemerkenswert, sodass ich da so jetzt meinen Frieden mit Andor definitiv gemacht habe.
Wie schön.
Jetzt ist aber an euch die Frage, was glaubt ihr denn, gibt es irgendeine andere
Serie, die das geschafft hat, fünf Folgen hintereinander über 9-0 zu kommen?
Tja, also ich bin hier schon vom Chat gespoilt, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Wo steht, dass es nur im Anime-Bereich bisher so war?
Das ist falsch.
Okay, dann, was ist die Wahrheit?
Obwohl, ja, ja, ja, also Steffen schreibt hier, Wertung 9,5 oder besser. Gut, das mag sein.
Ich würde jetzt jetzt ein bisschen aufweichen über 9.
Was erlaubt. Okay.
So, was glaubt ihr denn so? Wo ihr denkt, das sind Prämienserien,
die mal so einen richtigen Strike hatten.
Severance Na dann tipp doch mal ein in die Suche Der Chat darf live mitmachen.
Da habe ich jetzt wirklich wenig...
So, Steffen bringt Breaking Bad ins Spiel. Mach erstmal Severance.
Ich kann hier nichts eintippen.
Du kannst da nichts eintippen.
Weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich wegen irgendeinem...
Ach, Timme.
Was denn?
Ich kann auch nichts eintippen.
Technik.
Muss ich hier wieder erst meinen Inhaltsblocker ausschalten oder so?
Eigentlich mach mal einen Reload von der Seite einfach.
Habe ich schon...
So, eigentlich sollte die problemlos sich neu laden lassen.
Ja.
Kannst du mit dem Tab das Feld, was ist denn alles für komisches Zeug?
Ah, jetzt.
Die blöden Privacy-Cookies, Scheiße muss ich wahrscheinlich,
ja, jetzt geht's Severance. Severance 22.
So, da sehen wir.
Guck mal, hat hier drei, fast neun.
So, das Season Final von Severance Staffel 1 hat es auf eine sehr,
sehr respektable 9,7 geschafft.
Die davor, die aber auch schon nicht schlecht waren, alle unter 9.
Das heißt, Season 1 hat es nicht geschafft und Season 2 von Severance hat drei
Folgen über 9,0 hinbekommen, aber jeweils mit deutlich schlechter Bewerterin
dazwischen. Das heißt also nicht 5 in a row.
Die wissen ja gar nicht, was gut ist.
So, jetzt machen wir Breaking Bad.
Was ich natürlich auch nicht gesehen habe Was?
Oh Gott im Himmel Ja.
Das ist irgendwie mit Nadeln und so Irgendwas.
So, müsste unten schon geladen sein.
Hoch.
Oh, this one goes to 11.
11?
So, und da sehen wir in der Tat, dass die letzte Season, also die Season 5 von
Breaking Bad, fast durchgängig über 9,0 war.
Hier ist eine 10 auch.
Da ist auch eine 10,0.
Stimmt das?
Das stimmt, die Daten stimmen, ja.
Echt? Die wird immer besser? Okay.
Das heißt also da, ich habe die letzte Season auch nicht so stark in Erinnerung,
wenn ihr mich jetzt gefragt hättest, hätte ich auch gesagt, so die 2 und die
3 sind irgendwie so die besten,
aber das Internet ist da in der Tat anderer Meinung, genau.
So, das nächste, hätte ich auch nämlich gesagt, das von mir so geliebte Lost.
Und da sehen wir, Lost schafft es auch und zwar in Season 3.
Wo ich auch wirklich sagen würde, das Ende von Season 3 ist überhaupt das Beste
an Television, was es je gesehen hat.
Und die schaffen auch 5 in a row über 9,0.
Bis auf eine schöne respektabel, ich glaube 9,8 oder sowas ist das.
Tja, keine Ahnung mehr, was da war in Season 3, aber war auf jeden Fall ganz schön spannend.
Das ist das mit dem Sprung in die Zukunft statt in die Vergangenheit. We have to go back, Kate.
Wo plötzlich das Pattern gebrochen wurde, dass es gar keine Rückblenden waren,
die man gesehen hat, sondern...
Schon zu lange her.
So, und jetzt mach aber nochmal Tschernobyl.
Sowas gibt's?
Sowas gibt's.
Als Serie?
Tim.
Ja?
Das hab ja selbst ich mitbekommen, aber wie schreiben die dich?
Ich nicht.
So nicht gerade. Du hast irgendwo einen Tippfehler drin. Mach mal...
Wie, was, wo? Chernobyl?
Das ist eigentlich eine Serie. Ja, nee. Ja, mach das mal an,
aber eigentlich ist das in einem
Jahr dürfte das nur sein. Muss man eben gucken. Irgendwo hast du dann.
Episode eine Serie, fünf.
Das ist eine Season, oder?
Naja doch, das stimmt schon. Jetzt stimmt auch die Jahreszahl 2019.
So, jetzt guck dir mal das Ranking an.
Eine Serie, die nur aus fünf Episoden besteht?
Die nur aus fünf Episoden besteht und alle deutlich über der 9-0.
Das heißt also von 9-4 auf 9-6, auf einmal 9-3 runter und dann das Ende auf 9-8.
Das heißt also, das ist von allem, ich habe da wirklich mal ein Stündchen rumgesucht
und bin auch einfach so die 100 bestbewertetsten Serien insgesamt durchgegangen
und von all denen ist Tschernobyl die einzige, die es schafft,
wirklich sämtliche Einzelepisoden über 9 zu kriegen.
Wo ich auch sagen würde, völlig zu Recht.
Habe ich auch schon mal hier im Podcast, bin ich mir relativ sicher,
angepriesen. Ich würde sagen, dass Tschernobyl die derzeit beste Serie der Welt
ist, was so Konstanz und Kompression angeht.
Und das ist jetzt das Beste oder was sagt hier PMI oder von allen oder wie?
Genau, also da gibt es einfach keinen, das ist auch eine Serie,
die von den ersten 20 Sekunden dich schon packt.
Die machen also wirklich keine Gefangenen. Also von Anfang bis Ende sitzt du
da auf der Bettkante, obwohl du schon weißt, wie alles ausgeht.
Also wer das noch nicht gesehen hat, Tschernobyl, müsst ihr euch anschauen.
Ich wusste noch nicht mal, dass es das gibt.
Mann, Mann, Mann.
Deucht, ich wusste, dass es gibt. Die Diskussion, wie nah das an der Realität
ist, die hat sehr hohe Wellen geschlagen.
Okay. Weiß nicht, ob mich das so reizen würde, aber ja, okay.
Also wenn dich davon die ersten zehn Minuten nicht packen, dann kannst du es auch ausmachen.
Also das ist halt der Vorteil. Da weiß man sofort, was los ist.
Das ist wirklich groß. Naja,
aber in dieser erlauchten Liga, Also es stand ja vorhin wahrscheinlich drin,
so im Anime-Bereich gibt es halt dann noch etliche Serien,
wo dann halt wirklich die jeweiligen Fanbases dann einfach entsprechend voten,
was auch total legitim ist, aber das halt nicht so richtig in den Mainstream
halt irgendwie reinschafft.
und halt irgendwelche Serien, wo insgesamt irgendwie nur tausend Leute für abgestimmt
haben und die dann halt irgendwie ihren Fanclub motiviert haben.
Die schaffen sowas schon auch, aber von den größeren Mainstream-Serien sind
das also jetzt die, die ich überhaupt nur gefunden habe.
Da steht noch The Wire. Nee, The Wire kommt mit Sicherheit nicht in solche Regionen hin.
Einzelne Episoden ja, aber mit Sicherheit nicht fünf in a row.
Nee, ich hab schon geguckt.
Ja, genau. Wir haben Einzelne, die drüber sind. True Detective kann ich mir
auch nicht vorstellen, dass es da ist. Interessant ist auch Game of Thrones.
Das ist auch ein Klassiker auch davon. Oh, was haben wir denn da?
Ist das True Detective gerade?
Ah, okay.
Der ist ja richtig abgestürzt.
Die erste Season liegt hier aber auch gut los. Okay, die True Detective Season
1 ist auch in dem Club drin.
Die haben sechs in a row über 9-0. Von überhaupt nur acht Folgen.
Aber baut dann alles total ab und das Season-Finale ist nicht so.
Okay, hat keinen Spaß gemacht.
Game of Thrones kannst du nochmal machen. Da ist es sehr erwartbar.
Die waren ja quasi bekannt dafür, dass sie halt auch so einzelne,
sehr spektakuläre, herausragende Serien Folgen haben.
Okay, das Ende muss ja wirklich scheiße gewesen sein.
Die schaffen es halt so fast. Du kannst mal gucken, ob die vierte Season es
vielleicht sogar schafft. Ob der eine Ausreißer genau auf der neuen Null sitzt.
Siehst du das? die vierte Season und dann die letzten fünf Folgen.
Dieses Overlay hier nicht so nervig.
Das Blaue, links, links, runter, runter, runter.
Was soll ich?
Da jetzt den Episode 7 ist das glaube ich.
Den rechts drüber. Der hat eine neue 0. Ah doch, okay. Game of Thrones schafft es auch mit Season 4.
Die letzten fünf Episoden sind alle über 9-0.
Also, wenn man 9-0 als über 9-0 bezeichnet.
Ja, ja. Du klug scheißer, du.
Naja, also, wenn ihr da draußen noch mehr Serien irgendwie findet, werft es mir mal rüber.
Hast du Game of Thrones auch komplett geguckt?
Ja, natürlich.
Und ist das Ende wirklich so scheiße?
Ah, wie viele Stunden haben wir denn Zeit? Also, das Problem ist ja,
das Problem ist ja, dass die letzten, ich glaube, anderthalb Seasons halt ohne
die Buchvorlagen von Romeo auskommen mussten.
Und die haben sich halt mit ihm abgestimmt, so was hast du denn ungefähr vor
und wenn du es nochmal irgendwann schreiben würdest, was er jetzt glaube ich
auch nicht mehr tut, ich glaube der hat einfach keinen Bock mehr,
wie wird es denn dann ausgehen? Wir müssen es jetzt wissen.
Und das hat dann halt den Fans alles nur noch so semi gut gefallen,
weil die Qualität der Dialoge wurde halt schwächer, viele Handlungsstränge,
die vorher sehr liebevoll aufgebaut worden sind.
Dass sie die Serie starten, bevor die irgendwie zu Ende geschrieben werden.
Ja, aber was willst du denn machen, wenn der Typ nur alle sechs Jahre ein Buch schreibt?
Dann wartest du halt noch sechs Jahre.
Ja, dann sind deine Darsteller aber zu alt.
Dann nimmst du halt andere. Fingst du gerade nicht erst an.
Also das Kreativ-Dilemma, da konnte ich schon nachvollziehen.
Aber jetzt das Season-Finale ist auch keine 4-0.
Und so schlecht ist die letzte Season auch nicht. Da passieren auch noch ganz coole Sachen.
Die Leute sind einfach nur...
Das ist schon Hater-Fandom hier.
Das siehst du aber bei The Witcher auch ganz gut, dass er richtig abgestürzt ist.
Ja, da haben sie den Lieblingshauptdarsteller auch ausgetauscht.
Ja, vor allen Dingen war der ja so, der war ja so ein Advokat für das Original
und wie das richtig sein muss und so weiter und dann hat sie das genervt,
haben sie den ausgetauscht und haben dann irgendwie freigedreht und dann sind
die Fans davon gelaufen.
Tja, naja, das ist also finde ich ein schöner Sport, mal immer wieder gucken,
was da auf Rating Graph sich so abbildet.
Und von daher, also freut euch Andor Season 2, da habt ihr was vor euch.
Dann weiß ich ja zumindest, weil das werde ich mit Sicherheit tun,
zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt.
Okay, Roddy, wollen wir nochmal Spanien aufrufen kurz?
Ja, ich will das relativ kurz halten.
Es hat ja wahrscheinlich jeder mitbekommen, wie lange ist es her?
zwei Wochen oder so, dass in Spanien ein kompletter Stromausfall war,
also die gesamte iberische Halbinsel.
Spanien und Portugal waren komplett dunkel.
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, auch irgendwie über eine Stunde oder sogar mehrere Stunden.
Das hat ganz schön lange gedauert teilweise, ja.
Das hat relativ lange gedauert.
Um es kurz zu machen, ist es immer noch nicht so ganz klar, was da eigentlich
passiert ist, was was da der Root Cause war.
Aber ich habe da so ein bisschen geguckt und es gibt bei YouTube ein Video zu dem Thema.
Eins, da gibt es viele.
Ja, da gibt es viele Videos von Leuten, die keine Ahnung haben.
Das braucht man jetzt so nicht.
Aber ich habe eins gefunden. Na, okay, ich muss hier den Slack aufmachen oder ihr postet das mal eben.
Ich habe eins gefunden von zwei Professoren, die sich da unterhalten bzw.
der eine macht einen Vortrag.
Und ich sag's mal so, wenn ihr nicht studiert habt und irgendwie das Gefühl
habt, euch ist was entgangen, weil ihr nicht studiert habt,
dann guckt euch dieses Video an, guckt euch diese Folien an,
guckt euch diesen Professor an, diesen Professor Fette, dann geht das Gefühl
ein bisschen weg, weil viele Professoren sind so.
Also die Folien sind richtig schlimm. Der Typ schwadroniert auch so ein bisschen
um den heißen Brei herum, beziehungsweise erzählt halt auch Dinge,
die er gerne erzählt, die nicht so ganz was damit zu tun haben.
Trotzdem sind da sehr, sehr viele Erkenntnisse drin in diesem Video.
Und da steht Teil 3.
Da steht Teil 3, ja. Der dritte Teil ist auch der spannendste.
Man kann sich auch die anderen beiden Teile noch angucken, wenn man so eine
gewisse Leidensfähigkeit mitbringt.
Wie schlimm ist das denn? Was empfiehst du denn hier Sachen,
die irgendwie schlecht vorgetragen sind, aber auch schlechtes Leid haben und
noch nicht mal die Lösung bringen?
Ja, aber der Typ, der beschreibt relativ ausführlich, wie komplex es tatsächlich
ist, so ein Netz zu betreiben.
Und zwar, wir sprechen hier von dem europäischen Verbundnetz.
Es gibt Leute, die behaupten, das europäische Verbundnetz wäre die größte Maschine der Welt,
weil es geht halt von Portugal bis nach Lettland beziehungsweise runter Griechenland.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Türkei auch noch dran hängt.
Bekannt sind so Phänomene wie, dass es tatsächliche Wellenphänomene gibt,
Ost-West in, ich glaube 0,15 Hertz waren das und Nord-Süd in 0,25 Hertz,
das sagt er glaube ich im zweiten Vortrag,
Interessant ist dabei, ja genau, Türkei ist auch noch dabei.
Nicht nur das, auch Marokko, Algerien, Tunesien.
Ja.
Krass.
Ja, so und jetzt ist es so, Spanien ist an dieses Netz angeschlossen über zwei
Kopplungspunkte nach Frankreich.
Und das ist eine Besonderheit von Spanien. Die Franzosen wollen quasi ihre Kernkraft
gut verkaufen und möchten möglichst wenig Solarstrom aus Spanien in ihrem Netz haben.
Deswegen haben sie relativ schwache Verbindungsknoten in die iberische Halbinsel rein.
Aber das geht auch both ways. Also ich meine, wenn sie ihren Atomstrom verkaufen
wollen, dann brauchen sie doch auch dicke Leitungen oder nicht?
Whatever. Auf jeden Fall führt es dazu, dass das Netz der iberischen Halbinsel
stärker in sich selbst hineinwirkt als in den Rest des Netzes.
Trotzdem ist es also so, dass in Spanien Schwingungen aufgetreten sind,
die man auch in Deutschland und in Lettland messen konnte.
Also die auch schon Tage vorher waren bzw. Stunden vorher am gleichen Tag.
Es wird ja immer wieder gefragt, war das jetzt ein Hackerangriff?
Sehr wahrscheinlich nicht. Also klar, man kann es nicht sagen,
aber so wie die Kennzahlen aussehen, ist nicht so, dass die irgendwo ein Kraftwerk
lahmgelegt haben und dann ist das Netz zusammengefallen,
weil 2019, glaube ich, war das so, dass der...
Dass denen der Netzübertragungspunkt nach Frankreich ausgefallen ist oder die
Franzosen hatten ein Problem.
Auf jeden Fall ist in Spanien nur ein Teil des Netzes ausgefallen und nicht das gesamte Netz.
Interessant, wie gesagt, sind diese Schwingungen, du hast jetzt gerade Wikipedia
aufgemacht, dieser Abfall der Netzfrequenz.
Dazu ganz kurz. Also das Netz wird geregelt einmal über die Netzfrequenz.
Wenn die runter geht, ist es ein Zeichen dafür, dass zu wenig Strom da ist.
Das heißt, die Kraftwerke müssen mehr liefern. Wenn die Netzfrequenz zu hoch
ist, dann ist es ein Zeichen, dass zu viel Strom im Netz ist.
Die Kraftwerke müssen abregeln. Das kommt aus einer Zeit, wo man Generatoren hatte, die drehen.
Und wenn quasi zu viel Last im Netz ist, also zu viel Strom wird verbraucht,
dann bremst es die Generatoren zu stark und dann geht die Frequenz runter.
Wenn zu wenig Strom abgenommen wird, dann drehen die frei und werden schneller.
Deswegen hat man diese Kopplung aus Frequenz und Netzbelastung.
Gleichzeitig hast du natürlich auch noch Spannung in dem Netz,
aber das wird zum Regeln irgendwie weniger verwendet.
Jetzt hast du das Problem, dass du relativ viele erneuerbare Energien hast.
Und erneuerbare Energien und Leute, die das alte Freakshow-Trinkspiel machen,
ihr dürft jetzt trinken, ich sage Wechselrichter.
Erneuerbare Energien haben in der Regel Wechselrichter, die einfach sich auf
die Frequenz synchronisieren, wie sie im Netz ist und fertig.
Die machen sonst nichts weiter.
Die wirken auf das Netz nicht so wie ein drehender Generator.
Deswegen sagen viele, okay, die Erneuerbaren sind wahrscheinlich schuld.
Das ist aber Quatsch, weil zum Beispiel Spanien hat noch deutlich mehr Generatorkraftwerke,
als es zum Beispiel Deutschland hat, in Bereichen, wo sehr viele Erneuerbare im Netz sind.
Und es war glaube ich auch nicht mal ein Tag, wo besonders viele Erneuerbare,
also es waren Erneuerbare drin, aber die Parameter waren nicht so,
wie sie die Wochen vorher nicht auch schon öfter gewesen waren.
Auch da gab es so leichte Labilitäten.
Interessant auch, neuartige Verbraucher nenne ich es jetzt mal,
vor allen Dingen Elektroautos, aber auch viele andere Verbraucher,
die sehr viel Schmutz im Netz machen.
Also da gibt es dann Schwingungen anderer Art, die dadurch entstehen,
dass zum Beispiel ein Laderegler für einen Akku für ein Auto halt immer an und
aus und immer aus und an und aus und an und aus macht und dann eine Frequenz ins Netz ausstrahlt,
die da nicht hingehört, die man aber mitunter schlecht wegdämpfen kann.
Also alle Frequenzen, die unterhalb der Netzfrequenz sind, kannst du eigentlich nicht dämpfen.
Es sei denn mit diesen großen Generatoren, wenn sie nicht zu groß werden und so weiter und so weiter.
Des Weiteren kommt dazu, schon
in den 1940er Jahren gab es einen deutschen Elektrotechnik-Professor,
Doktor, Nerd, sonst was, der bewiesen hat,
dass also tatsächlich ein Netz, was nur aus rotierenden Erzeugern besteht,
auch instabil werden kann.
Und das alles habe ich jetzt nur erzählt, um zu sagen, man kann nicht auf die
Erneuerbaren mit dem Finger zeigen,
man kann auch nicht auf die neuartigen Verbraucher mit dem Finger zeigen,
man kann letzten Endes auch nicht auf die Regelung zeigen, die die Spanier da gemacht haben,
sondern es ist nach wie vor unklar, was da wirklich passiert ist.
Also es gibt keinen Abschlussbericht von irgendeiner Kommission.
Viele Leute haben viele komische Ideen, aber im Großen und Ganzen weiß man es immer noch nicht.
Ich fand das interessant, wie stark tatsächlich,
wie schwierig es ist, so ein Netz tatsächlich zu betreiben und zu steuern,
weil jede Regelung hat einen Hang zum Schwingen,
wenn nicht ein Ingenieur genau ausgerechnet hat, wie er die auslegen muss,
dass sie nicht schwingt oder die Evolution das hin evolutioniert hat.
Wie gesagt, also ich kann den Vortrag eigentlich verstehen, eigentlich empfehlen
kann jeden, verstehe jeden, der sagt, das kann ich mir nicht angucken, das ist mir jetzt krass.
Aber der Herr Fette wird ja auch in der Wikipedia zitiert.
Mit der Aussage, dass die Vermutung aufgestellt habe, dass Inter-Area-Oszillationen
eine Ursache für den Netzkollaps in Spanien sein könnten.
Ja, Inter-Area, wie nennen die das? Inter-Area-Schwingungen.
Also das Problem ist so ein bisschen, das gesamte Netz schwingt natürlich so
ein bisschen wie eine Gitarrenseite beziehungsweise wie so ein Rohr von so einer Kirchenorgel.
Und dann hast du im Prinzip Reflektionen an den Netzgrenzen.
Was dazu führt, dass du in der Mitte des Netzes und an den Netzen entgrenzen
die größten Ausschläge hast.
Was man auch in den Daten sieht, wo zum Beispiel dann in Lettland auch große
Ausschläge registriert wurden.
Die sind natürlich auf dem Weg dahin gedämpft worden, aber auch die konnten
messen, was die Spanier gemessen hatten,
nämlich dass sie allerlei Schwingungen, besonders die Schwingung,
ich glaube doppelte Netzfrequenz, so um die 100 Hertz, hatten sie ein größeres
Problem und die Schwingung ist ihnen auch so ein bisschen aus dem Ruder gelaufen,
sodass man durchaus davon ausgehen kann, dass Schutzeinrichtungen abgeschaltet haben.
Das ist ja hier das, was hier steht. Über die Toleranzgrenzen hinausgehende
Frequenz- und Spannungsschwankungen in den Netzen, die dann letztlich automatische
Schutzvorrichtungen an Kraftwerken aller Art und Leitung Auslösung,
die dann kaskadenartig innerhalb von Sekunden das gesamte Netz kollabieren lassen.
Interessant an den Daten ist halt, dass du tatsächlich 20 Minuten vorher oder
so eigentlich eine noch viel größere Schwingung siehst, als die,
die dann das Netz kollabieren lässt.
Was auch so ein bisschen weird ist, aber keine Ahnung, wie da die Grenzwerte sind.
So ein bisschen wie beim Tsunami, wenn sich das Meer erstmal zurückzieht.
Vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Was da nochmal richtig zuschlägt.
Also klar, als das Ding, als die Kaskade dann angefangen hat,
war natürlich alles zu spät, weil wenn erstmal genug Strom fehlt,
sich dann nach und nach die ganzen Kraftwerke abschalten, weil sie halt das
dann auch nicht liefern können.
Und irgendwie haben sie es auch nicht geschafft, irgendwie das Netz so weit
aufzutrennen, dass die Kaskade nicht durch die ganze iberische Halbinsel durchläuft.
Ich frage mich, ob sich generell in Zukunft diese Netzstabilität nennenswert
dadurch erhöhen lassen wird, dass wir mehr Batterien auf Netzebene zum Einsatz bringen,
die da als Ausgleich dienen können.
dass die diese Frequenzgeschichte so weit stabilisieren können,
um solche Resonanzvorgänge, gehen wir mal davon aus, das war jetzt der Grund,
keine Ahnung, verstehe ich auch eher alles nur zur Hälfte.
Ja, die Frage, da geht er in Teil 3 auch drauf ein, die Frage ist,
wie schnell kann ich messen, was passiert, um gegenregeln zu können.
Und wenn ich zu langsam messe, um gegenzuregeln, dann kann mir das passieren,
dass ich eher genau das Gegenteil erreiche von dem, was ich erreichen will,
je nachdem in welcher Frequenz das Netz schwingt.
Und wenn ich ihn richtig verstanden habe, geht er davon aus,
dass die Lösung wahrscheinlich eher ist, dass in der Zukunft Wechselrichter
so ausgelegt werden müssen,
dass sie tatsächlich bei einer Unterspannung auch die Frequenz nach unten ziehen.
beziehungsweise bei einer Überspannung auch die Frequenz nach oben ziehen,
sodass die Gesamtregelung des Netzes einfacher wird.
Aber da müsste man ja quasi die Funktionen aller Wechselrichter ändern.
Im Prinzip ja.
Kann man das nicht mit AI lösen?
Bestimmt.
Also dieser Fette, das ist halt der aus dem Video,
Der erzählt da auch noch ein bisschen mehr, zeigt auch ein paar Kurven,
die man nicht auf Anhieb versteht, selbst wenn man wie ich Elektrotechnik studiert hat.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es so,
dem traue ich noch am ehesten zu, dass wenn er sagt, ist nicht klar,
was da passiert ist, dass er das gut einschätzen kann und nicht andere Leute,
die sich schon drauf eingeschossen haben, was es jetzt genau war.
Ja, also ein Hackerangriff war es ziemlich sicher nicht.
Es sei denn, da hat jemand sehr viele sehr leistungsstarke Wechselrichter irgendwie
gehackt unter seine Kontrolle bekommen und in der richtigen Art und Weise manipuliert.
Dann würde das gehen, aber davon gibt es eigentlich bis jetzt keine Spur, dass das passiert ist.
Insofern ist es wahrscheinlich alles einfach nur ein normales elektrotechnisches Phänomen.
Das ist schon krass, wie das alles so wegkippen kann.
Was erstaunlich ist, ist, wie schnell sie es geschafft haben,
eigentlich das gesamte Netz wieder an den Start zu bringen, weil andere Leute sagen immer,
kompletter Kaltstart des gesamten Netzes ist ein Horrorszenario und die haben
das offensichtlich einfach mal so hingekriegt.
Also insofern ist es auch ein gutes Trainingsfeld oder ein gutes Anschauungsmaterial,
dass man halt ein Netz auch irgendwie wieder anfahren können muss.
Okay, das ganze Video ist ja auf dem Kanal von Stefan Krauter,
ist das nicht der Solarpapst auf Mastodon?
Weiß ich nicht. Der ist auf jeden Fall jemand, der, ja, also du merkst,
die Leute leben in einer anderen Welt.
Ja.
Also ich weiß, ich habe von dem Krauter jetzt noch nicht so viel gesehen, aber ich, ja, ähm.
Schau gerade, ich meine, dass das der ist.
Wo du gerade sagst, erstaunlich, wie schnell sie es wieder hochgefahren haben.
Das ganze Thema fasst mich insofern gerade etwas an, weil wir vor zwei Wochen
an der ZLB mal in einer Spaß-Abend-Veranstaltung Neustart gespielt haben. Kennt ihr das?
Das ist so ein halbdidaktisches Spiel.
Ich werfe mal einen Link in die Shownotes. wo es darum geht,
dass man nach einem sehr ähnlich gelagerten Blackout eine Stadt verwalten muss.
Und jetzt ist hier irgendwie, eben hattet ihr die Schwierigkeiten,
jetzt kann ich hier gerade nichts in den Slack reinposten, warum das nicht?
Tja, so habt es überall nur Päpste, meine Herren.
Ja, ist krass, oder?
Und das dauert fünf Tage, bis da der Strom wiederkommt. Man muss quasi eine
Stadt, Kleinstadt managen, dass sie nicht in Anarchie und Chaos versinkt während
dieser fünf Tage Stromausfall.
Ganz lustig.
Okay.
Ich denke, dass aus diesem Vorfall noch sehr viele Learnings entstehen werden.
Und ich denke, wir werden auch sehen, dass die Regularien zum Thema Wechselrichter
nochmal angepasst werden.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das keine Folgen hat, was die Standardisierung
von den Dingern anbelangt.
auch wenn die jetzt vielleicht nicht zentral die Ursache waren,
aber sie waren auf jeden Fall ein verstärkender Faktor,
ja interessant.
Also jetzt wollen sie wohl eine Kommission einsetzen die in sechs Monaten berichtet,
was jetzt wirklich der Grund war, vielleicht finden sie es ja auch aus.
Ich bleib dran, wenn da was interessantes in dem Dokument steht.
Dann wird Freakshow berichten Ja.
Naja, gut aber nur wenn was Interessantes drinsteht wenn da nur drinsteht,
dass es auch nicht so ja okay, werden wir auch, egal,
ja
So, wir kommen langsam dem Ende entgegen. Wir könnten es mit Pizza abschließen.
Das ist doch eine gute Idee. Das machen wir.
Pizza ist ja auch für alle da irgendwie.
Pizza ist für alle da, schmeckt aber nicht immer gut.
Es gibt auch schlecht schmeckende Pizzas. So ist das Leben.
Man muss schon viel falsch machen. Weiß ich nicht, die Aussage ziehe ich zurück.
Besser so. Ich würde jetzt gar nicht so sehr in die Details der perfekten neapolitanischen
Pizza, wir wissen 400 Grad und nur 70, 80 Sekunden im Ofen und sowas,
da würde ich jetzt gar nicht einsteigen, sondern in dem Problem,
was durch Lieferdienste entsteht, die dann diese schöne, perfekte Pizza aus
dem Ofen nehmen, dem Steinofen mit irgendwie ordentlich Holz befeuert und sowas und in,
die Pappschachtel verladen und dann nach Hause bringen und dann packst du sie
aus und es ist labberig und lauwarm und man isst sie dann trotzdem ganz gerne,
weil das gehört ja irgendwie so zum Feeling dazu,
aber dann schafft man es vielleicht nicht, sie ganz aufzuessen.
Und dann hast du sie da am nächsten Tag stehen, kalt und labberig.
Obwohl kalte Pizza am nächsten Tag sehr lecker sein kann.
Muss nicht schlecht sein.
Muss nicht schlecht sein. Aber was wäre, wenn ich euch sagen will,
dass es mit sehr wenig Aufwand möglich ist,
diese labberige, kalte Pizza vom Vortag in einen Zustand zu bringen,
der ziemlich dicht dran ist an dem ist, wie sie aus dem Ofen rausgekommen ist.
Ja, ich weiß auch, wie das geht.
Du weißt auch, wie das geht.
Man nennt es Heißluftfritteuse.
Nee.
Doch.
Also vielleicht auch, aber ich habe eine andere Methode, die noch einfacher
ist, weil du brauchst keine Heißloch-Fritöse für.
Genau. Dieses Wissen ist wahrscheinlich schon 20 Jahre alt.
Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe das auch erst vor ein paar Jahren entdeckt.
Nicht breit genug verbreitet. Erzähl doch mal, was du tust.
Ich sage Pfanne. Einfach in eine Pfanne rein, vielleicht noch einen Schluck Wasser dazu.
Your mileage may vary. Und dann einfach in der Pfanne heiß machen.
machen, ohne viel Brimborium, macht unten die Kruste wieder richtig schön kanackerig
und die Hitze treibt nach oben und dann kannst du das wieder voll genießen.
Also aufpassen, dass man es nicht verbrennt, aber im Prinzip ab in die Pfanne,
nicht irgendwie auf Backen oder Mikrowelle oder sowas ganz schlimm. Das macht alles kaputt.
Aber was brauchst erstmal alles richtig, aber was ist noch eine entscheidende Zutat für die Pfanne?
Einen kleinen Tropfen Wasser oder so drei, vier Tropfen Wasser ist richtig,
aber damit das überhaupt wird, genau, ansonsten ist dein Wasser nämlich nichts
wert. Ein Deckel muss drauf auf die Pfanne.
Ansonsten bringt dein Wasser raus.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie ich es, ja, ja, wahrscheinlich habe ich das so gemacht.
So, und das ist, als ich das mir irgendwann mal vorbei, ich glaube in meiner
Instagram Timeline irgendwie so durchgescrollt, da erfasst einen ja irgendwie
so ein Kram und irgendwie hörte sich das alles erstmal nicht so richtig plausibel an.
Ich dachte mir, naja gut, aber probieren kannst es mal.
Und es ist verstörend, wie gut das funktioniert. Also die Art der Pfanne ist,
würde ich sagen, ziemlich egal.
Ist egal, ob Gusseisen oder beschichtet Teflon oder Edelstahl, was auch immer.
Hat der da einen Eiswürfel reingetan?
Der hat da einen Eiswürfel, also ich habe jetzt gerade ein Video gepostet,
gibt es 150.000 von auf YouTube.
Nicht zu heiß, aber auch nicht zu kalt, also so, was weiß ich mal,
von 1 bis zwölf, die Stufen hat so eine Zehn, ist genau richtig.
Heiß werden lassen, die Pfanne auch heiß werden lassen und dann in die heiße
Pfanne das Pizzastück mit so einem Teelöffel Wasser und sofort Deckel drauf.
Und das führt eben, wie du schon richtig sagst, unten wird es kross,
richtig kross und durch dieses Wasser, den Wasserdampf, der dann eben durch
den Deckel in der Pfanne gehalten wird, kriegt sie halt genug Flüssigkeit,
dass oben auch der ganze Käse wieder topfit wird.
Das heißt also, wenn du dieses Stück Käse aus dieser Pfanne nimmst,
ist es wirklich exakt so als...
Das Stück Käse.
Von was für einer Pizza reden wir da? Das Stück Pizza aus der Pfanne nimmst.
Quattro Formaggi.
Ist es wirklich, als ob die aus dem Ofen kommt. Und denkst dir so,
warum wird einem das nicht viel früher beigebracht? 40 Jahre meines Lebens.
Also ich muss hier nochmal,
Werbung für Airfryer machen.
Unheimlich gute Geräte.
Ist im Prinzip genau das gleiche, nur dass du halt, du klappst halt das Ding
auf, legst das Stück rein, machst einen Pluck Wasser dazu, machst das Ding an
und dann nach Timer und bla und kommt das halt knackig raus.
Ja, wir schleichen seit Monaten um so einen Airfryer.
Airfryer sind ja technisch auch nichts anderes als Heißluftöfen.
Es gibt ja da eigentlich keinen Netzwerkunterschied außer dem Volumen.
Aber der Airfryer, der macht mehr Wind und er heizt tatsächlich nur durch Heißluft.
Was so ein Ofen ja im Prinzip, aber nicht wirklich macht.
Also Umluftofen ist mehr so, ich bewege die Luft mal ein bisschen,
aber ein Airfryer ist halt volle Lotte heiße Luft.
Und was hat das genau für eine Auswirkung?
Das ist doch alles nur heiße Luft.
Richtig, aber es ist halt mehr heiße Luft. Ja, es ist mehr Luft.
Also der Klassiker ist, du schneidest Kartoffeln in handliche Stücke,
machst Öl drauf, packst es in das Körbchen.
Du machst Öl auf, die Kartoffeln direkt drauf.
Ja, also ich mache das immer so, dass ich die klein schneide,
dann machst du sie in eine Schüssel.
salzen, Öl drauf, ordentlich durchwühlen und die Dinger so wie sie sind ins
Körbchen vom Air Fryer und dann hast du hinterher Pommes.
Weil das Ding halt die Dinger heiß macht, als würde man sie tatsächlich frittieren.
Schaltest du das Gerät selber ab?
Ja, also das, das ich habe, ja.
Weil du eine Zeit eingestellt hast oder weil er irgendwas misst?
Es gibt auch eine Möglichkeit, Der hat so einen komischen Modus mit so einem
Thermometer zum reinstecken, wo man dann irgendwelche Steaks auf dem Punkt noch grillen kann.
Aber das habe ich nie ausprobiert, weil ich das ein bisschen over the top fand.
Das Hauptproblem mit Airfryern ist, dass die allermeisten Geräte furchtbar hässlich
aussehen. Das ist auch das, was sie so mit Reiskochern verbindet.
Das stimmt. Und ich so ein Problem im Moment habe mit so einem hauptischen Geräten.
Sie brauchen halt Platz. Das ist bei mir im Moment der Punkt so.
Den Platz.
Den Use Case hätte ich aber den Platz, den muss man sich jetzt erkämpfen und
dafür müsste ich erst die Mikrowelle woanders hin verfrachten,
weil die Kriste haben mit eben dann doch nicht abgelöst, finde ich.
Aber die Mikrowelle kann man überall hinhängen.
Ja, das ist auch der Plan, aber die Wand ist so gasdicht, da brauche ich nämlich
deinen Bohrhammer, um ordentlich Dübel in diese Wand reinzukriegen.
Ich habe jetzt einen zweiten Bohrhammer.
Der Trend geht zum zweiten Bohrhammer.
Naja, ich war vorletztes Wochenende in München, weil ich hatte irgendwie Abi, Treffen, bla. Ähm,
War auch wieder sehr lustig.
Genug.
Abi 90, die kannst du selber ausrechnen.
Und meine Mutter hat die Gelegenheit benutzt, mir alle Dinge mitzugeben,
die sie nicht brauchte, die von ihrem Mann, ihrem inzwischen verstorbenen Mann noch stammen.
Und da war unter anderem noch eine weitere Bohrmaschine und ein Bohrhammer.
Weil ich mir aber in der Zwischenzeit selber einen gekauft habe,
habe ich jetzt zwei Bohrhämmer.
Und deswegen auch zwei Bohrmaschinen, aber die sind auch beide von dem ehemaligen Mann meiner Mutter.
Aber du hast nur einen Airfryer?
Ich habe nur einen Airfryer.
Und welchen Airfryer hast du denn? Ist das eine Marke oder ist das so ein Ninja?
Von Ninja, ja.
Ninja. Ist das eine etablierte Marke in diesem Was Airfryer anbelangt.
Ja. Die haben quasi einen Fanclub und die sind meiner Meinung nach auch recht gut.
Also ich kann jetzt nicht davon sprechen.
Oh, haben die viele Buttons.
Ja, die haben auch sehr viele Modelle.
Also ich kann nicht sagen, ob andere Firmen auch schöne Airfryer haben.
Die haben sie bestimmt. Ich habe halt...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie meiner heißt. Der hat nur einen Heizraum und den klappt man nach oben hin auf.
Gibt auch ein Ninja-Kombi 12 in 1, Multikocher, Ofen- und Heißluftfritteuse, 12 Kochfunktionen.
Ja, ja, ja. Also der kann relativ interessanterweise, was der auch kann,
ist, der hat eine Dryer-Funktion.
Also du kannst tatsächlich Dörr-Obst.
Dörren.
Eine Dörre-Funktion, genau. Das Lustige ist, dass man da die Zeit nur in Stunden einstellen kann.
Okay.
Aber jetzt kommt ja die eigentliche Frage. Pizza im Airfryer?
Ja.
Is a thing oder was?
Also ich habe es einfach gemacht, weil...
Das ist aber ein ganz anderer Ansatz.
Aber wie lange dauert das dann? Also unsere Pfannentechnik dauert ungefähr eine
Minute. Dann ist die top.
Naja, eine Minute. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, wie lange ich das gemacht habe.
Und je nach Größe der runden Pfanne kriegst du auch stattlich eine Anzahl an Pizzastücken rein.
Ja, das ist der einzige Punkt, dass der Airfryer, der ist zwar nicht klein,
aber er ist auch nicht riesig.
Ich habe deswegen die Stücke relativ schmal geschnitten und so gegenläufig reingelegt und so weiter.
Aber es hat für ein schnelles Pizza-Frühstück gereicht. Also, weil, ja.
Aber der Griff, ich erinnere mich jetzt gerade, ich glaube, ich habe das nämlich
gerade irgendwo im Hals gesehen.
Kann es sein, dass dieser Griff, der so nach Metall aussieht, kein Metall ist?
Das kann durchaus sein.
Den kann man nicht in die Geschirrspüle stellen, weil dann geht nämlich das Chrom ab vom Plastik.
Also der, den ich habe, da kann man das Gerät selber natürlich nicht in die
Spülmaschine tun, Aber alle Teile, die irgendwie mit Essen in Berührung kommen,
die kann man da ausbauen und in die Spülmaschine tun. Das ist alles irgendwie kein Problem.
Und weil wir vorhin beim Essen drüber sprachen, von dieser Firma Ninja habe
ich jetzt auch die Slush-Maschine gekauft.
die hat große Welle gemacht irgendwie unter den Foodbloggern und ist so ein
bisschen Singled Purpose Device, aber das was sie macht,
macht sie schon sehr geil also ich bin,
ich bin nach wie vor sehr zufrieden damit man hat in relativ kurzer Zeit ein
sehr sehr kaltes Getränk also Slush ist ja kein Getränk, aber du weißt was ich meine.
Wow, ist ja sportlich im Preis.
Ja, schon ein bisschen luxuriöser, das gebe ich zu, aber hat sich gelohnt bis jetzt.
Banköhrturm zu ihren Gunsten, wa?
Naja, also sagen wir mal so, andere Slush-Maschinen sind nicht wirklich wesentlich
billiger, geschweige denn besser.
Ja, okay, da ist ja so eine komplette Kühlgeschichte mit drin und so weiter.
Da ist ein richtiger Kompressor drin und der ist auch relativ stark der funktioniert
relativ gut trotzdem würde ich immer empfehlen das Zeug vorher ordentlich vorzukühlen
weil sonst dauert es wirklich lang wenn.
Ich sowas zu Hause stehen hätte, wüsste ich nicht womit ich meine Jungs sonst
noch ernähren könnte so das wäre,
gerade diese Slushie Maschinen hier weil so egal wo wir sind in welchem Urlaub,
sobald eines dieser Viecher irgendwie erspäht wird geht der Terror los das Zuhause,
das wäre der totale Worst Case.
Es sei denn, sie gewöhnen sich dann so sehr dran.
Dass es wieder langweilig ist. Ja, die Hoffnung besteht.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich die ganze Zeit Pommes essen möchte.
Man kann im Prinzip alles damit warm machen, backen. Ich backe auch Brötchen
auf und so ein Kram. Das passt irgendwie ja schon.
Gut, Leute, ich würde sagen, wir packen mal langsam ein. Packen wir es ein.
Nächste Sendung ist wahrscheinlich nach der WWDC.
Wir haben uns jetzt hier nicht groß im Glaskooling bemüht.
Also keine Vorhersagen, die sich überprüfen lassen.
AI, AI, AI.
AI, AI, AI. haben wir denn Wünsche?
Ich würde mir was, was ist, also vielleicht nochmal das kleine Segment.
Unabhängig davon, ob wir erwarten oder der Meinung sind, dass es schon Gerüchte
gegeben hätte, die in diese Richtung gehen.
Einfach wünsch dir was. Was wäre das Gerät, was Apple,
und gehen wir mal davon weg, dass es ja eigentlich eine WWDC ist und es geht nicht um,
Produkte im eigentlichen Sinn, aber manchmal kommen ja auch noch Geräte raus
und so rein theoretisch wäre ja auch wieder so MacBook-Zeit und so weiter vom
Zyklus, also man darf ja noch träumen,
und wenn man das dann tut, was ist eigentlich so das Gerät, was fehlt im Line-Up,
wo das jetzt so einen unmittelbaren Kaufreiz auslösen würde?
Also was wäre sozusagen das Produkt, mit dem Apple rauskommen müsste,
wo dann doch der Griff in die Wallet einfach so passiert, weil es nicht anders geht?
Also ich würde für mich sagen, wenn sie eine VR-Brille bringen,
wo der Preis tatsächlich nur dreistellig ist.
Dreistellig?
Ich würde sogar ein bisschen hoch gehen. Also eine Vision nicht pro für 1999,
aber nicht Dollar, sondern Euro, wo sie an allem sparen, außer am Display.
Also die Auflösung darf und die Brillanz des Displays darf nicht schlechter sein.
Alles andere können sie Plastik, sonst was machen. und die vorne drauf,
da können sie sofort wegwerfen, hier diese Augensimulation und sowas brauche ich alles nicht.
Aber eine Brille für 1,999 mit aber der Displayqualität, vielleicht noch eine
schnellere CPU drin, dass da noch ein bisschen mehr geht.
Da würde ich dann glaube ich sehr schnell schwach werden.
Also ich würde auf jeden Fall weiter runter gehen mit dem Preis,
weil für 2000 Euro löst das noch keinen Kaufreiz bei mir aus.
Bei unter 1000, da, da könnte man nochmal reden.
Ansonsten Devices,
weiß nicht.
Also ich kaufe ja immer jedes Apple TV, wenn es neu rauskommt.
Habt aber bei dem 4K jetzt auch noch nicht echt Schmerzen, dass ich denke,
da müsste irgendwas jetzt groß anders.
Ich hab noch das allererste, wo TVOS draufläuft. Das kann noch kein 4K.
aber ich benutze es im Prinzip auch nicht so richtig viel also keine Ahnung so ja.
So ein HomePod, der irgendwie preislich ein bisschen attraktiver ist und deutlich
besser klingt als die Minis, fände ich irgendwie charmant.
Ich hätte gerne in der Küche eigentlich was geil Klingendes gerne,
aber das letzte Update von dem HomePod ist ja irgendwie, wurde es überhaupt jemals geupdatet?
Nee, es wurde noch gar nicht, der große wurde noch nicht geupdatet, oder?
Doch, der wurde einmal geupdatet und dann aus dem Programm genommen.
Nein, nein, der ist.
Ist der noch im Programm? Arm?
Ja, du kannst den großen...
So, und der ist mir irgendwie 100 Euro zu teuer für das, was er irgendwie macht.
Den hätte ich in 100 Euro günstiger so irgendwas in der Liga.
Fände ich ganz spannend.
Ja, also 350 Euro für einen ist halt irgendwie auch eine Menge Holz,
wenn man eigentlich Stereo-Sound mag.
Das Hauptproblem ist halt mit
diesem ganzen Siri-Mumpitz, es funktioniert halt alles nur so begrenzt.
Also da müsste sich in der Tat richtig was ändern. Okay.
Ja, Hardware finde ich jetzt schwierig, weil momentan,
also außer bei jetzt der Vision, ich jetzt nichts sehe, wo Apple irgendwo an
der Stelle ist, wo man so sagen würde, also wenn sie das Gerät nochmal richtig
neu denken, dann hebt es das auf ein neues Level.
Vielleicht habe ich auch nicht die Fantasie dafür, aber ich meine iPhone ist auserzählt.
Was wird da kommen? Eine bessere Kamera, mehr Sensoren, dann war es das.
iPad ist auch auserzählt, das wird nur noch dünner und leichter.
Bei den Macs, ja, keine Ahnung, das ist jetzt auch kein Ding,
wo jetzt große Neuigkeiten, also ich meine,
die Sache mit dem, wir bauen da mal einen Funkchip ein, dass man von überall
Daten hat, das hätten sie schon vor 20 Jahren tun können, wenn sie es hätten gewollt.
Aber das wäre bei mir genau der Durchbruch.
Ja, natürlich wäre es ein Durchbruch.
Ich habe eigentlich, also ich meine, Ich bin ja ein MacBook Air-Mensch,
seit es MacBook Air gibt, habe ich mir keinen Pro-Laptop mehr gekauft.
Keinen einzigen. Weil ich halt einfach, weiß ich nicht, für mich war das Leichte
bei dem Laptop immer das Feature schlechthin und das hat irgendwie alles überstrahlt.
Und ich würde mir heute ein MacBook Pro bestenfalls kaufen wegen der Performance,
aber nicht wegen des Notch.
Also der Notch Richtig.
Du bist ja so notchempfindlich.
Das geht gar nicht. Aber würden Sie sagen, jetzt gibt es ein MacBook Pro mit
so einem scheiß Notch und da ist ein LTE-Chip drin, oder ein 5G-Chip natürlich
im Idealfall, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich schwach werden.
Und wenn Sie keinen Notch haben, dann ist es Shut up and take my money. Dann ist alles vorbei.
Also ansonsten, wie gesagt, hardwaremäßig schwierig.
Also die Uhr ist, ich will nicht sagen, die ist auserzählt, Da gibt es bestimmt
noch den einen oder anderen Sensor, den sie da einbauen können.
Ansonsten ist da jetzt, also ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass da jetzt irgendwas in der Pipeline ist.
Auch bei anderen Geräten, wo ich sagen würde, hey, das muss Apple mal bringen, dann ist geil.
Also vielleicht mal irgendwie ein Mac Pro, der irgendwie sinnvoll ist.
also momentan gibt es halt dieses Ding was im Prinzip auch nur ein Mac Studio
ist mit ein paar Slots in einem riesigen Gehäuse, was zu teuer ist,
ich weiß es nicht, ein iMac hier schreibt jemand iMac, iMac den man als externen
Monitor benutzen kann wenn sie
das wieder bringen dann wäre ich dabei vielleicht, mal sehen, keine Ahnung,
aber so ein iMac der halt irgendwie nicht lange hält, weil dann irgendwann gibt
es das macOS dafür nicht mehr und dann hast du ein wahrscheinlich wunderbares
Display, das du nicht benutzen kannst, weil die Hardware da drin irgendwie nichts mehr kann.
Nee, also gut, klar, man kann ja irgendwelche alten iMacs umbauen,
dass sie dann ein externes Display sind oder so, aber solche Sachen, zu Kleinigkeiten,
Ansonsten als Software-seitig, was ich halt gerne hätte, wäre Multi-User für iPad.
Ich meine Da treu mich schon lange von Und ganz ehrlich.
Der Vision würde es auch gut zu,
ins Gesicht stehen Multi-User zu haben jetzt mal abgesehen von aber ich meine
man kann ja diese ganzen Teile kann man ja irgendwie zweimal kaufen und linsen
und hast du nicht gesehen und kannst dann tatsächlich die Vision auch mit mehreren
Leuten auch angepasst verwenden Also da spräche ja nichts dagegen.
Aber da sträubt sich Apple ganz besonders. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber gut.
Verstehe ich auch nicht. Das ist eigentlich Unsinn.
Gut, für iPhone wäre es ein bisschen sinnlos.
Nee, für das iPhone muss es nicht sein. Aber iPad und Vision Pro,
das sind schon so Dinge, die man weiterreicht und die auch, sagen wir mal,
einen ganz anderen Wert hätten, wenn du weißt, das eine Teil kann von der ganzen
Familie jederzeit benutzt werden.
Ja okay, du musst halt vielleicht deine Einsetzlinsen wechseln,
aber die sind ja eh identifiziert und du kannst problemlos an deiner Iris erkannt werden.
Du setzt das Ding auf, weißt ja sofort, welche Person das ist,
ist automatisch eingeloggt, fertig, aus.
Wenn da nicht die richtigen Einsätze sind, dann warnt er halt kurz und sagt,
bist du sicher, dass du das jetzt so benutzen willst? Ja, zack, fertig. Fertig.
Vor allen Dingen so Multi-User wäre auch eine gute Einstiegsdroge,
um mehr von den Teilen zu verkaufen. Bin ich völlig von der Überzeugung.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Also weil du dann hätte Apple die Möglichkeit, du hast das Familien-iPad und
dann krähen die Kleinen, dass sie ein eigenes wollen und dann, keine Ahnung.
Dann wollen die Eheleute das auch je eins haben und sich keins teilen müssen.
Es wird ja einigermaßen schon seit längerer Zeit gemunkelt, dass neue AirTags rauskommen.
Da warte ich jetzt auch in der Tat mit meinem nächsten Kauf,
um zu gucken, ob da jetzt was kommt.
Da bräuchte ich nämlich immer wieder so einen Schwung, so eins fürs Auto,
wenn ich doch wieder verpinnere, wo habe ich es eigentlich geparkt?
Was mich inzwischen an den AirTags...
Alle andere Fahrräder, ihr kennt die Geschichten.
Mit größerer Reichweite.
Was mich inzwischen an den AirTags nervt, ist, wie schnell sie eigentlich die Batterien fressen.
Also diese Batterielaufzeit von einem Jahr ist einfach nicht so gut.
Vielleicht habe ich auch schlechte Batterien gekauft.
Das kann durchaus sein. Aber so AirTags, die man vielleicht auch mal aufladen
kann oder so, das wäre eigentlich nicht verkehrt.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Ich sage ja nur, das wäre nicht verkehrt. Wir waren bei Wünsch dir was.
Ja, aber das macht das Ding ja viel zu groß und viel zu komplex dann.
Also ich glaube, das werden wir nicht sehen.
Auch vielleicht AirTags in anderen Formen. Also wenn Apple, ich habe ja so eine
AirTag-Karte für das Portemonnaie und die funktioniert so schlecht.
Ja, meine auch.
Wenn Apple da tatsächlich eine eigene gut funktionierende Lösung bringen würde,
das wäre auch mal nicht verkehrt.
Flacher würde schon reichen.
Flacher wäre schon gar nicht verkehrt.
Ein Apple-Portemonnaie, da könnte man das doch alles drin integrieren.
Oder dann irgendwie das iPhone so rein schnappt und ein AirTag gleich drin verbaut ist.
Da muss ich jetzt mal ranten. Apple hat sich irgendwann auf die Fahnen geschrieben,
nur noch vegane Dinge zu verkaufen und du kriegst keine Lederarmbänder mehr
bei Apple für die Watch und wenn die ein Portemonnaie machen,
dann ist das garantiert auch, weiß ich nicht,
was für ein Gewebe, dass sie dann einen tollen Namen geben, aber im Prinzip
ist es dann alles nur Plastik. Sorry, das will ich dann nicht.
Also gut, Leder hält jetzt auch nicht ewig, aber gut, das Gewebe hält auch nicht ewig.
Nichts hält ewig.
Nichts hält ewig, aber trotzdem, nee.
Nicht mal diese Sendung hält ewig.
Ja.
Jetzt machen wir Schluss, Leute.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank für eure Kommentare, vielen Dank für eure
Vorschläge, die ihr machen werdet für unsere Tierlist-Shootouts.
Gebt euch Mühe.
Was haben wir noch für Wünsche oder Tipps oder Anforderungen?
Ihr könnt euch auch gerne zur Sendung 300 äußern, was euch da vielleicht vorschwebt.
Wir haben uns ehrlich gesagt noch keine Gedanken darüber gemacht,
aber wir werden diesen Sommer in irgendeiner Form nutzen, denke ich mal.
Sehr viel mehr gibt es eigentlich nicht zu erzählen, oder?
Skepsis.
Ja gut, ihr könnt auch noch Fragen einreichen, wie wir Dinge finden,
die da bei Apple, bei der WWDC vorgestellt werden, aber ich denke,
wir müssen sowieso drüber reden.
Genau, ihr könnt generell auch Fragen stellen, falls ihr möchtet,
dass wir uns mal mit unserem außerordentlichen wissen.
Eine gute Frage kommt gerade noch über den Slack rein. Wo sollen die Tierlists
denn hingemeldet werden?
In die Kommentare.
In die Kommentare. Na gut.
Ja, einfach in die Kommentare. in die Sendung rein. Das werden wir dann schon machen.
Wir lesen die Kommentare. Tierlist-Vorschläge, Fragen. Wir lesen alle Kommentare.
Auch die ein bisschen rantigeren lesen wir auch.
Beschimpfungen aller Art.
Beschimpfungen aller Art. Wir nehmen alles zur Kenntnis und manchmal haben wir
es ja auch verdient. Manchmal.
Das stimmt.
Aber nicht immer. So. Und jetzt machen wir es zu den Laden. Vielen Dank.
Das war's. Freakshow 292.
Der Countdown läuft.
Mir wäre es gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn die Sendung mal kürzer wäre, ne, Ralf?
Das sagen wir immer. Das hat noch nie funktioniert.
Alright, das war's. Tschüss.
Bis dann.